[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
they're an output from over there we go
I see levels let me know let me just
make sure y'all
trying to sabotage
our I see levels there
shall be dead
Nick I'm a soldier do you and a soldier
yeah what's going on wrong call y'all
know what it is I'm a soldier that's the
thing today
what's going on roll call chris713 Pop
now what's going on Bots went to Soldier
let me know all my levels are sounding
anger man I see you Zach Riley Kevin
Baldwin
995 gaming nine five I like that ashes
the ashes Michael Bayless got him for
Sofa King no doubt hustle to motivate oh
he said oh man it's on if you put that
in his George Foreman oh we got the
heavyweight champion of the world George
Foreman hold the line no doubt normal
people Dover 360 salute Mason games
what's going on that's the ashes oh man
Paris Lily up in the chat early because
he's like somebody kid comes out you
know wearing an emerald crowd rolling
something
I don't know what you you gonna do he
wouldn't tell me he wouldn't tell us he
would not tell but he'd never tell us
anyway but he was really extra secretive
usually he would be a little cryptic and
still give me he would even give me a
hand yeah he was like you're gonna find
out during the show find out during the
show so we don't know what's about to go
down Stu Jersey what's going on salute
salute yeah what's going on assault
wagon what's going on you know that
Lydia Master censorship too was going on
that too what's going on Chris Jones
loyal to gamer.net see you Nick what's
going on
Nintendo Donna talking what's going on
hit the like button we're going we
trying to blast off we're trying to do
it all today
was going on Frank F what's up dead
proof what's up yo y'all in here y'all
are in here audio is clear thank you
hustle appreciate y'all appreciate y'all
it's gonna be crazy today Seth Lord
what's going on you guys did you see
that picture that they had with uh you
King Ryan doc doc G with his soldiers I
see you in there yo okay
everybody go like this tweet
don't like it right now I want everyone
to go like that too
it's it's cool it's legitly what
happened corporate Cog and King got him
over there
though the soldiers Island soldiers in
the building look we know it's about to
go down
um y'all know I know what the initiative
is I know what y'all want me to do you
know we got some things planned we're
going to do it right and uh we got some
breaking news breaking news man right on
the Lord's day so it never happens I
think this is the first time we've got
breaking news on a Sunday like this yeah
it's it's crazy it's crazy right now
yeah shout out to oh Mike Myers going on
staying up past bedtime for this yeah
it's crazy so look I gotta go because
um yeah um you know who's coming we
can't we can't get them monetized you're
probably gonna come with a theme song
but we had to get it going so anyway see
y'all in a bit
it's a beautiful day it's a beautiful
day we'll talk about it
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
don't stop
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I ain't
heard the boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turn me to an
animal and headers be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns uses the
target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but a man time
social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back weed with
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social lower
my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless of people don't aim check my
vocals follow on Twitter but I'm
anti-social but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers they don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
with regardless and people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold ya I ain't
heard the boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell because it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm
[Music]
three
times
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to an even though I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really be Stevo you like
to collect stuff and that's cool but I
got bad news even if you really was that
joke you never still be the king of the
statue sister juvenile I've been cursed
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord okay
[Music]
and then I write my check mic check we
are switching over
um so let's start with you sir let's get
a quick uh mic check huh you'll see how
you sounding hola hola hola hola Lord
addict the man of Dimensions can I get a
mic check sir
what's up uh shout out to over a
thousand people in the chat already
I wonder why
there's nothing nothing happening
we have a legendary uh appearance in the
real realm a good might check from uh
legendary Destiny how are we doing sir
bam hey everybody how's it going
let's go let's go and uh everyone's
favorite for today can I get a mic check
from The Kinks oh it feels so good I
don't feel bad King I won't interrupt
you today oh is this velvet
it feels so good
we have arriving
[Music]
it's gonna be a show it's gonna be a
show here you hear you and we are live
and welcome to the island launch podcast
LLC and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 313 and it's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the round
table on the Lord's date and today we've
got Xbox defeating the ftc's request to
block the ABK deal
FTC they're losing their appeal bid bang
bang
Microsoft now free to acquire
acquisition
you were the sound effects
Bill Spencer announcing deals on the law
day with PlayStation you know what I
actually want to put on one of my little
voice things uh the the Pokemon narrator
say that's super effects
rumors on Halo speed feature Ratchet and
Clank apart rest the parts PC specs to
discuss so we gonna get right into it so
um actually we have a special bonus
guess the legendary Destin legary of the
Destin YouTube channel podcast unlocks
on how are we doing sir good to see you
good I made the joke off air but I said
this shirt's mandatory
the light is Big held it is great to see
you awesome to see the support thanks
thanks for having me it took too long
for me to get on the show long overdue
brother good to have you man have you
all have you been playing anything with
all the videos you've been doing through
this and crazy have you had to play
anything I've been playing Diablo mostly
Diablo 4. so you know just playing
another Xbox game
my current favorite Xbox title
the difficult game conqueror Lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man Lord attic back to back with two
profiles of himself look like going on
in his character why you have to ruin
everything it's confusing me
scaring me scaring me so I I I guess uh
you know we we will go ahead you know a
change of order can't you know we had to
have the Diablo shirt the Diablo poster
I got that from Gamestop
I walked in there was like yo I need a
prop I can't tell you what it's for but
I'm gonna need that that right there on
the wall no not that one that one right
there hey attic is that coming to Game
Pass it's
man I'm surprised there's like game pass
on here you know maybe let me give him a
pen I'll put on only on cake a little
doubt that's pretty soon because we got
to get through these intross
that's it no questions and of course our
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gaming list for the single player
selfish experience and also the
sastradamus the Lord of clarity and Lord
Patriot of the iron bank PC Master races
oh Lord Sovereign how we doing sir I'm
doing good thank you for holding me down
last week while I was ankle Deep in
water I appreciate that yeah
I appreciate it today listen it was I
woke up there was a lot of it was
pouring rain there was Zero visibility
of fog out here I was like oh no so I
haven't gotten a call yet so I'm good
um yeah been playing Resident Evil 4 on
the on the Rog um I hate Ashley I hate
Ashley
she just she just ruins it for me but
other than that loving the game still
no doubt No Doubt end of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
access gamer
the prophet and Morpheus of Xbox Swami
King of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the unequivocal leader of the whole the
line movement
be loved Lord King how are you doing
huh I'm doing better than every dude
that reps that blue oh my God hey in
memory of you I got an aqua blue cup for
you
what are those the ashes the Earth the
title of the show should have been tears
of the Kingdom
you know what that is that's back to
back Birds
yo I mean I'm telling you I'm copping
I'm doing stuff I'm making a video today
and then
Phil Dominus Maximus are really
expensive first of his name best in his
class
AKA The Closer
sent out a tweet the day that just took
me to Goku blue to Goku black to insane
Goku levels oh man it is this right now
today is like a dream like I'm waiting
to be pinched
it's been a wonderful week and I can't
wait to hear what Dusty has to say hey
oh cause he held the hell out of that
line King where were we a month ago Phil
should go where it's all banks
them frauds they still trying to get
back in hold the gate yeah
because it's it's like it's like that uh
scene off the Lord of the Rings where
they have they're holding the the door
and then you you have the what's his
name through uh through the door over
into the wall as I hold the line
don't let it bust in that door oh man
beautiful we don't got destined long so
yeah let's let's get this but listen I
want to tell everybody stick around to
the end of the show we have a ton of
people we almost got 2 000 people
watching I want you to hit that like I
want you to hit that subscribe and I
want you to share it out because I'm
gonna tell you right now you do not want
to miss stay to the end yes
you do not want to miss the stuff that's
going to happen because I said if we get
2 000 people watching there's going to
be a new persona that is going to be
unveiled so we just need 300 more and
that person is going to be Nifty
soda I've been playing Persona that's a
funny little question and of course we
have the gaming ninja himself the beefy
Shinobi Lord cognito's friend never
really listening oh we actually he's
rolling with it
this I heard I heard something else over
the you know the twitchers over the
weekend I I say we start calling him
Lord cognito
[Laughter]
had a great discussion with him in
reference to what's been going on prior
to all the news today check that out uh
hog law is back like he never left us
shout out to the last word by co-host is
a Baptist tie guy Travis absolutely I'm
sorry I couldn't make it I was actually
in uh New York the games critical Circle
salute to Jordan minor this is an
excellent book y'all video game of the
year go check it out from 1977 every
game of the year listed pictures it's
fantastic go check them out I think it's
Jordan uh at Jordan W minor on Twitter
excellent gentlemen go check that out
and uh yeah as far as gaming Diablo 4
again uh doing my Paragon and now my end
game Run so I've been doing that EXO
Primal is out shout out to about to
Buddha shout out to sin we were rocking
that for a little bit having some fun
and all flame for my lord gave me that
then of course and uh Destiny's exotic
quest uh Wicked Implement is out so look
I'm Gonna Keep a short brief we got uh
destined real quick uh I just want to I
completely forgot it's so used to you
know me and uh smooth on planet Xbox we
actually interviewed Colin Moriarty and
uh the majority of what we're talking
about today was uh was was the was the
questions that we asked you know just
get got his overall temperature on you
know how he thinks the ABK thing that's
over on the weapon wheel patreon and I
think it will go free like Monday or
Tuesday
no doubt now us off it's gonna be a
crazy day so you want to get the uh
super chats now I would say just no no
just give destination yeah you're right
I'm sorry I'm sorry because of
Engagement there's a lot there's a lot
we'll get to some of them before Dustin
leaves but we do uh the Destin stuff and
then you know okay then wow stuff is
fair yeah
we'll get those now and just I signed on
to do a sound check and they're like all
right we're going live
we ain't playing with you sorry bro
and patreon questions we got you we will
Implement a lot of them that are
pertinent to the topics on the show
we'll get that going I'll just do the
poll then and then jump into the topics
if that's what you saw uh last week's
probably in and the people have spoken
if XBox wins the case against the well
then this is dated against the FTC to
stop the preliminary injunction for the
APK deal how do you think PlayStation
should respond the winner of the
four-way IOP poll at 42 percent of the
vote was continue making quality first
party games and improved PlayStation
Plus group coming in at second at a
fairly close 22 percent of the vote was
developed their own multiplayer live
service game to compete with Call of
Duty and raise a close third place at 18
was continue to make strategic
third-party deals exclusive to
PlayStation consoles and in last place
16 with the messy Lords I don't care
we're gonna double up with the CMA to
block this damn deal so salute to
everybody that rocked out soft quickly
thoughts on the um yeah someone else
because I was just copy pasting no you
good you're good you're good
as far as up the people want uh Sony if
the deal was to go through what you see
where we at now to make uh quality first
party games and um uh improve
PlayStation Plus thoughts I think at
this point it's it's it's battle the
bias I I think I think when technically
it's PlayStation's fault you know it is
King because you know they they bought
stock they try to get star foes and
exclusive and it started all this mess
so if you want to blame someone blame
PlayStation but the moment Microsoft
bought Bethesda it just started a chain
reaction and I I find it like really
hard to believe that PlayStation is
right now looking for some kind of you
know not not necessarily a response but
just to show Force it's like look we
could buy stuff
and I just gotta say I told you before
the day it was going to be the own their
own instrument to their demise and they
did it theirself I love this this is
beautiful you did it to yourself it
doesn't look like you're gonna say
something uh 2 000 views
oh shout out to Khalifa the building
shot the parents of the building salute
oh I'm sorry that's when you're about to
say something
well I don't think Sony needs to change
too much of their strategy to be honest
it will work for the next few years but
the problem is they're trying to set up
stuff to evolve how they monetize their
consumers for lack of a better term
they're expanding the PC that window is
getting smaller and smaller right they
revamp PlayStation now and it's part of
PlayStation Plus
there's a lot of interesting things
going on there like they're they're
building up their mobile Division and
xBox wasn't joking around when they said
mobile is where the industry is going so
PlayStation has been setting the
groundwork for that but they're playing
catch-up Xbox has been implementing the
strategy for years with Game Pass and
the subscription services and now
PlayStation is realizing we got to
compete in new interesting ways the
console Market is a flat Market there's
not room for expansion there the
internal emails that Microsoft confirm
that so Microsoft evolved their content
strategy PlayStation remained the same
for too long so yes keep making amazing
first party games I agree with that I I
love a lot of the games that PlayStation
is putting out I've never fall to the
developers my main criticisms of Sony
are corporate strategy being the first
the 70 being the first to increase your
console prices you know and Xbox did
follow suit in those two areas which is
just an unfortunate part of inflation
again guess but um I don't think they
changed too much I think they already
have the groundwork laid and I don't
mean to cannibalize too much of the
panel's time no no you're good you're
good you're good we're gonna get one
person 26 hours today bro
no this is great we just let you get
your bars off and yeah this is great
this is great actually fantastic poison
I definitely hear what you're saying and
as far as you know Microsoft try to
transform their own strategy and be a
first to this you know new way of doing
things so look we're gonna get into the
first he was a visionary
what are you going to do with ABK done
four letters Sega
yeah well we have that whole list of
Acquisitions that Microsoft was eyeing
up right one of them was Zynga that fell
through but the the big ones are like uh
Sega
what's the company you made Hades again
and blanking on their names oh what is
this
yeah so that's on the list there's a lot
of really interesting Acquisitions on
that list that could still be in talks
one of them was Square Enix and we
Square Enix has been consolidating and
doing a lot of interesting stuff a lot
of people have complained about the
consolidation of the industry and I was
responding to somebody last night I'm
like talk about it look Sony's acquiring
companies
um embracer group is acquiring companies
and Microsoft is acquiring companies
they're all acquiring companies right
now Microsoft got put in a place where
they were about to lose Cod they were
about to lose Starfield they already
lost two major releases for the from
Bethesda softworks so they're like okay
I see I see what we have to do to become
successful and remain on the map they
started buying and everybody's going to
continue buying like this isn't going to
stop the consolidation is going to
continue whether you like it or not
that's where we're going and I do think
that eventually we're going to come full
circle like in a decade all these
smaller companies that are starting up
now they're going to become bigger and
potentially we'll see another Activision
in 10 years yeah interesting that's just
how it goes it's just like the circle of
life yeah it's technical yeah yeah but
what is what is funny is
everybody's going shopping and they're
getting mad at Microsoft because
Microsoft is shopping shopping
these guys are going out to get snacks
for the party Microsoft you know feeding
the college right we need 25 pies
um yeah shopping I don't like how he
shops Sony's buying the Ford Taurus the
Microsoft is buying the Maserati
Microsoft playing the Maserati
it's a messy day today all right see
what's going on
look let's get into it right now so look
we added something planned as far as
topic wise but then we got breaking news
breaking news shout out to Sunday on the
lowest day shout out to Time Warner Time
Warner The Verge Sony agrees to a Call
of Duty deal with Microsoft the Battle
of Call of Duty on Playstation is over
as so many signs the Microsoft deal so
it looks like they've agreed to keep the
franchise on Playstation after the uh
acquisition CEO spell Phil Spencer
Microsoft gaming has said that they've
agreed to a binding agreement to keep
calling duty on PlayStation and AFL put
the Tweet out we are pleased to announce
that Microsoft and Playstation have
signed a binding agreement to keep Call
of Duty on Playstation following the
acquisition of Activision Blizzard we
look forward to a future where players
globally have more choice to play their
favorite game so this pretty much ends
that bitter battle between the companies
that have wage Wars more privately and
publicly over the past year regarding
the acquisition of the ABK deal in 2022
uh Brad Smith Then followed up from day
one of this acquisition we've been
committed to addressing the concerns of
regulators platform and game developers
and consumers even after we cross the
finish line for this Deal's approval we
remain focused on ensuring that Call of
Duty remains on looks like he has more
to the tweets and looks like a sub tweet
excuse me
um than ever before for more consumers
than ever before so yeah this was him
quote tweeting Phil's statement and uh
yeah similar to looks like a similar
10-year agreement between Microsoft
often Nintendo as well as well as the
other various deals by yourself have
struck for cloud companies and all the
Rival services so yeah
we got to talk about it let's talk about
our esteemed guest the news broke today
destined Lord Destin how are you feeling
about this situation as it unfolds real
time on a Sunday
yeah so you're talking about Sony
signing the contract right with
Microsoft finally we don't know the
duration of the contract but it's now
been publicly stated by Phil and you
kind of went over that already but uh it
feels good it feels like Jim Ryan should
assign that and say this all a lot of
money in terms of uh taxpayer dollars
and time in terms of this whole trial
and everything but uh here we are
finally at the end I don't like what are
people gonna come at them with now like
what does the CMA have cloud gaming
that's still the area where they're held
up I'm really curious what's going to
happen next week Monday and Tuesday are
they going to close are they going to
wait until August and renegotiate the
contract between Microsoft and
Activision those are the questions that
remain largely they could close over the
CMA and deal with the CMA messiness or
uh they could wait and renegotiate the
contract those are their options right
uh it's done the deal is done it's going
to close like what's the FTC gonna do go
to trial again in August
my problem with FDC isn't that they
litigated Microsoft it's that they
litigated Microsoft and their case was
garbage they made up terms they didn't
have a clear strategy for What Microsoft
was actually infringing upon
and they're just wasting time and money
for you know taxpayers for uh consumers
that actually want the deal to go
through if I think the gamer's lawsuit
personally had some better points about
the overall industry effects of the deal
right but the FTC failed to even mention
that and I I went through and um looked
at how many times they had actually said
consumer versus
uh well yeah here here's my tweet they
said Sony or Playstation 76 times during
closing and 27 times they said consumers
but it's worse than that it was only 27
times because the judge repeatedly had
to remind them well how does that affect
consumers we're talking about consumers
here not PlayStation at that point when
they had to take a break
unprompted they said it even less than
that they repeatedly went to Sony and
Playstation versus the industry how this
is going to affect developers how so
where can developers work afterwards and
The Gamers lawsuit at least called out
that aspect of it yeah so I I'm pretty
upset that instead of actually
litigating in a way that painted a
picture about how this could be
detrimental to the industry with data
and proof to back it up like their
lawyer Dr Lee it was just nonsensical
yeah a lot of a lot of the stuff he had
and the judge was like so it wasn't even
20 that he's hypothesizing it's like 5.9
percent she's like what are you talking
about then
so yeah so uh I'm feeling good
uh I'm frustrated at how the CIA the FTC
approached the case say what you will
about the CMA but I I felt like they did
a little bit better investigating as to
the negative impacts on the industry
they got their math wrong and they grow
on that and they made the correction and
it sounds like they might have got their
math wrong on the cloud gaming front
we'll see what happens right I'm there's
other stuff I'm not happy about with the
CMA but I'll let you guys go from there
no I I hear you I do see uh Randall Thor
in the building
um Ram good to see Just One Direction
how's it going yeah real quick what's
going on brother where's King oh he's
hot we'll set him up but uh real quickly
because we we did get breaking news and
let me set you up there I got you I got
you you know but um ran like again just
the breaking news today on Wednesday
Phil Spencer Brad Smith the Tweet goes
out PlayStation signs the deal the the
knees appear to be bent your thoughts on
this quick well first I gotta apologize
to attic oh you know because
we ended up epic Xbox 2 on Friday you
were there you were there and then you
left and came back yeah yeah and I did
promise attic he could come on the next
time we had something like that and I
failed I'm sorry addict although you
could have came and chat and said you
wanted in because everybody literally
came in once the you know the
announcement was made so your apology
not accepted
don't worry whenever this deal goes
through I'm sure we'll probably have
another one of those uh where you where
you can joined
the only one who predicted the ABK stuff
gotta hand him his flowers on this one
well wait on this show sure
hold on Dustin
receipts out bro all right let's be
clear what what we're talking about you
predicted your deal as soon okay as soon
as all the bad stuff started coming out
about uh about ABK and Bobby kotec so we
had a uh we had a topic one day saying
like hey that was over a year ago that
was that was a long time ago before
anybody acquired anybody right so yeah
anybody acquired this is long long time
ago so we had to talk about hey uh you
know what would be a good fit for
Microsoft different and I was the only
one that said ABK I said hey
they are hemorrhaging Goodwill
it's a perfect time to strike and
everyone is No don't touch that with a
10-foot pole no way and that's right
it was like almost two years ago yeah
yeah he called it as they should be the
partner you know partnership that
Microsoft should go out to but ran I
want to finish your bars thank you red I
appreciate that I remember
it's hilarious because Jim Ryan
you know lying crying flying
hiding Jim dance move Saving Private
Ryan
um he was out there the whole time
speaking from his chest beating beating
his chest like we don't want this merger
we just want to block it right they felt
so confident everybody felt so confident
after the CMA block like it was all over
Cog you remember I remember it's a bed
yeah oh yeah you know people were saying
I'm podcasting on Twitter that if you
think this deal is going through you're
part of a cult you know what I mean and
it was kind of like well we never know
what's gonna happen
uh and then eventually kind of all
played out like some of us expected the
FTC lost and please don't be too hard on
Jazz Corden
he he did this he sacrificed
his taste buds he sacrificed the stomach
and he sacrificed his ass whoa Lord's
days
okay he's got he's got to pay the
Penance but this is what he wanted
because you ever have that thing where
you're just you want something so bad
yes but you don't you put it out there
and you know it's just not gonna happen
the world and the universe is gonna
align against you and you're you're not
gonna get he's such a blizzard Fanboy
that he it's gonna get blocked because
he didn't want to say it was going to go
through because he felt if he did it
would get blocked so please don't be too
hard on Jazz he was doing the reverse
drinks the whole time she just took one
for the tree trying to block the
flip-flop from Jazz no sir
you two have been cast to the Shadows
excuse me
you was you was a little waffley over
there
I saw you over there I said he's
waffling hold my shoulder ran but just
turned Tails there he turned it all
right well I mean he's not here so he he
is running from UK
smoke is very heavy here he's not here
to defend himself but we got you
I'm here that's all you need from the
Xbox too anyways it's just me what do
you need just for outside of code names
for projects that are five years out oh
[__] oh Jesus slander
um but yeah so Jim Ryan comes Crawling
Back to the table you know really out
there saying at the top of his uh you
know his voice his chest we don't want
this deal and as soon as it gets done
he's like pass me the pen Phil please
right oh man
um can I can I chime in on that though
we're in sure I think reading those
emails from the court case I think Jim
Ryan was playing that really smart at
that point when he was trying to use the
deal as leverage to get Bethesda games
back on Playstation I think that's smart
in terms of a business strategy what I
don't agree with is everything that
transpired afterwards where like he's
publicly saying like because I believe
we now that we have read the court
documents it was initially five years
years like the contract was five years
and then like so like he did all this
for like the last year to get a 10-year
contract like come on that's that's well
did they get a 10-year contract it
wasn't specified in the tweet at least
we're imagining I don't know I would
imagine it was 10 years but it wasn't I
would feel like if it was 10 years they
would have put 10 years there uh I'll
tell you but we put 10 years for
everything else 20 years for PlayStation
but but
it's five years for PlayStation that's
whatever years they have left to breathe
just your question for Rand well ran
what what is your take on that initial
communication the long definitely
planned out email from Jim Ryan back to
Phil Spencer and Phil Spencer's Hardline
answer of saying no man we gotta compete
with you I mean I don't begrudge Jim for
doing any of this I've always said it
like you're you're best in you know he's
got to protect PlayStation do what's
best for him and for that business so
yeah if I'm Jim I would have said the
same thing I Phil all right give me all
the games though I want ABK I want
Bethesda right and you know I I don't
begrudge him for trying to get that
trying to use whatever leverage they had
over Xbox to try to get as many games as
possible and to try to make Xbox as weak
as possible because you know if
Starfield if they if Phil Bent the knee
to Jim and Starfield was you know coming
to Playstation or
future all the future APK games are all
the future Bethesda games that kind of
does look make Xbox look weaker and that
makes Game Pass look a little bit weaker
makes the platform look a little bit
weaker uh but Phil clearly it was like
no we we need exclusives he explained it
on the kind of funny interview and I see
Paris and chat and he's he's I think
he's salty he's not here [__] yeah I
will talk
uh you know it's like sure Jim where's
Final Fantasy VII yeah where's Final
Fantasy 16. they can keep 16. well we'll
keep our bethesis
but you know these exclusives are
marketing like beat right so they're
they're important so it's like Jim did
what he had to do and Phil was like
right and and maybe Phil could have
could have acquiesced because at the I
mean I don't know what the time the
timing was on it but you know like they
were facing regulatory pressure and
maybe the deal would have went through a
lot quicker if Sony was
behind the deal like if they were like
all right Xbox is giving us everything
We're Not Gonna really fight this right
they wouldn't no we're fine in court if
it wasn't for Sony's uh snitching yeah
but instead
but instead it's like all right so here
we are and they come back to the table I
would like to see the what the terms
work because we we got a sense of what
the other contract was detailed in
previous
um like CMA documents how like what the
terms were and all that sort of stuff I
wonder if anything changed I wonder if
maybe Jim's is like all right we're in
exchange for X Y or Z we'll give you
Call of Duty marketing rights this year
back or you can put it on Game Pass
starting this year because why would
Sony want to Market a game that's
basically Xboxes at this point
um I don't know I I'm very curious to
see
yeah the terminology behind the deal and
everything because you know because now
X after the FTC folded like a cheap tent
right
um XBox had all the leverage because
they're they've been you know negotiate
like their people their people right
they didn't just fold like a cheap tid
they really tried I mean sure no case
yeah they had no case they fold like a
cheap tent but either way I mean there's
been Xbox people that have been quote
unquote vacationing in London for the
past month yeah trying to work something
out with the CMA right like Sarah bond
does the trial and then immediately he's
like on vacation in London or whatever
so I mean like people at Xbox are trying
to get this done and once the FTC was
hey we lost and then the appeal was
basically just like get this out of here
you know they're like
you know and at that point Xbox has all
the Leverage
so I I couldn't imagine filling them
offering more than what they originally
offered in fact they probably could
offer less because they don't need it at
that point the ftc's lost the CMA threw
up a console harm uh so is this
basically like what what did you offer
them like I wonder what that phone call
would be like man that's literally what
I would say I was in my mind I just wish
I was the kids and family how did that
call go that that's uh you know you know
what I'm curious what's King do yay but
look look we've waited we've postponed
this long enough before king turns on
his camera and we chat don't don't
introduce anything oh read the Super
Chat first yeah no no no read the the
group chat oh oh okay okay let's see
what's going on I'm gonna talk about
something yesterday
I think it's gonna be good man I think
it's gonna be good yeah you know I I
want to thank Dustin and Ryan for coming
on though yeah yeah this we had to have
a it just ran I woke up this morning and
then I put in the chat I was like it's
like the gaming Gods want to keep giving
a smoke
so look we've waited here long enough uh
before King does whatever the hell he's
got to do all right before I have to do
something I don't know there's no
corporate car but we gotta we gotta do
something so look man two immortalize
this moment I want all y'all in the
congregation to turn me to a very recent
edition of the New Testament of the book
of x
courtesy of Anchorman V this is a
Revelation chapter 20 verse 23 y'all and
the scripture reads when King David
takes the mics this Sunday be clear this
man started to hold the line movement
right after the CMA blocked the ABK deal
in the heart of all Xbox ridicule Phil
Dominus Maximus Aurelius firing talk
Xbox content creators jumping ship off
the platform
the upcoming PlayStation showcase was
imminent and based on Sony's past
history of dominant showcases fear ran
rampant across the Xbox round
Xbox was set to be abolished for yet
another generation and become a laughing
stock once again as in the Xbox One era
then came the disaster that was the
redfall reviews Xbox first seven all
exclusive game
embarrassment ran rampant yet again
across the community
when the Xbox Community was down at
their lowest King David gave you hope
King David The Comeback wardrobe was
born everyone rallied together and their
beloved platform and held the line
corporate Cog has been abolished today
no Devil's Advocate during this segment
we in the realm agree he needs to stand
down for this day
Sunday is the Lord's day and it's all
about King I present to you King David
of the iron Lords podcast
I do appreciate all the hard work
everybody has done
[Music]
I had to sit down
we gotta talk up you're riding in your
snitching gym
your words carry no wait anymore Jim
you gotta make it right Jim
now what I want you to do is I want you
to sign the contract oh man
and I want you to sign this and I want
you to understand that nothing is given
everything is taken it's not like a
sticker
Jim you have no other recourse but to
sign the document
this is the day the Lord has given and
we are taking everything from you again
but kick this don't sound like an offer
it's not like a threat it wasn't an
offer this is a threat
we need you to get right Jim
and by getting right is by signing that
contract so if anybody wanted the inside
I give you the Insight I made them
enough for you because of a few I went
off with this
your knees
or Call of Duty
Jim gave both
he's a giver you know
um
I feel right now and let everybody know
the general is on his way but
King Corleone had to come
oh this kid called yo oh okay okay
and sometimes we gotta apply pressure
and in certain circumstances pressure
bus pipes if the strong arm went there
to make him see your way to understand
where he's coming from we have a mutual
understanding Jim is a sensible man he
understands the difference between harm
and harm or harm competition okay okay
no he wanted competition so like the
great satis said competition
with Jim the redness
but a day is a new day we're gonna wash
it clean you're gonna sign on the Lord's
day you're gonna get that out to the
people and the people gonna have
information to run with for weeks
not Jim
I'm back on your word because the last
time we had a conversation we had an
agreement you woke up in the morning and
you was in Brazil
so wait a minute okay gotta get at it
get it you sounded like uh Leonardo
DiCaprio in the in the movie Departed
so I just wanted I wanted to see because
you know
oh he's going okay well I wanted to ask
him a question but it's all good it's
just interesting to see that you know he
got a chance to see his way you know
after that you would like to ask me you
know because based on how resistant Jim
was to to you and the org you know and
how techniques oh okay to make a man
change his mind
[Laughter]
it seems that uh the kid Corleone has
got his way and you know Phyllis jumped
out there and made some uh you know
deals with uh yeah we we've got we've
got the breaking news here so that's
always good to hit I don't know okay
let's continue on we're gonna open this
up attic and so but I want to make sure
kid gets all his bars off before I open
this up okay are we good well we still
have more things we need to discuss in
reference to the groundbreaking
announcement fulfillments
I think he's good addict
your thoughts sir the the deal you know
it's a long journey obviously today
breaking news you know Phil Spence
announces that they have reached an
agreement with PlayStation on Call of
Duty what's your thought sir
man we all know uh there was only so far
Jim was going to go there's only so far
PlayStation was gonna go the more the
FTC dropped the ball and sent someone
after they didn't really seem to know
the gaming industry and and I quote zero
and four that it was it was a wrap at
that point because the moment they lost
that hearing
Jim officially lost all of his leverage
because now it's just the CMA and and
it's like one of those things that what
I want to really highlight it's a Sunday
we get this yeah that's crazy it makes
me feel it was like somebody decided I
need the iron Lords to have a really
good show it feels like somebody has
decided they're closing tomorrow and
Phil was like you either sign now or you
don't do it at all because even if there
was no news coming out tomorrow like
that they would have just held this for
tomorrow
PlayStation but it's like something else
is gonna happen tomorrow and they only
got Sunday before tomorrow obviously
that's how the days of the week go but
it does it does feel like
we never have breaking news on IOP very
rarely something happened the week
before we we like the end show you know
we after everyone else has got they bars
we the end show we we we we uh what
what's what's like a recap at the end of
the week yeah yeah and it's it's just
it's interesting that they chose to
release this on a Sunday at 10 A.M when
they normally release stuff on Mondays
and Tuesdays for the most part mainly
Monday so it's like why didn't you just
wait a day unless something else is
going to happen tomorrow thank you Phil
thank you
because it was it was him that tweeted
it yes yes yes it was yes so then you
got to say being that you know he's an
avid watcher I'm glad that you're
watching Sir have fun in UK
um but
you got to think about it before the
show started he's like uh I don't know
the time difference over how many UK let
me put this out at 10 o'clock over there
so these guys have something to talk
about and I do appreciate it because all
you Microsoft guys have supported us
shout out to Greenie it's been fun and
this is even more fun and stick around
people because we almost got 3 000
people watching oh wow the general will
show up uh that's later okay and and
King we we all know why Jim signed that
paperwork but he wanted that Diablo he
was scared to lose that Diablo you know
what's interesting too he doesn't get
that though and on Phil Spencer's tweet
it's interesting
that only Call of Duty is brought up in
no time when it was brought up okay
because then every other thing we've
signed a 10 you do a 50-year deal a
lifetime deal but this one like yeah
they signed it they're like well what's
the time frame ask Jim
but then didn't yeah well
I just because I heard it from Destin
didn't the judge Dustin say um call um
Diablo wouldn't harm yeah said anything
but Call of Duty right so yeah I'm
because I was going to ask you that
question you know specifically uh in her
saying that so I I don't know if I got
it wrong or right but what did she say
particularly about other games other
than Call of Duty I don't have the exact
phrasing but she mentioned Diablo and
said well it's a popular game it's not
in the same league as a game like Call
of Duty is and
even the analytics from their Dr Lee
said that it wouldn't be that negative
if it was entirely removed from the
console and remember it's passed in like
what 40 places 40 countries now none of
them saw an issue with the console
Market not even the CMA right yeah no
good so that market including the FDC uh
preliminary injunction hearing there's
no issue with the console market so it's
it's a little ridiculous you know I
agreed I got to get soft in the realm
missed out last week breaking news
solved you know
man you know we are here Phil puts the
Tweet Out PlayStation bends the knee
effectively signs the Call of Duty deal
what are your thoughts here
but first of all good enough
I just want to say you're welcome to all
of you
let's see at the Plaza Hotel
for planting that you know Inception
like seed into Phil's mind you know
give give him Bobby kode that call you
know and so now that everything is said
and done I think I I'm free to speak
freely I can't cause any more damage
right I'm gonna I'm gonna speak freely
now and and I have to say that I agree
completely with Dustin I've been saying
this for the longest time I think what
bothers me most about all of this is the
fact that the arguments were always a
losing proposition they were never going
to win based off of either Call of Duty
or either this small vertical that is
the gaming Cloud right
it just never made any sense if you
really wanted to kill this deal and show
that Microsoft was trying to monopolize
anything you show how their Monopoly and
Cloud period was going to affect Cloud
throughout the entire planet
and then you show the small little
microscope under the microscope what
what damages whatever whatever change is
going to cause to the gaming space
because that's how small it is it's
cloud in general and they dropped the
ball they didn't follow that that sort
of train of thought and now it's too
late
and now it is now it is late no
backseats you can't go back you can't go
back and argue this now but it was
always a dumb argument nobody stopped
and thought hey isn't it weird that the
moment we back off of the Call of Duty
talk we back off a little bit of the the
the the console Cloud stuff Microsoft is
miraculously able to offer everybody
Under the Sun a cloud gaming deal
companies that we've never heard of oh
yeah we got that we got that what this
this dark corner of the world yeah we
have servers over there don't worry
about that nobody thought to say hey
maybe let's look into that no no no
let's worry about if Call of Duty could
be playing on the phone right let's do
that and and so here we are so if Jim is
mad if uh if leader Khan is mad if
whoever's mad out there it's your own
damn fault I don't know what you guys
are thinking it was just a stupid
argument to begin with and now now if
you were really truly trying to prevent
this you're done messed up and it's a
wrap and that's what it is so and and
this is kind of the final stake about I
woke up this morning and I posted this
in our chat I was like 10 years
confirmed by the way
you confirm okay okay breaking news
y'all satello just confirmed it okay
10-year confirmed right tenure confirmed
and it's going to be readdressed every
time that 10-year period comes up it'll
be readdressed right and and probably
extended because that is the that is
just what it is
um yeah I'm just mad at them for wasting
our time and money on foolishness if the
if the arguments had been legitimate
that what they did was that was good
right in general it's just that hey
deals this big should always be
scrutinized of course whatever of course
um but then don't come don't go there
with disingenuous arguments thinking
you're going to win something because
you're not and that that's just that's
just sad so yeah here we are
I'm happy for everyone that's super
happy about this I you know again when I
when I when that thought came to my mind
I was like hey this would be crazy
for me it's just about seeing how what
happens to the industry right you know
it
Game Pass needs as much content as
possible for it to continue to grow
especially in the PC space especially in
the cloud space and you know the the
console space is going to grow as much
as it's going to grow and that's it so
this is huge for them what I want to see
in my hope as a gamer right selfishly is
hey does this really allow for some of
these companies that have been put into
the Call of Duty uh assembly
um are they allowed to come back and
start making games for themselves some
of them right because my thing is this
if you're gonna have support Studios for
Call of Duty
build a studio that's specifically for
that right you're not going to ask Nexus
to go build their own game or anything
like that right you're gonna go to build
the studio specifically for that the
understanding is you're going to support
Call of Duty don't pull Studios that
have a history of making their own games
to support on COD in that way where in
just eliminating their own personal
identity so for me I would love to see
raven come back and do stuff uh Toys for
Bob things of that nature so we'll see
we'll see what happens I hope that them
coming into you know the Microsoft fold
allows for that and it's just not
Microsoft taking over the Sweatshop we
have new ownership at the Sweatshop but
that's it
um but yeah man it's a day it's a day
for sure yeah and I just want to all
recap quickly you know what a week right
what a week this has been because you
know initially we started off you know
Microsoft winning the court case right
and we had the announcement you know
over activation blizzard you know judge
corley's decision we saw what happened
there and then you know immediately
Little Seeds well not too many seeds of
Doubt but you saw immediately the ftc's
response you know then they appeal the
ruling right and we have to go through
that and we see what goes on with the
ninth court and all that kind of stuff
and then we get kind of close to where
we got before today which is they're
losing the appeal bid to block you know
Microsoft Activision and just to see
where that's at and look it it is very
interesting because to me and now where
we are here with a 10-year deal this is
this is an inflection point this is an
inflection point in the industry you
know regardless to whatever side you're
on regarding consolidation or whatever
you know this is the thing that I think
which is very interesting we learned so
much on how everyone thinks all the
parties involved think you know you get
there behind the scenes on what Sony is
thinking as far as them you know as far
as exclusives in the console Market as
well as Microsoft the way they're
thinking and my position has always been
what's best for the consumer like that's
in you know eloquently said you know in
judge told please you know talking about
the case just reference to how many
times the consumer was mentioned versus
how many times Sony was mentioned you
know what I mean and at the end of the
day selfishly for me I have to I come
into things as a consumer first how does
this benefit me right how what what is
this going to do as far as the games
industry how I access content things of
that nature and to me it's about when
you look at it objectively right
pre-deal Call of Duty
supposed to do a deal Call of Duty right
all the platforms that would get said
plot you know set access versus not and
also the other thing that I'm thinking
about is from a competitive standpoint
from the position in the market where
Xbox is in comparison to where
PlayStation is does this harm
competition and that to me was always
airtighty always logical to me that that
did not harm competition because you're
giving more people access to something
and on the in the end of the day like we
learned today it's not being pulled from
PlayStation right in terms of Call of
Duty one of the most influential 10
years for 10 years you know same kind of
game so you know for me it's like I
personally don't care about Call of Duty
like that I forget about it since you
know the Vincent validates back in those
days but you know I understand the
impact and I understand more gaming is
accessing this you know is extremely key
here so this is we've come full circle
this is this is a day I do want to
implement before we open it back up to
kicking everybody um and ran I want to
open as far as the patreon questions you
know one thing I want to say real quick
before you do that yeah it's kind of
crazy if you think about it like why was
it Nintendo given the same you know
leeway in the court why it's saying like
they only cared about the health of
PlayStation like they didn't bring up
anyone else right really no that's huge
but Nintendo was looked at as a last
generation not kidding as a different
vertical completely almost yeah they
they categorized it how convenient
or uh like a child's toy and then every
time they did bring up Nintendo's name
they were like it's not in the same
category as a high-tech spec uh gaming I
would have said how convenient
what I like about Bobby is Bobby let you
know uh the new Nintendo will be able to
run it oh yeah my boyfriend put that
information to the table do not discount
them you know they they ready
and it works for the new machine oh I
wasn't oh he wasn't supposed to say that
oh it's comparable to the Xbox one oh my
bad my bad I was supposed to say that so
it's okay for you to snitch
no that's real that's real and I I
definitely wanted to get that part off
and then um yeah just want to implement
uh patreon question really quick because
it's kind of related so just a shout out
to Lord Stitch he said to the Lords of
the beef Market that's me once avk is
part of the Xbox family what dormant IP
do you think all should be brought back
and what studio should work on it see
you all Sunday hashtag Hold the Line
hashtag let King cook so thoughts on you
know what what now in this you know post
acquisition World it looks like where
this is where we are now you know um
what do we think what are we thinking on
that so I don't know can you want to
answer prototype oh yeah
who wouldn't make that on Microsoft
Ninja Theory maybe make a prototype I
don't know
I'm sorry ran I apologize
expecting Jazz to pop up and you know
and hope yeah let's let the dude that
would invited me on a show go
somebody else
you could have came in everybody else
did addict you just didn't want to go go
Dustin
so that's just prototype that's the
doorman IP yeah I gotta go pretty soon
anyway but yeah prototype definitely
like if you think back to like when
Incredible Hulk Ultimate Destruction was
being made one of my favorite like
superhero games uh there was some
stealth stuff in there that was weird
but that game was awesome it was just
like Rampage but with a Hulk right yeah
it's really really cool
um well Activision came on with this
game called prototype which utilizes a
lot of the same mechanics and sort of
power-ups and stuff like that a modern
version of that would be so cool I do
think people in the chat talking about
Transformers the reason I don't think
that's licensing right right you've got
issues with Hasbro those games were
great but prototype as far as I know is
owned by them by Activision yeah so they
could do that tomorrow or announce that
tomorrow if they wanted no doubt who do
you think would make a Dustin because I
don't know I don't know radicals no
longer around right Raven get them off
of this raven is so freaking talented
they're just plugging away at Call of
Duty for all yeah but they own but they
Raven owns war zone though they may move
enough for us and I'm kind of curious if
you guys like truly believe that
Microsoft is gonna like
disassemble the Cod machine like no and
I just don't know what they're doing but
I would say like I said build teams
specifically for that and let the other
teams Rock I mean again we don't even
know what these we don't know what Raven
looks like anymore it's probably not
even sort of built to be to make their
own game but again that's just wishful
thinking but I would say let let
somebody make these IPS come back for
sure let me ask well you asked who I
want to make
or whatever no no let's get Raven on
something new and interesting you know
Revitalize that studio let them make
another Wolverine that won't happen yeah
I love their Wolverine game I grew up in
their backyard they're in there as far
as I remember in Madison Wisconsin
maybe Microsoft is looking at stuff like
that they're like look you know we're
gonna spend off some of these Studios
and hire and let people continue working
on call that wants to but you know we're
having these other teams that they're
working on something new I want to ask a
quick question 3
000 people wow hit the like button
you know Rand and and Dustin is here
let's share that out share that out and
quickly I gotta say I was gonna say and
you know uh shout out to uh stitch for
leaving the patreon question you know
there's our patreon right there guys if
you guys want to be part of that or you
know we me and King do reactions I know
it's been a minute since I did another
one I promise you I'm getting back into
that and you can ask all of our uh shows
a question no questions Eddie can you
give me a can you give me a chair spin
please
before the chance spit I got it I got to
get it that's the last question because
he's got it I got it he's a limited time
so um I do want to ask because we do it
besides the breaking up news 10-year
deal PlayStation we did we didn't get a
chance to quickly talk about one the CMA
right the next steps there and then two
obviously the whole thing shout out to
Time Warner talked about the um the
NASDAQ aspect as far as it being removed
from activist Blizzard from its index
and he said not delisting entirely from
NASDAQ which means that NASDAQ that
NASDAQ believes the merger is highly
probable so I want to get your thoughts
next and uh again shout out to you shout
out to Michael pacta who you had on as
well you know you guys are pretty
adamant about how things would play out
hold all these guys false patterns you
know and like you said in your latest
video
all the experts all the money and this
is exactly how it's going now so what's
your thoughts CMA and then the whole
NASDAQ situation before you had it well
I had hogla who said everything that
would happen happen I had Michael
packter who said everything that has
happened would happen I had Foss patents
who called all of this yes so it's like
you don't believe me here's three more
experts people still want to doubt those
experts like people who are much smarter
and have been following this stuff in
the industry longer than me and they're
just like oh no like it's not going to
happen the deal's dead
yeah and it's just like well here we are
today exactly what they said would
transpire did yeah right and as as for
the NASDAQ thing I actually called that
on in my last video over on on my
YouTube that yeah NASDAQ made the call
saying that they're gonna be delisting
Activision because
they believe that the deal is going to
go through that's a NASDAQ decision
Activision didn't like call up NASDAQ
yeah and say this that was an
independent decision by them so
yeah I mean yeah that's just it is what
it is right what what people don't
understand when you're saying that
um if they don't buy trade and sell
stocks that means that you cannot buy
trade or sell that stock because that
stock is not there that because it's
either imminent growth is going to
happen or uh imminent uh Decline and
that happened with Robin Hood uh back
with the GameStop
um stuff you don't remember when they
had to pull uh GameStop off of the
NASDAQ because of what they were doing
when they pushed the the stocks all the
way up and they had to stop the
purchasing so stuff like this happens
all the time and this is an indication
of bigger things to come all inside of
trading and they wanted to limit inside
of trade yeah I mean this is very very
interesting developments and that's the
last question is in reference to timing
of potential closing what you know we
heard some things from Tom that maybe
you know it maybe it might not close
Monday you know but now with this
announcement from Phil today do you
think that potentially accelerates
things or do you think Microsoft says
look we're this close the FTC let's for
all intents of purpose has been
vanquished right there's no opposition
moving forward from them so maybe we
slow things down give UK the time to do
it the right way and and not just kind
of Brute Force our way through it like
what do you what what you're leaning
towards now that all this stuff is
developing in real time so this is my
personal opinion just based off of
everything that's happened and following
the case for so long I think the FTC if
they're smart they have a window here to
bow out gracefully if they continue it
through to August then lose again the
next
tribunal or whatever they have where
they're talking about their budget like
you want to get docked down another 50
like you want to add another L to your
list no I don't think so
preliminary injunction the standard is
to drop it after that just drop it and
move on there are other cases with
Microsoft where the the FTC has had a
good win like with uh privacy there was
the case with epic where the FTC you
know made sure that you know kids
weren't buying things that they
shouldn't be buying on fortnite or
whatever so like the FTC does good stuff
the non-compete stuff stop like they
sued Microsoft to block this before even
talking to Microsoft I don't think
people remember that so they didn't even
talk to them they were like nope we're
just gonna see you and block your thing
so it was purely politically motivated
it's very frustrating to see that
because sure you don't like Microsoft we
get it there are other things that you
should be chasing that are more
important than an August trial so anyway
the FTC has a window to bow out
gracefully the CMA yeah the CMA phrasing
in their chains timeline yeah there's
there's the last sentence in there where
they're like you know we're moving into
August but maybe we can figure this out
a little bit sooner it's interesting the
change in tone from the CMA because you
gotta remember they're sitting out there
on an island by themselves now they are
the only ones that have any grounds for
blocking this they're being ridiculed by
the EU the FTC just lost and they were
in cahoots yeah Canada
missed their deadline so I don't know
how they litigate like are they able to
just change the law and then
New Zealand's the 17th also I think but
they're already basically leaning
towards approval and Australia right and
well I I don't have the full list of
other territories left to approve or
block but like who who just to prove it
like South Africa just to proved it
somebody Korea I want to say who did
Lulu Chang survey just tweet about right
it was another location anyway I don't
remember which one but
all these places are approving it so
here's the CMA sitting on an island all
by themselves uh New Zealand had some
concerns but yeah so when will they
close they have two windows Monday
Tuesday right or they have to
renegotiate their whole contract and
figure it out turkey it was Turkey thank
you chat they have to renegotiate their
whole contract and move it to August to
see what happens with the FTC what
happens with the CMA right
I don't know it's a business question
business-wise I think they might close
next week yeah no and I I think they
don't want to renegotiate the contract
so but everyone just because everybody
else is saying oh they're going to push
the August this is one time where I'm
gonna say no I like they got this
contract with Sony they're working on
the Lord's day
I guess Sony must think it's imminent
then because otherwise why why not wait
and see how it plays out with the CMA
right exactly I know you don't want
stuff going on I know y'all didn't want
corporate [__] but I have to mention
this I'm sorry oh shout out to my
brother when they're in Dutch he said a
couple of talking points the Call of
Duty deal doesn't affect CMA concerns
they aren't discussing discussing
behavioral remedies
three thousand oh wow thank you wow wow
wow congratulations thank you that is
amazing hit the like button hit the like
button subscribe point two Microsoft
Activision Blizzard can extend the
agreement it without shareholder
agreement only requiring the senior
decision makers to sign off on it this
negates the requirement to renegotiate
in circumstance in special circumstances
where the timeline to close it it's
closed but not close enough to deadline
and third point he says to close
tomorrow the CMA would have to lift the
i o in order for that to happen
Microsoft will not close over the CMA
likely point two will occur so that
that's Dutch's story who's oh yeah Dutch
I actually had that tweet up I disagree
I think they close next week and I think
they deal with the CMA stuff as it comes
they're like we're still working to
figure things out in this location but
we're closing everywhere else basically
and I don't know I just I think that's
what they're going to do I think I think
it's closing tomorrow if I'm wrong
whatever I'll eat Pro on it but that's
my guy remember what they said to the
FTC during that whole trial they're like
if you if you block this it's dead right
so that deadline is important enough for
them to testify on the stand that if
they hit that deadline and have to pay 3
billion
then the deal is dead well to be fair of
course they're going to say that right
they're under oath though right well
yeah they have to say it but there's an
added weight to say yeah but but the the
July 18 thing that wasn't necessarily a
hard deadline like it's not like July
18th hit and it was like oh well you
know this this agreement's torn up it's
like they could still keep it going it's
just that at that point one of them
could leave without really any sort of
problem right so do you think if the FTC
would have blocked the deal would have
been dead
I could have seen I could I could have
seen Activision and Microsoft taking it
to Supreme Court all the way up
potentially I could see it because when
you look at all the stuff that kind of
was poorly redacted right or and some of
the testimony that came out
you know that you know inside of
Activision Blizzard there were some
dissension in terms of should this deal
when you talk about Call of Duty and the
idea of putting it in Game Pass a lot of
the higher-ups didn't necessarily agree
with that so the idea that the deal as
it was
was you know pristine and shiny and
everybody loved it is is kind of not
true so if you never know if they had
the opportunity to walk away from it
they easily could have so it I I do
think that the the realities of that
deadline are pretty strict in that all
of these things can happen legally
without any repercussion if they reach
the deadline date and and nothing is
resolved yet so I think it behooves them
to get it done as quickly as possible
just so that that deadline does not come
into play at all but I do sort of agree
listen you know you know how I went up
there's an authentic set plan
and when you look at the Optics about
the CMA stuff we plan nicer are we and
that's the thing if you don't wait for
the if you don't wait for the CMA right
you know how when a an actor wins an
Oscar for a role he doesn't deserve
really and and and and and and and and
oh he doesn't get the Oscar for the role
that he deserves it for then he gets it
you know I always think about Russell
Crowe Like Gladiator I love Gladiator he
should have won for a beautiful mind for
Malcolm X yeah
exact same thing same thing so my thing
here is that they didn't get you under
this big humongous Planet altering deal
right right
if you if you overstep right if you line
step and say you know what I'm not going
to wait for you it's going to close and
I'm not going to wait for your process
they could really make waves for you
when you try to do okay other things
yeah like if they go after ever born you
know I know you can chat what if they
what if Dustin what if they try to go
get Sega but you closed over the CMA
exactly imagine you know like what
happens then imagine if they come out
with all the best arguments ever when
you just when Sega wants to get by and
take us what two billion dollars you
think this is gonna get it that's a good
point they don't give a crap about
Bungie yeah oh yeah whatever Sony you're
right the market leader that's fine
politics politics politics but to
Dustin's point you know when we I had
Hogue law on and one of my concerns was
in a world post ABK would they be
allowed to do something like this it
wouldn't regulate us give scrutiny again
these either cornhole just like that's
gonna say it's it's about the financial
scale so Millions versus billions
doesn't call people outside necessarily
so to speak but do you yeah I'm sorry I
was gonna say yeah do you think they try
try to go for another big big publisher
because I don't think they do not
immediately for six months
but like let's say Sony's announces
another buy of square
you know then might as well that's the
industry beat and I think about six
months from now we hear about more
Acquisitions from either Sony or
Microsoft they're not done they've said
publicly they're not done more
Acquisitions are coming
um do you that's why you need to tune
into his channel because a lot of you
soft guys are talking soft and he's not
pumping any Kool-Aid out of his heart
do you guys think they keep that margin
below 10 billion like they don't go
above that then nobody who's who would
be worth that much maybe
Rockstar
that's what I'm saying like the big big
Publishers like the goliaths like
because I would consider Activision one
of those collides and they got lucky to
get that I don't think they get another
one of them I I can't remember what they
said like those company companies are
worth but a PlayStation can buy them
it's not going to pop on the radar
because PlayStation doesn't have the
investment Capital to make purchases of
Activision's caliber and that's not a
dig that's just the reality of just
reality as a company right Microsoft is
a trillion a billion dollars that's
funny
PlayStation and Sony billion dollar
company
it just it just comes down to what's
easier it's easier to convince a bunch
of people to room to spend money that's
just chilling here to buy something that
is like yeah we got we got to take a
loan out on this IP put these buildings
up for sale it's easier to make sense
you can once only to do whatever their
wallet don't call for that all right you
have a inside the store and wanted
something but your wallet just didn't
call for it so you had to go get the
knockoff we understand and I don't even
see them buying Square they've been
getting the milk for free I think they
might get square I don't think so I know
who would go after Square because they
already have paperwork drawn up
I know for a fact somebody's being eyed
and grew yo Dustin on the other side has
been taking him for granted question
Dustin how bad would the salt be if in
six months they announced they bought
square units Xbox
oh if they bought Square I mean that
would be interesting I think they're
gonna buy take two though oh
I think Sony's gonna buy take
heard it here first no no Microsoft oh
Microsoft's gonna buy take two yeah
let me hear this Grand Theft Auto Grand
Theft Auto is on X Club right now it's
back on on it's on Gamecast right yeah
so like that relationship has been going
for a while now they did that little
test of water with Game Pass back in the
day where uh it was on there for like a
day and then off and now they're back at
the table it's really interesting timing
like the day the FTC loses oh Grand
Theft Auto 5. can you make the but you
sorry real quick so you can make the
same argument about Sega games like
almost every Sega games on game pass at
this point yeah it was Yakuza they had
like the whole collection on there for
months again
look at the paperwork that we have
access to now they were having
conversations about having that purchase
so maybe that was like testing the
waters again who knows who's going to
come back to the table now that this
whole thing is cleared now that they
know Microsoft is here to play I think
Sony is going to get some of them and I
think Xbox is going to get some of them
I don't know I don't know what's going
on at Square Enix I don't know if
they're trying to do these Partnerships
with Sony for leverage but we know now
that Final Fantasy 16 was coming to Xbox
at one point and then Sony dropped some
Bank on it so quick solved get your
questions yeah everybody yeah
do you think what time take two if take
two becoming part of Microsoft do you
think that is more that is more of a
they they operate uh independently just
like kind of like a Bethesda does or an
Activision Bliss will or because I don't
I don't see Strauss zelnick being okay
with GTA and any sort of Rock Star
Property going into Game Pass so I think
so I guess he's cool I mean day one I
mean
just lose one of their Founders yeah
yeah they do take you or you mean uh
Rockstar
maybe they're just looking to get out of
it you know like Larry herb just was at
Xbox for 20 years right these companies
have been around forever and and like
everybody's gonna miss Larry very very
much absolutely at some point people
like to do other things oh I have to
wonder like
does take two wanna do other things or
like I don't know I just have this
feeling something's going on with take
two and Microsoft
Rockstar properties
and they admire it they don't get a
choice
I don't really understand the question I
don't know
they own them
I think
the day and date aspect we know if
they're quiet Bobby Kodak said the same
thing here we are
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he has been my good luck charm this
whole time and if take two happened yes
if they come out and take two and you
know Grand Theft Auto 6 is exclusive
I don't think they do that because of
the online the online is too big come on
because they did rock star Prince money
so they have separated them you know
online you know in the store you can't
once if they separate them in the
online's everyone put the stories
exclusive to Xbox no I don't think they
do that I think it will remain
multi-platform
let them pay the seven shots
we'll take your 330 million install base
on PlayStation and you can pay us that
30 we're fine with that absolutely
that's what they're talking so right now
destiny take two's market cap is 25 Bill
okay how much should I pay for it how
much you get how much you offering stock
price is only on the rise and Grand
Theft Auto 6 by all accounts is coming
out next year which means their stock
price is going to the same it's just got
their stock price is even higher Rand
what's what's what was activations can
you do you know that activities was like
60.
it was at 100 and all the all the
problems hit all those lawsuits and it
dropped all the way down to like 59.60
and that's when the next thing and then
Xbox bought it and it jumped all the way
back up to like 80 and it kind of sat
there for a bit going between like 80s
and 70s so when they did the purchase it
was at 59 and they did some 69 right or
was it lower okay so then 25 they offer
35 billion yeah 35. yeah well they
offered they offered Call of Duty they
offered Activision a 40 premium on the
stock price yeah I'm sure it's a it's a
percentage thing then right so it
wouldn't be a flat 10 billion right now
uh take two is 150 uh a share so yeah so
I'd have to I'd have to like do the math
like what was the percentage increase
that they offered for Activision
Blizzard and I would just make that same
correlation to take two so if you're
saying their market cap is 35.
it says their market caps 25.4 then 30.
so like whatever the percent Edge
correlation would be to the Activision
deal I imagine it would be similar
amounts for what they would offer so so
okay so we we did see the mergers and
acquisition hit list at Xbox Live right
yep and there were Publishers on there
none of them were take two correct and
obviously this was before ABK and and
and stuff so APK wasn't on there but
that was like an opportunity thing we we
also know that they approached core Enix
at one point and their their name wasn't
on there either it's true so do you
think Bungie was on there and that
Deal's closed yeah Bungie Pete Parsons
are saying oh no no no no even though
everybody was like I interviewed Parsons
and he was talking about being
independent yeah later two years later
he sells the Sony
um and again like you said people like
to do other things
[Laughter]
Jones is still a Bungie right would EA
be a better buy
uh I don't think EA's in trouble in any
curiosity I mean I think the company is
looking to sell Sega Square Enix
um Ubisoft ubisoft's having trouble with
right you know nobody wants Ubisoft
though
I think geemo so that's before you go um
I did want to say like could be over
yeah I know you weigh a lot you gave us
so much time he's been giving so much
time look first of all like the
questions that's fine no the questions
are fantastic and your last the last
book you dropped the bombshell with the
with the take two things so like you
think that um because it wasn't on that
list so you think it does fall into that
situation the same way as in ABK where
it's kind of like hey this is developing
this is happening they're going through
something we jump on this opportunity
potentially now and then you know M A
let's be damned because this is an
opportunity that we didn't see coming
the same way where there was the
scandals going on with you know
Activision and then we found out that
they're you know they're kind of
available do if it was take two do you
think it's a similar situation to that
and then I gotta let you go so what's
the question exactly as far as the the
fact that the take two wasn't on that
list that m a list that came out mergers
and acquisition of who Microsoft was
targeted that we never an email is 2020
right right so so 2023 a lot can happen
in three years
okay when did when did take two like
bring GTA to game that was like eight
months ago it wasn't even a year ago
right so I imagine at that point that's
when sort of that conversation started
and that's why it's not on the m a list
from 2020 or 2021 whenever that
particular file was from uh like more
imminently the companies on that list
are probably the ones that people are
looking like IO interactive they seem
like based on their announcement that
they're staying independent right so
we'll see what happens but like but I
don't know that's just that's just my my
Spider Sense is saying something's going
on with Xbox and take two and it's been
going on for like the last year and
change no doubt we'll look salute to the
legend Destin legary all the laws they
long overdue to get you on the realm
again IGN's finest podcast unlock his
own channel and salute to you for the
way your your persistent coverage of all
the legal you know information during
this time getting the whole laws the
fast patterns on you know Michael pacted
getting his flowers on your show
predicted things right you've been like
a pillar as far as the information and
getting this stuff salute to you or one
thing personally um I want to salute you
on your destiny coverage back I know you
don't do fire team chat no more but
salute to you on that and I've always
respected one thing you don't ever get
your flowers when we talked about these
exclusivity deals I always have to give
you your files an interview with the
great deej back in the day Xbox players
were wondering consistently why was
content being left out of that platform
you asked the tough questions and I
really appreciate that because there was
a base that didn't understand how these
exclusive deals hurt another platform
and people Xbox fans were suffering for
that for so long you're the only one to
bring that up so salute to you telling
people where can they find you what you
got going on before you leave I got heat
for that but that's a and I love it for
another day I love it
yeah you can find me youtube.com at
Destin period the period is important
because otherwise you're gonna go to
some random dude
yeah or the Destin Channel over on
YouTube of course you can see all my
coverage at IGN I just executive
produced the ID at Xbox stream I'm very
happy with how that came out so if
you're curious about the Indies that was
a partnership between IGN and Xbox very
happy with how that uh came out as a
presentation so thank you anybody who
watched and uh yeah that's buy cookies
Gary Bakery yeah push those cookies push
those cookies sir
thank you thank you so much everybody
for having me uh I really appreciate it
Cog King I've wanted to hang out and on
the show for a long time and it's great
to see you do your personas attic
Sovereign thank you and ran thanks for
the invite to take oh that never
happened
[Laughter]
the legend enjoy your Sunday so thank
you so much
salute you want to get the super chat to
us yeah yeah I should get Hazard pay for
this day bro
hold on let me get this last one copy
pasted you let me know when you like
like uh five away from finishing yeah
I'm pretty sure
there'll probably be a hundred more by
the time I get to five or eight hold on
a second
absolutely everybody
let's go around outdoor 19 man we're
playing some ABK games you know what I'm
saying working it out
I just actually just finished oxen free
too oh no yeah I love oxen free so I had
to play the sequel right away
so please let's get those likes let's
share that out and I promise you I will
not disappoint you after these super
chats are red all right we gotta hustle
and motivate member for 19 months Lord
bronze oh man it's on yeah yeah and real
quick before you read the next one let's
get some hashtag rand's faults in the
chat this is not my fault
you're just mad that you're just mad
that King Incognito have been on Xbox
two and Xbox two plus one and you
haven't oh damn that that's the whole
point
damn
get on the spot said Lord remember for
six months two dollars Super Chat the
Lords are making my Sunday thank you and
hold the line absolutely absolutely
absolute
then we have a resting Craig face
I'm just here for the beef
um
there's meaty beef where's this cold
kind of beef
then we have snack five dollar Super
Chat who is this rapper he is incredible
[Music]
man
then we got BT Maverick 707 10 super
chat don't worry Cog we got your back
like let me play with your joystick
General King we got the we got them Sony
see oh salty knees thank you guys taking
on this Epic Journey must love the
addict and Suave as well
then we got nobody the five dollar Super
Chat
everyone we held that line let's go yes
today just to celebrate today yeah we
have Robert kellett five dollar Super
Chat we held the line General will you
add excav and Cognito charge past the
line now the crash spiral and more are
Xbox only
see we just gotta gotta see that ten
shoe yeah
she said we hit 18K just now wow
beautiful blessings y'all this is this
is awesome 18K 3K watching almost 2K you
guys are doing it let's get it it's good
to see the room come out like this wait
till I show you what's next and we got
Necromancer zail member for 20 months
Lord gold we're looking forward to this
since Xbox two show when the news broke
bro let him have it King yeah Xbox two
is lit man people like you guys left
like it was such a it was such a great
show you Paris Colt gas and then all of
a sudden the thing hit and then car
comes back in Harris comes back in Colt
comes back in like everybody dropping by
it was uh especially when in comparison
to uh other things going on that day
where it was basically just a morgue and
just a bunch of crying and complaining
grown men
next
let it out don't hold that in let that
out therapy sessions
I can't watch the show live but I wanted
to contribute because I want to see you
guys become the place to be for video
games podcasting thank you I appreciate
that much love I wish you all the best
to hold the line and hey Boo-Boo
there we have Robert Kelly chat little
Timmy smiling down on us oh yeah little
Timmy the great beyond
man
last minute that we have
then we have Alvin remember for six
months 7.77 uh Super Chat Phil's tweet
said nothing about 10 years today's
price is not yesterday's price a
glorious day in the road yesterday
[Music]
then we have necromancers they'll
remember for one year ten dollar Super
Chat anyone else looking forward to the
Xbox slash ant stream arcade deal
oh yeah okay we're talking about it yeah
I saw that yeah then we have Michael
Mooney five pound Super Chat and
Playstation has bent the knee yes they
have yes they have
these have been better
gloriously you know actually I before I
joined I recorded a video
I still have to edit it and stuff but
it's a good one it's a good one
okay okay
you saw ferango play his new video
[Music]
then we have project Aries remember for
two months five dollar Super Chat I for
real got popcorn ready today
no beefy seasoning unfortunately salute
to IOP and the mighty realm shout out to
use enjoy your popcorn sir
then we have Robert Kelly to get five
dollar super tap welcome to the Lord's
realm fell you must give your general
his Purple Heart for holding the line
and believing in your vision yes
if I get wounded in battle bro no
do not give me the Purple Heart of Valor
that means I went down and was captured
behind enemies
keep that one I don't want the wounded
metal
I was gonna say I wanna I want attic to
give us a back to back whoo we need that
can we eat that can we get it said you
would have got it
we have constructive game critiques cgc
uh put the crest in the chapter
constructive game critiques newest
member Lord bronze thank you so much no
doubt we have Ralph Carter five dollar
Super Chat can't stay for the live show
but looking forward to hearing king
reach his final form of Super Saiyan
cutting off my Tails then we have Dean
Rivera five dollar Super Chat I hope
Microsoft gave PlayStation the bare
minimum deal a deal possible especially
after all the crying general what other
next orders hashtag Hold the Line push
them to the brink
Ken what do you have to say to Jazz bro
have you have you mentioned have you
talked to him no but he can hear what
general has to say later
that's a general talk to everybody that
generally ran away from them
because Jess loves you you know and I
love jazz I love jazz deaf he she he
should have called me before he made
certain decisions
there we have Cedric H remember for two
years put the crest of the chapter 8
gifting 10 IOP memberships thank you
thank you
then we have Ed ROM with the five dollar
Super Chat this is my most anticipated
show in years also here's my
contribution to save the beefy Rhode
Island leopard all those likes
especially we're saving the uh what is
it the endangered uh blue Hedgehog over
the blue for Sega yeah we got to get
them back home exactly
then we have Nintendo Taco member for
one month ten dollars if you chat Cog Go
corporate somewhere else
go to your own world SOB just go
actually stay and read the super chats
but turn your camera off we're only here
for General King David thank you kindly
thinking the other guys podcast thank
you Don thank you
you triggered my trap card
[Laughter]
then we got Mandingo big Dickens Batman
for two years five dollars in the chat
earlier today addict said I feel it in
my bones
well sir I too feel it in mind
by the way has anyone seen Saab no
yo why he looking for you after he felt
it I don't I don't did I say I feel it
on my bones on this should I say to my
video earlier I don't know
you feel the stuff in your bones
I know I said my old big bones that's
what I said oh well he he said he felt
something in his big bone too oh
it's that have my hold the line to you
ready to advance shout out to you
appreciate that thank you then we have M
Marquis ten dollar Super Chat Xbox tells
PlayStation like Achilles told Hector
there are no packs between lions and Men
yeah
and we have Hollywood rules remember for
one year two dollars for chat we want
knees hashtag lion gym the knees were
given needs were given no no no doubt
then let's put the crest in the chat for
Lord bronze wavy kosher shout out to
Wavy kosher remember for two months
appreciate you
then let's put the crest in the chapel
Lord bronze again remember for six
months Fastback OG nlg podcast
hello appreciate you
then we have zip Davis two dollars to
the chat all who held the line get
access to the club now
[Laughter]
there we go uh here we have goo like
hold on I got a hold on I gotta make
sure this is not right
yeah trolled
we have gooey cheese
42. Gucci's 42 five dollars for chat do
you think with Xbox owning this many
studios that there is a risk of Studios
getting shut down if their games
underperformed
not not as much as if they were by
themselves well I think about it you
know APK is going to be pulled over and
all the stuff that they're working on I
don't think they break up that machine
at all if you're making 800 million off
of one platform which is PlayStation you
just handed out all these deals the
level of money that's going to be coming
in uh incentivize them to keep those uh
Studios pumping out what they're pumping
out I don't think they're gonna be
making any subpar games I think you keep
the machine going I was going no doubt
no doubt so
and we got a Malcolm X LAX three two
dollar Super Chat King The Godfather
Pimpin Ain't Easy
somebody gotta work the track
then we got big black Cog
yo yeah and if you look at it the the
letters
[Music]
now y'all doing this yeah BBC
yeah
it's a pause
yeah man this is a family show bro
listen yeah I decided to put I didn't
say oh your determination of what that
is
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
Jim Ryan said [__] up on me I feel
obliged yeah
for British broadcast Corporation
yo
he said that is not prediction approved
no exactly got a big show we write the
sponsorships
it's a fluid show it's a live show it's
a live show it's definitely different
connotation for those that's a little
too much fluid
or just the right amount of fluids
wow Adam 22 we not doing that Let It Go
appreciate you hello salute then we have
Ricky Fallon or Ricky felon I don't
think it's felony
what's good Lords we ain't good over
here hold the line salute everyone
special shout out to the king excited
for today's show Xbox slash Bethesda
slash activism blizzard slash King
lfg hashtag hold the line yes
y'all better be ready you better be
ready no doubt then we have Brit man
with the five pound Super Chat hi guys
you should invite a PlayStation
representative for discussion MBG the
deal affects his Camp you should you
should get his thoughts it's only fair
respectively no
bring somebody over here they be
slaughtered like that don't make no
sense the last time we had
Representatives over here it didn't fare
well right now see please somebody go
check on JW salute to jail
holidays
then we have nuisance with the news
answers of nuisance nuisance with the
five dollars of a chat all that crime
Jim did was just to bend the knee I
don't want a new Call of Duty deal I
just want to block your merger dude
wasted everyone and he ended up signing
that dotted line regardless
oh but that conversation had to be
adjusted you can do this the easy way
he's like I need you to decide this
she's like I don't have a pin he's like
we write this in blood these days
legendary all right your whole name too
Jim you know how to use cursive right
I don't want none of those initials I
want your full government
you got a middle name Jim put it on the
paper
[Applause]
messy today bro yum y'all like Zion in
The Matrix today the ring looked just
like this
you know I I've been looking at this
chat I don't see you know free R Kelly
trolls I'll be watching y'all when the
news don't go that way there's a certain
subset that does not come to IOP and
don't make me call your name cause
that's what I'll be missing right now
yeah
you said you're gonna be messy bro
there's certain people that talk that
talk constantly but if there's good Xbox
news there's nowhere to be friends
it's just a disingenuous stuff when when
things don't go their way based on their
bias of things when they don't show up
that's the particle every time you're
gonna get like that though I like when I
say shut up they shut up nobody just
it's for where we from it's just like
being a man yo the Lord
like that I know they say we get it
wrong we still here we Face the music
yeah but that's what you do is get it
wrong these dudes been telling them the
deal's gonna get blocked all this
hellacious stuff and all this all of a
sudden concern for the industry Sony
would never do this Sony and then the
things happen and then they disappeared
that's the part that grabs me crazy
their magic tricks are the best
I know I know parents know what I'm
talking about
I'm just here for King
No Doubt
uh let's put the crest in the chapel
Lord bronze Trail Roberts what's up
troll Barbers thank you sir appreciate
you we have hargit Chaney remember for
two years five dollars for chat destined
only Hebrew this already Dustin what are
you going to do with the APK done four
letters Sega right not Microsoft isn't
done yet then I know though it's Lucas
well I'll see you in the chat absolutely
we got to put a cap at one of these
because
still more like all right so do do like
at least six more six more and then yeah
because we got to get King in Paris we
gotta get his balls off okay yeah then
we got it we got to pay the bills that
way I'll make sure I know I know Optimum
uh traffic yes yes
then we have uh let's put the crust in
the chat for uh Craig hole again ah
Steph did one IOP membership appreciate
you thank you so much no doubt yeah
squirrel 137.92 with the two dollar
Super Chat love the podcast Hold the
Line
thank you let's put the crust in the
chat for a new member five dollar Super
Chat normal people
today we celebrate Victory September 1st
we put our Cognito on the table
oh man
that's gotta be my favorite now when I
call when I call Cog on the phone I'd be
like what's up Lord Cognito oh man
y'all I was cool with the beefy now
y'all going too far
y'all doing too far
salute then we have King is overrated
five dollar Super Chat love to see Lord
Dustin in the realm just called for
another service call hope everyone has a
good day here's to a 60 plus hour work
week
before I guess about yourself hey we
have Dragonheart yo me remember for two
years five dollar Super Chat until the
U.S gets their internet infrastructure
to a perfect balance cloud gaming will
not be prominent China has that down pat
already that's true that is very true uh
let me see I think he's getting ready
two more two more
rocker Corey five dollar Super Chat Bill
Daddy Spencer said to crying lion fly
Ryan Jim Ryan Press X to bend both knees
like a good boy yo not to press X damn
pause
and finally for now for now Mandingo
make seconds remember for two years two
dollar Super Chat Sony bent both knees
elbows and put the chin to the chest wow
yo
wow wow so look you know we still got
more you know obviously it's a it's like
I I almost consider this for the Xbox
your beauty like one of my favorite
movies all time is the Matrix you know
and and King is kind of like our
Morpheus in a way right so it's like
yeah it reminds me of the face for me
hear me and we are still here you don't
say like if the machines were coming to
a babe with King David's the Tulsa King
you know the floor is yours out your
cameras I don't know what is going on
Paris Lily has arrived for this so I
don't know what's happening Paris so
King what do you say
I hope everybody likes sing-alongs
oh
Spartans
present arms
forward March
[Music]
what is he doing
he about to be too extra this is extra
about to get demonetized
[Music]
we're about to get copyright we're done
no we're not
but today
hold down the line
all you jellyfish that ran
this is your weapon whoa
I am my weapon
this is my armor this is my shield oh I
will never yield not one time did I
think this deal will get blocked and I
told you maggots to stand in line and
stand next to me now this is the day
that I have promised you I told you if
you stand tall you will receive the
promised land here we are here those
that ran in fear
I want you to look over and I want you
to see that brother right next to you
that sister right next to you that held
the line with you you had all the ups
and all the doubts but you did not Bend
break or fall trailer you are made of
Sterner stuff the stuff that Legends are
made of we have individuals here that
are frauds those guys ran and we know
who you are they're trying to come back
wait a second
I have a new phone
what is that
the FTC unfolded
the CMA is on the Run
and the main protagonist has signed the
deal
yes we have them right where we want
them
beneath the Boop
and we will not let up we will continue
to press we will push this line so far
down they throat they will choke the
line for months in a week do not give in
do not fold do not break we understand
now Phil Dominus Maximus Spencer is the
closer and he closed this deal
you stood tall
now with all those badges that we gave
out weird I'm proud because you earned
them
I do not want to see anybody false
flagging out there the king they want to
celebrate if they want to say we're
scared
but it was looking spooky
can we fold them not having the
confidence and then you giving the the
community inspiring the community you
must reapply and you must have a made
man or made woman vouch for you
now go get your Xbox series X than us
and get right back in line Soldier and
if you don't have this you don't have
ish
wow what what what a day I mean General
I will say it was it was almost like a
Transformers moment you know light our
darkest hour things were not looking
good the CMA blocks the deal at the time
the red four reviews PlayStation
showcase imminent It Was Fear red
rampant across the Xbox station can we
say but you you gave us the inspiration
that we clearly needed and now that
fateful day has come Jim Ryan has bet
the knee
10-year deal according to Tom Warren has
been announced and uh here we are so
Paris let's start with you
this has been a serious turn of events
we've this thing has gone on for so long
what are your thoughts on all of this
that has transpired okay I have to start
here I am blessed
that I was here live I've been telling
you I've been telling you this card for
the longest I was like King I I got to
be there because he's going to be a damn
fool and you're a damn fool you are and
I love it I love it but I'm I'm gonna be
real for a second let's go let's go
let's go I'm gonna take this back to LA
when they did the whole Fan Fest and and
all of that man and it was as I was
walking through the JW and I walked by
the infamous breakfast table and I had
it on up in the LA Live
and to be in that crowd and to see how
like Aaron Greenberg specifically just
embraced hold the line yes and that
whole crap everybody in there knew
exactly what it was and that's a
testament to you and the iron Lords and
what you guys have been doing from a
Content standpoint of you never wavered
I mean you know being real about this
for a second you never wavered you're
like look Xbox has a plan they're gonna
figure this out and they did they
figured it out
they got Activision they got Activision
Blizzard they got their whole plan with
the mobile Call of Duty's not going
anywhere they're handing out 10-year
deals like like it's candy the whole
thing is here's how I look at it because
I've seen a lot of feedback online
because I see this as a net positive
right versus trying to look at the
negative side of it where
I see people now saying but you're
consolidating the industry the industry
is being Consolidated here's the truth
it's consolidating whether it's Xbox
doing it or not
we are seeing consolidation happen right
before our eyes so the question I would
push back to anybody on this is
if it's going to change if there's going
to be consolidation I would wanted to
see it be handled responsibly and at
least what we're seeing on paper and
what's being said by by Xbox's
leadership is they're trying to do the
responsible thing they are trying to
bring these games to more platforms they
are trying to give us more value by
putting in their Subscription Service
things like that honestly that's all you
can ask now Phil Spencer came out and
was just like [__] like I've altered
the deal pray I don't alternating
I'll be different from the industry
that's not that's not good for the
industry right but the truth is some of
these games will wind up being exclusive
but other ones where it makes sense like
Call of Duty as an example is going to
stay multi-platform as it should you can
look on the PlayStation side when they
acquired Bungie Destiny Marathon all
these games are going to stay
multi-platform so as a gamer to have
more choice on where I want to play
throwing cross play along with that as
well yes please
this isn't look it in a perfect world
we'd have multiple Publishers you'd have
all these independent Studios and there
would be that flexibility that's not the
truth of the matter it's just not the
reality of this industry right now so
for me and people can call me bias or
whatever I would rather see Xbox doing
what they're doing than to see a tencent
coming
and take everything and now they're
getting it behind whatever
platforms and all that so
got it I'm for this I'm I think this is
a good day that that this is happening
obviously
we can hope that you know there'll be
like a leadership Roundtable or
something they'll explain further
exactly what they're going to do with
some of these IPS where they're going to
live things like that but I think this
is a good day and King
I you got my knees
[Laughter]
look look let me let me say it's one
last thing let's go it was my honor and
pleasure to meet Cog an attic in person
we got to break bread we got to hang out
that was great in L.A so I have King
y'all next yeah
we see you in Seattle but you're not
gonna see me
hey
blame my wife yeah okay bro I hear you
bro sometimes you know concessions must
be made
look you had to make a choice either was
going to be uh LA or Seattle I never
been to Seattle and I just like to go
when I go to these conferences I like to
work right and I thought that
um E3 didn't have enough work for us and
I and I know Pax will always have that
grind that work that scene these
developers seeing these new games and
having those conversations so I had to
make a choice and the choice was
business over pleasure you know doubt no
doubt slip appreciate you brother oh man
this is low we got the legend he's
limited time also the legend Jazz
recorded in the realm one of the most
nervous people coming into this deal
what are they what are they called when
you like abandon the Army he went AWOL
he went away with us he gave us every
reason to think they call that treason
what do you know he's got audio problems
every Xbox two audio issues
with those who abandon us in the midst
of battle who turned tail who you know
what I was talking about I was totally
confident
we have the early process right now
charging you for going AWOL on the iron
Lord
how do you play in front of your king
with that I accept your apology
you know how Jazz truly accepts for his
apology he got to tell Rand right now to
turn his camera
but good try good try I just need to ask
for one thing since this public flogging
of you
this is like the Game of Thrones shame
and then we're flogging them down the
street
all I want to do be on the show with you
and you take that chip
because I did a live chip challenge and
I want to know if you're made of the
stuff that I'm made of
to look at our show when I took that
chip so I want to watch you as you
square them and wiggle sir yeah what are
we doing that Jess oh man uh I think we
got it for Xbox two ultimate this week
aren't we so it'll be
well I don't know we could we could make
an Xbox tool well we're gonna do Xbox to
Ultimate on patreon but the clip will be
posted publicly but it's not just you
it's Gaz and hargit are doing it with
you right oh damn yeah
I would love that you can come on yeah
of course King yeah thank you yeah don't
forget attic you know I mean okay so
I'll make sure you know because you know
you promised I mean I want Cognito as
well all right I'm good how you doing
today
I need to see if people are made of the
stuff that I'm made of if you watch my
videos it's really good but look just
caught it again window centers on half
of the Xbox 2 with the best Xbox podcast
on the internet here we are here we are
you know we got the the the announcement
from Phil 10 years
we got CMA up next
what how are you processing all of this
and how quickly things are moving
well
until might still not go through oh get
out of here
this makes sense
so don't celebrate oh don't pop do it
there goes the jelly spine guys I want
you to see the spine I flipped his head
come on seriously though seriously
though yes
[Music]
um
hopefully with this day with this
PlayStation I'm just gonna I'm I'm
bouncing it quickly about it tonight
because I got things I need to do
appreciate it but um I'm working right
now and I slept all day and it's like
it's throwing everything out of whack so
um my sleep cycle is just crazy right
now but um with this deal with
PlayStation hopefully people are
starting to realize that it was never
PlayStation who was I mean it was about
anchoring Xbox's future in the console
Market you know but this is a longer
fate this is a much forward-facing deal
and this was always about Apple and
Google's duopoly it was always about
mobile but Microsoft talks about mobile
they're completely serious about it and
like we we saw epic games have the
massive court case last year where they
did win some slight concessions but
almost they want almost nothing and it
was it was over this sort of Apple and
Google control how you can monetize on
their platforms Windows does not control
how you can monetize on Windows that's
why we have platforms like steam which
are great for the consumer on Apple's
platform you only have the app store
which is terrible for consumers on on
Google on Google we only have Google
Play Store which is terrible for
developers and um you know and it holds
back Innovation on things like Cloud
Glam cloud gaming platforms which aren't
allowed to be monetized with in-app
purchases on either platform
um with apple completely blocking it out
right but with this deal they get the
cloud to start chipping away that
duopoly and I bet your next year will
see another round of court cases with
apple and now with Microsoft on board
and saying like look we got Call of Duty
we've got Hearthstone we've got fallout
shelter we've got Minecraft we've got
all these Mega games and now we have the
kind of clout to really bring some more
consumer benefits the likes of which we
have on windows with steam epic game
store and all this competition it's a
apple and hopefully this deal will start
making people realize that it was never
about being a dick to PlayStation it was
never about foreclosing Sony like the
ftc's so desperately wanted to allege
without a shred of evidence the judge
laughed that out of court and you know
hopefully people start realizing this
but
um I mean without with all like you know
joking aside completely they say at the
end of it like the deal might they might
be closed maybe that's what I'm about to
ask you this CMA UK reporting on the
scene I need to know what you're feeling
as far as you know the CMA the next
steps well I think the CMA is going to
bend the knee they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna fold it's it's
become political and they're being
attacked by MPS and saying what are you
doing we need this investment because
the UK is a sinking ship what are you
doing pissing off one of Mark's the
biggest corporations on Earth you know
so there's that aspect to it but I think
the CMA stuff will they've got they've
already got a plan in place for that I
think and it probably evolves everything
everywhere which is a telecoms provider
that used to be T-Mobile they're
rebranded in the UK for some reason to
EE it's it's I don't know I think it
might be separate from T-Mobile now I
don't know but they're part of BT which
on our infrastructure for telephony in
the UK so I think like um there's going
to be some kind of concession there but
um the court cases won't end and even
after deals closed right even after
deals closed even after the FTC appeal
goes away the court cases won't end
because Microsoft's now going to go
after Apple and Google I think I'm I'm
so sure of this they're going to go
after app and Google they're going to
make their own mobile app store which we
heard about which is going to have Xbox
integration and all that kind of stuff
and um it's going to be really exciting
like from it from Attack tacky nerd
industry kind of perspective it's going
to be really exciting to see where they
take it against up on Google because I
hate those confidence I hate those
companies so bad you guys know I know
Apple and Google killed my Windows phone
I was like vindictive about that [__]
but yeah it's really exciting and it's
really awesome and you know you guys you
know King what
podcasters you just have that in your
wardrobe
what pray tell are you talking about
are we talking about the crown am I yet
not the king are you talking about my
velvet robe oh
the gold belt this is your day this is
your day bro it's your day
a couple more questions there's a part
in Fable 3 where you become the king and
you have to make decisions on what you
did throughout the game and I could just
see King right now sitting on the throne
be like off with the head oh yeah he's
making decisions right now yes so the
victor goes to spoils
my name will forever be in the annals of
time I told you attic
you must take up the fight you know I
gotta I gotta ask both Jazz and Paris
this because they're here
it's it's what Dustin said earlier yes
let's go Paris I know you're what where
your answer is probably going to be but
I don't think Jazz has heard this
because he's just getting the sleepies
out of his eyes Dustin says take two is
going to be Xbox's next acquisition yep
he said his spider senses are tingling
yeah what do you think Jazz take two
pairs take two what do you think
well I'll just I'll just try them
quickly I mean Rand
did we not talk about this on Xbox 2 a
little while ago a few years ago where
I'd heard that take two was looking for
a buyer you did yeah and that would yeah
that is true wow we know Sony ain't got
that money
they only looking at one person
in the club dancing just looking at them
with the drinking their hand like
I used to buy the drinks too King
they're like yeah
I'm done would you say Jess you heard
one thing
one more thing before Pirates runs in
but I've also heard that Apple is
exploring building a video game console
yeah so if if you were if you were Apple
looking to get into and shake things up
who one thing you'd want to be doing is
buying a publisher right
this is
but I think that that would like you
know regulate this might be a little bit
like if if regulates thought this was
bad apple buys only that might that
might well that you know would be crazy
proper you know I don't I don't think um
they would buy Sony proper I think they
would buy Sony PlayStation brand
you know it would be crazy though it
they took the PlayStation brand and they
kept all the people and it's like now
it's okay you know Sony we know you
can't realistically go bar for bar with
Microsoft but we got the money too that
would be a generous benefactor I've
heard that they're engineering their own
console I've never heard this for a
while they would be the only people I
feel like have the brand recognition and
because you think Xbox Fanboys and
Playstation Fanboys are better talk to
Apple families the thing the thing I I
hold out hope for is that they do make
their own console and they do we need
another one yeah leverage no we don't
because
um not from them if you didn't see that
the virtual reality machine is uh what
was that what what does it be like yeah
some some crazy
thirty five hundred dollars yeah so yeah
like how many people we had in the chat
um that's all give it one dollar y'all
could get one headset
that's what that is and to the fact that
if they do make a console it will be far
out priced because they believe that
their stuff is super pretty if you think
Sony has this arrogance look at the
iPhone look how much the iPhone cost
they would similarly price their console
like the the virtual reality headset it
will be so far it would never penetrate
you you know what they have to do two
King who's that dude that they always
blame he he goes everywhere and he ruins
the company then goes on and runs
another company
let's feel over this let's get parishes
thoughts on what I just was talking
about as well yeah mine real quick and I
don't know the chat was cooking me for
my 240p camera
funny Paris they're saying that your
resolution was still better than Final
Fantasy 16. wow messy
I do not want Xbox to require another
publisher not to that degree not to that
degree yeah yeah it's starting to be way
too much consolidation at that point so
if we get to the point of a take two or
a Sega also joining I need my sake I'm
okay with Sega just not take two that
gets a little messy for me because I I
feel like Sega has very iconic names and
iconic IPS but I don't think they have
anything that like carries the wave as
like a take two mm-hmm and I agree on
that I I think the consolid the the
compromise if that were to happen even
if it was Apple since since we were just
talking about that those IPS got to stay
multi-platform I don't yeah we can all
of a sudden make a Grand Theft Auto
exclusive to one system or something
like that or NBA 2K but it again goes to
the point uh someone like EA throw that
in there too or Ubisoft I think they're
too big of Publishers to want to see get
get Consolidated in that way I think
this Activision thing I like all right
that's enough let's slow up maybe you do
some one-off studios I can understand
that as you continue to grow out you
know their first party lineup but entire
Publishers I do think we still need some
competition some diversity out there
from a publishing standpoint in the
market to keep competition going so and
I do think that they know because of how
close this Activision deal went through
I don't think they would try another big
big big
areas I mean
just just at least
there we go just just just just at least
for two years don't you just want a pure
dominance factor
I mean I mean we did get Shaquille
O'Neal don't you want a pure shocking
like did you like it well not for
yourself sir
didn't you like when young Shaq would
just get on a basketball court you
didn't know what Rim he was going to
tear down uh Microsoft to be so dominant
in this space that you quiver when they
mention new games Microsoft is having a
showcase oh my God I wanted to feel like
Godzilla has been cited I want you to
run for the hills I want you to hide and
look from under your bed
someone someone needs to draw an Xbox
theme Godzilla running towards a place
just imagine like the people being in
score Enix running
continue Paris no no this is this is
what I want being serious for a second I
want Matt booty to deliver on his
promises of a major release every
quarter um
but that's what I want okay that over
the next two years well you know you
know Paris to to even eloquate uh uh
Matt to shoot a booty
um I believe that that guy's the right
guy I've always felt that and uh you
know you don't get a lot of his
publicity in the background because he's
doing the work in the background but
when the paperwork did come out and it
was noted that because of him Standing
Tall to keep those games coming to Game
Pass day and date I think he believes in
the products that he sees coming forward
and then he can deliver on that promise
so he would hold them to their fire to
those words that they did set forth so I
think he's the proper person for that
job and I think he would hold that line
for you no I agree with that and it's so
funny when uh him and Phil were on the
Giant Bomb couch yes right and Phil got
that twinkle in his eye when they
started talking about
um ID yes yeah they got some stuff
coming they for sure got some stuff
coming and even going out of that
showcase just getting that glimpse into
the future of okay we're starting to get
there and I think Phil even when we
interviewed him he had even said he can
see it they know what it's going to look
like over the next two to three years
they just got to start delivering it but
I don't think you need another
acquisition to do that
um internal Studios right now even
without activities Never Enough
hold on let me get let me get ready
because that's what I want perfect
transition and I love because we're
getting opposing views on what should
happen next and I love this is very
important discussion so ran me you have
obviously talked about stuff like this
ABK is now where where we are the you
know we're at that we're getting close
to the Finish Line This thing is almost
wrapped up put a bow on it but to your
point and what Paris is saying and and
even Dustin was alluded to maybe take
two like what is your thoughts in
reference to to Xbox and the possible
continuation of acquiring more Studios
before standing patent well you know
they're not going to stand Pat because
the competition's not going to stand Pat
right tencent just acquired another
studio just this past week with Lucid
games right right they're always
dropping 20 or 40 like owning in
companies and Sony they've been making a
lot of Acquisitions as well so you know
and then you have other company I think
there was that uh that rumor it wasn't
really rumor it was reported that like
EA was almost acquired by Comcast
but who's to say EA isn't going to get
bought out by somebody else I mean they
did just sort of split up their
divisions right you have your the sports
side and your your uh other other uh
side which kind of like looks kind of
good if you're trying to maybe sell
yourself off
on Amazon possibly so the thing is
when I look at Xbox and it's like okay
we got 15 Xbox games too you know Xbox
game studios 15 Studios under Matt booty
you have Bethesda you have the Call of
Duty teams or what's coming from
Activision Blizzard
um the thing is it's like it's not
enough it's like you could never have
too much and what I mean by that is
because you have all the stuff but still
2022 was as light as you could possibly
be right right for content and with the
fact that video games are taking longer
and longer which matters it's no longer
it's no longer two years or three years
it's now four five and six for AAA games
right and sure you can kind of mitigate
some of that by maybe having you know
making two two games at a studio instead
of instead of one but then delays always
happen and delays can really screw up
your your um you know your fiscal year
22. go ahead and Paris go ahead yeah if
I could jump on on your point because I
I want to be crystal clear on what I
mean by this of course this is going to
be an arm race of course PlayStation is
going to have a counter of Court you
know on down the line there's there's
going to be a response to this happening
it's inevitable I think my my point
again going all the way back to the
consolidation thing is the more that one
or two Publishers basically controls the
entire Market That's not healthy for the
entire industry and my my personal
opinion I would rather see instead of
acquiring existing Publishers existing
Studios let's curate more new Studios
into your internal into whatever it was
going to be I know that takes time and I
know that's not going to happen
overnight and clearly we've seen through
this FTC trial why Microsoft has done
what they've done with Bethesda now
Activision because they needed immediate
results think about this year of Xbox
game studios without Bethesda it's
pretty damn light oh yeah so hey Paris
yeah go ahead about me and you come up
with a proposal for Microsoft
because you're giving me an idea and I'm
gonna run with it right the king in
Paris contract this yeah listen listen
we open up uh Microsoft college right
and we get the best and the brightest
new students in developing games and we
can just poach the match they come out
and we can put them new Studios right
there building from the ground up before
they even get anywhere we're not
purchasing any good Publishers we just
getting the best of the best all the new
ones come our way
yeah I think the biggest issue with that
I think the reason
I think the biggest reason that they do
go for Publishers is because they want
them to self-operate and they because
right now if they were to buy anything
it would either go under Bethesda
Activision Blizzard king or Microsoft
Studio and I think all three of those
maybe blizzard could take a little bit
more because they have a lot more of of
just here audience I mean they have a
lot more people employed so maybe they
were able to manage another Studio or
two but I don't think that they could do
those individual ones like they would
have to like build a publisher like from
the scratch like have someone over them
have people managing it like I think
that's the reason that they're very
focused on on publishing ours because
they do all that for them they just
gotta they just gotta go okay here's the
person you talk to
now I want to get ready to finish this
story and then I do have to ask Jess a
couple more questions because I know
he's unlimited time but um Ran So finish
your thought in reference to well yeah
so like it's not gonna stop
um I mean who knows what the future is
going to hold I know I mean Dustin was
out there with the take two thing
because I'm just like really gonna go
have to take two like immediately it's
like well I don't know I mean even Sega
which I think makes a lot of sense but
like when I look at it it's like
I don't want to be the Debbie Downer in
this thing but like ABK is going to be a
lot of work that's a lot of work
absolutely right like APK is like
equivalent to three bethesda's together
I mean like so there's a lot of problems
there you know from the the the the
harassment issues and all the the you
know the stuff that they have that they
have to clean up right and you have to
carry Cod forward and you talk about
like hey we need to make sure that Cod
is
successful that Cod is bringing in the
money that all the all these things are
and it's like do you have to change how
Cod operates and how the studios run
stuff it can you actually in this day
and age
make a card game every single year or is
that whole thing just
uh about to blow up in your face right
we saw Vanguard was troubled production
came out and it was even though it was
like the best-selling game of the year
it was pretty awful from from Call of
Duty standards they even in the
documents they lost like 50 million
players sure they got it back with
modern warfare too but now you have this
thing where like this year wasn't
supposed to be a Cod game it was
supposed to be an expansion and then
suddenly now it's a full-fledged CoD
game I'm not expecting great things from
this one you know
I think what I would prefer ran Paris is
I want them to just chill for like a
year and a half to two and just and just
like tighten the grip with the current
ones they have now
I can't this is not mustard heart day
this is you're bringing the show down
how do we put the show down being
realisticated okay get down there but
what I want to do is make sure that we
Temple okay so give me give me a logical
give me a logical argument for how they
could do before your billion dollar
purchase after this 70 billion dollars
I gave you a logical argument before
y'all laughed at me and who held the
line in your ran
a lot of people argument that you give
kick why are you upset
why are you upset that they can't buy
this 50 billion dollar company right now
stop stop with the monster hard talk you
know as we see knees will be bent even
on Sundays
um not too much anyway
a jelly spine we today is not the day
for that anybody that's watching today
is the day for strength and we will push
the line so if take two is what we want
to do we will wish and we will push and
we will hope for that and if Destin can
see it you can see it so I see it now
and I want it
I'm not going through 18 more months
my only thing sorry is is I just want
time to to really get in the in the
movement with Activision Blizzard I
don't want them the moment they finish
Activision please oh take two looking
mighty fine
can we learn how to functions in all
seriousness this is exactly what's going
to happen that deal is going to get
closed you're gonna hear it like in a
month or two they're gonna win they're
gonna go right over there embrace the
group remember that bag I told you to
hold for me Chris yeah give me
listen they're going to give them that
money
um from all indications from what I hear
square and Sega is the hardest to get
because
um that they're foreign I think you go
in and you you put in and you buy
controlling shares of all their stocks
right if they continue to operate
exactly how they're operating and the
fact that you have control issues you
have a bigger seat at the table we're
going to take two squares
The Entity that they are you you know so
so in the comment section can you say my
Sony started this by trying to get star
filled so that Microsoft gotta buy the
whole industry well you know they got
the money to do it somebody sound like
they salty
um the thing is you got to look at it
for for what it is right 10 cent is
going out here giving money they're not
giving money
for to take over they're giving money to
have some type of control at the board
sitting on the board allows you to have
a vote and then those votes but they'll
own the board oh you're talking about
just buying shares right okay just go in
there and get control and stake you
don't have to go buy the company
and if you can get them to sell that
then that's how you circumvent
circumvent the FTC and the CMA you have
controls what he's describing is a
long-term hostile takeover
[Music]
we got that part but I want to talk to
you because one thing that we're really
not talking about we talked about the
mobile we talk about quality adnosium
but what I love that you're here because
of is he here because I don't see his
face
oh there we go okay I was nervous Okay
cool so um the thing I'm I'm glad you're
here because no one's talking about the
PC portion the blizzard portion you know
moving forward with that what happens to
your beloved wow and then what does a
ABK Microsoft future look like what are
the things that you think will
anticipate happen we got departures
potentially Bobby white get his you know
golden parachute what happens with the
fate of Mikey Barra there's a lot on the
blizzard side that I'm very curious and
I want to know what you feel about that
jazz
well I'll say this now for anyone in
Microsoft who's watching if you [__] up
World of Warcraft
I know you love it I know you're using
an Xbox too where you could swear
you continue but anyway
um
world of warcraft's in a really good
place right now like I'm writing an
article next week that's this tired like
World of warcraft's quietly having its
best expansion ever you know
um and I really feel like Mikey Barra
has injected a sort of
I I don't know but since Mikey bar World
of Warcraft stopped trading war and
started innovating again like the the
Cadence the pace of content Commonwealth
I'd never known it before like every
every as soon as they ship a patch they
drop patch notes for the next patch
saying like okay here's the next bit of
content coming every few weeks it's
crazy I've never known worlds I have
this before I don't know if that's all
completely on mic or whatever but
something's changed to blizzard in the
last few years in a positive way you
know world warcraft's doing really well
OverWatch is here but uh Diablo 4 just
launched I think it's Michael borrow
yeah I do right because I think Mike
actually is a gamer of this Mike is
definitely a game he's confirmed I could
call someone there's a difference
between being a gamer and actually
playing the games you're overseen yeah
right exactly exactly I'm every time
even when Michael's at Xbox I lug on my
Xbox and I see Mike and my friends list
he was always on World of War bro all
the time Factory
um
but that's that's the kind of the fear I
have is that like Microsoft's going to
come in and and a lot of this sort of
senior senior level developers who've
maybe been there for past 10 10 20 years
and they've got stock and they're just
going to take the bag and retire like
like there could be a huge amount of
disruption coming to blizzard right in
that could make it in a negative way you
know and as a player of Blizzard games
and someone who you know I've always
said this for me this was not about Xbox
it's about blizzard you know I am I am
blizz on about on a shame blizzard
Fanboy I got a whole time
you have more confidence
because I just don't have confidence
here okay but listen I got you if okay
like you waving and you feel like nobody
got that jelly spine King
but I got him nobody goes into a
marriage saying you know she might cheat
we ain't gonna do that today we we're
going into this hoping for the best
she's gonna be the best she's ever been
She Gonna Shine the best every day we
wake up it's gonna be a new beautiful
day and the fact that we send our
Emissary over to Mikey bar shout out to
you thank you for doing all the kind
work that you've done over there see he
got it that was a Microsoft guy went
over there fixed your wild and we bring
them back but to kick but to Jess's
point you know once this completes
there's gonna be some Exodus do you
think and I just go back to Jazz nobody
found out
what you know how Sony made people you
know stay on they right nobody nobody
signed nothing we don't got none of
those I don't know but they're still
regardless even if that there is a time
frame we've seen with Bethesda that time
frame ended and you had people leaving
after that time frame because it just
depends when it comes to Mike Ybarra
he's very passionate I don't know if
like there's really bad blood between
when he left but if there is it just
depends on how Pat his passion for
working in the games ecosystem that he
loves which is wow and Beth and blizzard
does that surpass that there is beef
between the two companies or or the bio
so the question I got for jazz is the
fates of two former Xbox Star Wars which
are well respected Mikey Barra and of
course who I effectively called The
Finisher Rod Ferguson who who is
notoriously known to get games through
the Finish Line get them across we had
Cliffy be in the realm he always credits
Rod Ferguson for being instrumental to
Gears of War and the success that it has
during the 360 and its Heyday you know
what do you think are the face of those
two do they stay on or hey bio you can
cash out what do you think well this is
this is this is where the pessimism
comes in you know because I think I
think I can see I can see like people
like Michael Rod like leaving maybe this
thing there's a lot of unknowns here I
might go Instinct for whatever reason
and it's to always think like what's the
caveat here what's the what's the nasty
surprise hiding in the wings like maybe
there was bad blood between Mike and
Xbox maybe Mike doesn't work want to
work for Microsoft anymore maybe Rob
doesn't want to work for Microsoft
anymore maybe these guys are like man I
know how they operate corporately and
okay to say it
but look at what Microsoft did to Halo
okay
um
and I'ma say this once you put on your
little conspiracy hat and your little
conspiracy had it's cool
um I got a tinfoil hat on it was all
under this and um I actually need a
tinfoil help for a prop solve get on
that
um aluminum how about this how about
they were sent over there as double
agents oh my God and and and because hey
his conspiracy here's another road when
I say my conspiracy is oh it's
ridiculous but they got purchased right
because they didn't get they got
purchased after we send the agents over
so this is a Sleeper Cell agent okay are
you saying this is like some corporate
Espionage
and you're gonna tell us all the info
and we're gonna use that info to buy the
company
Mike and Rod was riding High when they
left and they went over there and they
did some nice things over there I'm just
saying hail Hydra what if they are
double agents what if they did get over
there and prep the runway for Microsoft
to land that plane
all the Rocks off the roadway so they
can land I mean all right kid to give
you fuel to your theory thank you all my
sports announced in Paris you appreciate
this when the deal was announced so
close to announce was the um the final
blocking I guess of MTC Mike mcbara had
a [__] cryptic gift where he had the the
bottom of the knife Kirk was it Kirk
Gibson yeah hits the Home Run for sports
aficionados we know that's like one of
those improbable comeback Sports kind of
uh memories like the timing of that was
interesting so to me if you're not Pro
the deal or you plan on leaving why are
you putting out that messaging what did
you take from that person I'm just
curious because you're a sports guy oh
maybe he's pointing out that messaging
because he's like hey Microsoft I like
you guys yeah so
yeah gadgets maybe he's trying he's
trying to like you know try and signal
that he wants to stay right and you know
and that is not certain that Microsoft
to let him you know well guys okay yes
what he's actually signaling is World of
Warcraft has come to PC game pass that's
what he said
remember that huge
not possible not rolling well well what
I've thought is they could do something
off work because one of the things about
wow is the subscription is the whole
business model yeah right right
ultimate package The Game Pass well this
is well this is what I'm thinking right
like the the World of Warcraft fan base
is pretty static it's all the same
people who play it over and over again
there's not that many new players coming
in Lane Blizzard's working to fix that
um but for now it's always the same
player so if you put that into Xbox game
pass it's really to Xbox game pass
benefit and it's not going to benefit
World of Warcraft at all because you
you're splitting that income amongst you
know all the royalties that have to be
paid out from PC game pass and stuff
like that but what I've thought is what
they could do like an extended trial
period through PC game pass like because
right now the trials up to level 20
maybe a PC game pass you go up to level
60 and then you start to buy the the
next expansion and then subscribe to get
the the new the new expansion experience
I think they will do something with it
but I people saying like the whole game
is going to be on there I think I'm
going to be solely disappointed
I think you're spun on with that that's
kind of my my thought being serious for
a second that you use it as an entry
point to get people into you know the
World of Warcraft ecosystem whatever you
want to call it and then you get to a
certain level at that point if you want
to continue you know you have to
monetize it outside of the subscription
service but it would then be a great
benefit to game pass because you're
going to get an influx of new people
that want to subscribe to it and it'll
be a benefit to World of Warcraft
because you're going to get new people
to jump into World of Warcraft no doubt
those other things too like the twitch
drops and stuff like a lot of like every
month there's like something you can get
for World of Warcraft or Diablo
Hearthstone or OverWatch even through
Amazon Prime on Twitch you could bring
all that to PC game pass instead because
Amazon's going to become your Chief
competitor very very soon I think if
they do by EI which is rumored
um and uh you know you can bring some of
that those benefits to Xbox game pass as
well but like this this is where some of
my nerves come in okay there's like so
many unknowns there's so many
uncertainties like we don't know what
Microsoft that Microsoft relationship is
like Mikey bar and Rod Ferguson these
days we don't know what might if
Microsoft understands World of Warcraft
business model or if that they just
blink it and all they see is like PC
game pass PC game pass we don't know
what Microsoft plans are for battle net
for example like I I thoroughly expect
like Microsoft could do a Dom and be
like okay well we'll get rid of
bottleneck we'll integrate with the Xbox
app which everyone hates whatever
everyone loves battle NetApp so you know
I I just I'm just nervous that they're
gonna they're gonna come at this with a
bludgeon rather than a surgical knife
and really think about how they can
benefit because their their mentality is
okay this is too big to fail and it's
it's money that we need to start making
right away I just hope they're gonna
take a very considered approach to this
because
you know like I I honestly like it does
come back to Halo for me Phil himself
said if we screw up Halo We scroll back
they they really screwed up halo I'm
sorry they have nearly killed that brand
um
we'll keep it moving keep get your
thoughts finish your thoughts there's
like
they're Halo like supposedly Halo
infinite's in a good place right now but
there's no one playing it look on Twitch
there's like there's more people
watching Heroes of the Storm yeah which
is a dead blizzard property which is in
maintenance mode then watching Halo
infinite on Twitch what does that say
about what Microsoft
what do you play Halo infinite no
because it's bad because you're part of
the problem
[Laughter]
you know you said it's in a good place
but you said okay so you saw the place I
haven't played it I'm not interested
okay you're not interested I've never
been interested
he's always been a good guy I just I I
just want to say you said it's in a good
place
I want how is it in a good place if
nobody's playing it supposedly so I mean
I mean the quality of the game like the
match is working out last time I played
it the matches were laggy and and there
was all these issues with the servers
and and you know loads of problems and
stuff like that the last time we played
it on our community stream that we'll be
doing another Community stream because
it seems like Halo is in a good place
y'all
um my brother has been playing it a lot
my brother has been playing with an
absurd amount yeah anecdotal but to
Jess's point the place
I'm not gonna stop messing with him
because I see sometimes
that you know he he gravitates to the
dark side
and I want to pull him I want to pull
him back over here speak the truth King
but I just I just want to pull him back
into the light and let him know and at
this different day I want to point out
Jazz that Gene says you and a Halo guy
so look to to
um to um paris's point in reference to
uh
no this is great listeners I know what
I'm in for I knew what I was in for for
today
um the thing is like what do you feel
about the consolidation in because Paris
does make a good point I know I'm Lord
acquisition but I gotta be balanced a
little bit I'm right there with Paris on
this one yeah addicts with Paris you
know what I'm saying Rands with me I I
don't mind if they if they purchase more
I just want them to tighten the Fist of
the stuff they own now I think that's
valid I think everything you're saying
there's nothing wrong what you're saying
and we do know the amount and the volume
that comes with an ABK because we're not
talking like one publisher they just
they're about to buy three three
blizzards back to back what what if I do
what three blizzards back to back there
we go for taking place we need that
um
the thing is Now jazz I never got your
feeling now now that your fears should
be alleviated ABK is pretty much done
in a post ABK world what side do you
lean on as far as Microsoft with future
Acquisitions I need to know what you
think
I think like I mean this is gonna be the
last point because I need to know yeah
thanks to everyone who's is put up with
my pessimism and the panels I gotta deal
with it every freaking day it's annoying
can't give him some positivity the
deal's gonna go through and jazz is
going to be well actually this could be
bad
with regards to Acquisitions I think
that should do more and I you know I
said I said on our show like until until
they've caught caught up Sony on that
Gap
um they can't be complacent they also
need stock Xbox series X consoles and
you know all this begins and ends with
console if you kill the console brand
you're gonna kill the whole brand you
know I don't want to see a world where
Microsoft's just be like oh well
consoles not that important anymore
let's become a PC publisher I don't want
to live in that world so and I assume
all of you guys don't want to live in
that world either so
um sure strengthening their position in
console has to be absolutely the goal
short term they can do that horizontal
expansion whatever but like I will
always push for the console as a console
guy primarily
um you know I play PC for World of
Warcraft and heroes of storm because
there's no choice but right um I prefer
a console but um
uh we've got to and so to solidify
Xbox's place in that world you kind of
need your
your the games that are appealed to you
know Asian markets so I would I would
honestly think well if like if they
could get one more
shirts
Capcom aquarionics Sega one of those all
of those no one of those one of those I
think that would be I I like Sega is a
good one to get like a football manager
they've got they've got uh they've got
RTS Studios who can work on Starcraft or
or they got Persona Sovereign
but like I would honestly I would not be
surprised if Microsoft's looking at
Square Enix because one of the goals
around this was Unix I would lose my my
thoughts you're not worried about their
managing anything what would you do what
would you do what would you do if they
brought Square earnings what would you
do
what are you willing to do
oh who are you talking to you
yes sir so you're you're asking me sir
are you gonna let me finish or is this a
rhetorical question yeah I just was
answering who I was talking to mm-hmm
so so are you asking me if I would if I
would bend the knee
if I would bet my knees that they
wouldn't buy screens that's too easy
what are you asking okay
um
I don't know you got just doing one trip
if you don't know then how are you doing
I'm not trying to scare you away
sir
I see it that's too easy because Jazz is
doing a one trip challenge oh you want
to make addicts suffer yes oh okay so
you try to you try to build conviction
and confidence in them you feel he's
being too yeah
public vlogging is not working okay okay
the perfect Ambassador
so are you clear so you want me to eat
whatever the hell that chip is called if
they buy squares you want to do a one
chip challenge yeah if they buy squares
all right so let's listen listen from
from this day we got one year for them
to go into talks to purchase Square wow
okay so and next year on this date
if they are not in talks or they have
not purchased Square
I will take a check you've got that much
confidence in Square Enix take a second
check it out and if they do
go into talks within this year
or purchase them you would take the chip
at it it got one year that's a pretty
good deal good deal that's a good deal
one year I mean you could put that up
because you already took the chip yeah
doing one chip where's One chip see this
my king is right this is the Mustard
Seed no no see I'm gonna do this I just
need a little sprinkle on see you always
want to do things
you you don't get no sprinkle it's one
chip versus one what's your first one
it's your conviction versus my
conviction yeah your heart versus my
heart
let's go
again but from this date one year
the acquisition of Xbox acquiring Square
Enix right if it happens one chip
challenge goes out attic has to do the
one chapter if it happens or if it had a
discussions
I said they have to the discussions go
into discussions or or purchase or
purchase so okay so so the announcement
is an interest in order for me to do
this I I feel like the the ways to term
it is too loose okay what do you mean
discussion okay like I don't want some
like leaked documents saying they're
gonna buy them like okay Microsoft has
to formally do that that that image that
Activision image that blizzard image
that blizzard image that's finalization
let's just say we get the Jazz quarters
they have to have that Xbox
diaphragm thing Square Enix with all
their icons behind them that is what I
need in order for them I'll join that
back I'll join that wait wait
after I go on your show this week you
can talk that after that all right after
you oh no he wants it now let's go
stop trying to run why are you trying to
run I don't want you trying to get
nobody I've already buckled up I'm
trying to get my co-star buckle up why'd
you let it go all the way stand on your
own
but but but yes and this is I'm giving
just that out because I just don't take
that out yes don't listen to this dude
there's room for you Jess don't let him
act like that yeah
I did this chip
I want to talk to you after you do the
chip okay with your mind is I'm not
going to tell you oh take this bet and
you have a nervous breakdown after you
take this [__] are you thinking about it
yeah
you're acting like we don't have to have
an ambulance on Deck when this happens
the whole law got a good point do you
guys agree with the square eating bet
between attic and King they announce it
at like just deciding remember when last
year is they you know the announcements
who are quiet does that count yeah I I
am calling I will be okay as long as
that initial tweet we have acquired even
if even if they put that like they did
with the Activision thing that almost
didn't go through right as long as that
tweet is on Phil Spencer is on the Xbox
side they have saying that they have
they have they have went into
arrangements to buy Square Enix right
and the whole like images there saying
like you know
but what if we get on the wiggle away
right but what if
what if we get to Jazz quarter report
the Tom Warren report Microsoft in talks
to does that no no I need it officially
from Xbox because I because they they
went into buying it with Bethesda took
like a year and a half to do it it took
almost two years to do a vaccines
there's no reason why Xbox they did it
with everyone else that I need a
third-party dude telling me this is a
third party dude I need it straight from
the sources map because we know we know
k n news
soft touch imma go with you and um
and I did this before I did this before
and it worked and it worked so well you
act like you have a winning record
against me by the way bill
by the way attic here Mike is peeking
pretty pretty bad that's cool it could
peeking King's ears
let's take him down
okay I know I know I know you did this
for me this this Sunday and that was a
wonderful gift I do appreciate you
I do appreciate that but this is the
moment that we gotta take this dude down
we already saw the paperwork where y'all
went into initial talks we already see
the battle plan to purchase them as soon
as this deal is done let's wait the 60
days and let's go after attic means
let me talk to Phil too Bill ain't
listening Phil do everything that man
said cause that's one bet I will want to
lose oh that oh okay so you want that
okay fair enough real quick elastic uh
and I gotta get you because just got
gotta go Tom Anderson says um of King
you got to pay him a second project Q of
the year to do the fake lead square and
talk are you willing to take that with
Tom Henderson based on your cute but he
said he already got to give me a q like
what he said well he said he go if
you're gonna pay him a second Q like but
because you said the price you gonna
give me the first one like
you saw the price bruh slide that to me
like the top come on the show and have a
good time
you're already a console now
fed up so so again like finally before
you head and then we get ran and then
we'll open it up socks off and patient
um in reference to you know future
how it's looking ABK like the future and
you know that post acquisition World
stuff I just wanted you to finalize your
thoughts today before you leave
um what is the thing the future looks
like yeah I think the future is going to
be pretty quiet for the interim I mean I
think like one of the things you've seen
this week was all of the classic Call of
Duty servers started working again all
of a sudden mysterious mysteriously my
brother was playing it last night too
it's like they wanted that to heighten
an announcement or something
yeah I mean I think there's um I think
Paris Paris just said they have to
bounce yeah yeah I just yeah I'm sorry I
didn't want to interrupt but no I
appreciate you guys having me up it's
got conversation King your damn fool you
message hell I'll see you later
much love brother hopefully King when I
win that Square Enix I'm gonna need you
to send me that cards God bless thank
you for showing up love you my dude no
doubts salute salute continue to finish
it up
I was just saying like I don't think
like in the in the sort of in the short
term I don't think anything major is
going to change but I think like you'll
see quote the classic Call of Duty games
hit Game Pass you'll see some of the
maybe some of the holdouts
in the chat for real
I want to point out uh he said attic got
a wedding DJ Mike everyone got to say
Mike but I'm the one that's a wedding DJ
Mike
Phil Spencer in the chat says welcome
fellow Gamers we are proud to announce
Sony has agreed to the agreement that is
definitely not that is definitely right
okay that is not the doctor you call
back to you back to you Jess
Bethesda like we've waited a lot a good
few years before we actually saw Xbox
oriented benefit to that really yeah we
got Dishonored in Game Pass and all that
kind of stuff but I think like when it
comes to exclusive games or you know
games that are you know sort of native
to the Xbox platform with the Xbox
ecosystem and things like Call of Duty
marketing deal or you know someone said
it's dark Phil
yeah good too
um I think I think could be a few years
I think Tom Warren said in in there was
some core documents I said Call of Duty
carnic game pass until 2025 I think I
read
um and that's probably as a result of an
existing deal in place with Sony because
Sony does do those deals like hey you
want to put your game on our system you
have to agree not to put it in Game Pass
for x amount of years
um we've seen that happen but
um down the roads
God knows what can happen like you you
probably see exclusive games from
blizzard you'll probably see exclusive
games from APK maybe some of the classic
franchises like crash or Spyro or Tony
Hawk or the field name checks stuff like
Guitar Hero and Skylanders and Starcraft
like a lot of this stuff could come to
Xbox exclusively because this deal I was
told by a Microsoft spokesperson only
covers Call of Duty yes I was about to
say breaking news right now looks like
what you just said uh in Time Warren
confirms Microsoft has confirmed you six
minutes ago to the version that Sony's
10-year Call of Duty is limited to Call
of Duty only Microsoft originally
offered to keep existing activists yo
you broke it sorry Jess Gordon window
Central
back division console titles were sold
including future versions of current
Activision games on PlayStation until
the end of 2027. so wow that the terms
the terms of Engagement Jazz what does
that mean what is that what is that City
ranges what do you feel about that
I mean isn't it kind of what Ron said
Ron said on our podcast that he thinks
that he thinks the the Xbox
um the blizzard Survivor game project
Odyssey he thinks that's going to be
exclusive to Xbox One wow
do you want to challenge me no I'm not
doing that dude I'm not doing that no no
I'm saying look it's kind of what I I
said earlier and when we were talking
about them bending the knee right yes
where Sony thought they had the leverage
and and Jim was pushing to get all the
games he was pushing to get all the ABK
games in Bethesda games and Phil's like
pause no right and you can probably
point to that as as Jim even said that
was the breakdown right right maybe this
whole situation goes down a lot smoother
if Phil had agreed and then they and
then and then PlayStation backs away
from the FTC backs away from the CMA and
the deal goes through but Microsoft is
kind of locked into this 10-year thing
where they have to provide all the games
to PlayStation right but now that the
FTC folded like a cheap tent right and
the deal looks like it's on the verge of
closing you know Jim Ryan comes
scurrying back to the table gotta sign
the deal because gotta make sure parody
and all that stuff is there but now they
don't have any leverage because now it's
like this deal is closing with or
without you and so it's like the terms
of the conditions have changed like like
King I think you said it earlier like
the deal today or the deal yesterday
today's price right right so now it's
like you know what you we offered this
to you eight months ago and we are ready
to give you the whole thing
you know not getting it anymore now
you're just getting Cod and everything
else
Odyssey whatever other excuses we may do
a prototype what happens to Diablo well
I mean the next Diablo's 10 is probably
12 10 years away anyways no but I'm
talking about like what about Diablo for
the game pass and Call of Duty for the
game oh it's going to Game Pass I mean
it'll go to game pass this is the
question of when what about quality Duty
though what we think about quality well
that's I mean that's the other thing did
I mean maybe there was like
because there was rumors that maybe Jim
was gonna be like all right I don't want
Call of Duty marketing this year screw
it maybe Xbox gets to marketing maybe I
I don't know I don't know what happens
right uh but it's just interesting to
see that now this the deal only covers
Cod when before it might have covered
more right and simply because you went
from a position of weakness to a
position of power right so yeah you you
only get caught sorry and everything
else is probably even a case-by-case
basis right got a report card
how you been this week Jimmy
have you been in the principal's office
well you know what that means Jim no
Diablo for you
it's like the first offense like they
you know they they talk back to the
teacher you get Diablo in six months
it looked like they go public he even
pay she didn't get a chance to get his
ball if ran finished because I do got to
get oh yeah yeah yeah plus I'm gonna I
gotta bounce real I'm gonna jump out too
listen Xbox two Xbox two right this has
been a joke everybody else stick around
yeah cause the show's not over and I
have a whole last trick of myself oh one
more trick and I promise this to you
guys and I will fulfill that promise
like I said no doubt I got you dude
because just like y'all had me holding
that line I'm holding that line I
respect it now salute again just going
in ran out though Xbox two monster show
monster show that I had the pleasure to
be invited to and uh I just want you to
tell the people waiting for yourself hey
yeah speak for myself where can you find
it just Gordon on Twitter Bond Man
xvxb2.com as well and uh Windows Central
but that thanks for having me guys I'm
gonna bounce
DM me
um so I can talk to you about uh
something so okay because uh it's a
concern I'll talk to you okay
bro
yo this what a saga has been right what
a song it's been and I wanted to say
this before you head out you know
because a lot of talk is and we haven't
got a chance to talk about it is like
why are people cheering on a trillion
dollar Corporation oh man you know why
are people getting excited this is
potentially death of the industry stuff
and definitely industry you know this is
the talk and and you know I want to ask
you from your perspective as a person
who loves the Xbox platform as a person
with a million Gamers score a person who
who truly puts his heart and soul as far
as into these games and loving the
platform your podcast is namely Xbox too
you know why is this a cause of
celebration for you why does this mean
so much to you in the Xbox community
um
it kind of
I just for me it's kind of like
it comes full circle to like content
creation
of like you like when I started at
YouTube 2016 xBox wasn't in a good place
right the Xbox one generation was not
good there were rumors that things were
winding down so I kind of look at it
like this deal
solidifies Xbox mostly in the eyes of
Microsoft right because Microsoft is
that we always kind of joked around like
hey if Microsoft got rid of Xbox their
stock price would probably go up right
because it's not important to Microsoft
as the overall Corporation right but
through that time right we've seen Phil
somehow convince Satya to buy Minecraft
and everybody at the time was like
Minecraft you overspent for 2.5 billion
dollars you overspent that right yeah
the biggest game in the world they
didn't have the vision right Minecraft
20 million sold at the time now was like
one of the biggest games sold ever right
the money it makes is monstrous
somehow Phil convinces Satya to remove
the Xbox division from underneath Terry
Meyerson and windows into its own
division Phil gets a seat at the table
the executive leadership position you're
like all right
but we need some studios we only got
five right we need to compete start
buying some studios great we're on the
right path things take time but we're on
the right path
all of a sudden you buy Bethesda and
it's like seven billion dollars that's
huge we're getting there we're getting
there and then ABK then it's like whoa
70 billion dollars seven billion dollars
like the compare it's like
the difference is staggering and now you
look at like all right they ain't
fooling around when they're talking
about we're all in right because some
people doubt it like Satya is just
saying it like it's just words doesn't
mean nothing actions speak louder than
words right so you see this and you're
like well Xbox's future is basically
secured right right
um regardless of whatever happens with
Call of Duty in the future you know
essentially that Call of Duty and Candy
Crush and all that stuff is basically
going to be funding and this is kind of
the way I look at it is like that's
basically going to be funding Xbox's
first party for the foreseeable future
the games that I want to play right the
games that everybody is looking forward
to this deal sort of is you know going
to help make those things better Xbox
can especially quarterly oh yeah Xbox
can invest more money into things
because they got more money coming in it
allows them to compete at a better level
against people like tencent and people
like PlayStation you know
you look at like what Sony was trying to
do you know trying to kill off Xbox
making these deals like Xbox had to buy
Bethesda and ABK so you wouldn't have
that situation of like oh they're just
doing these times exclusives taking
these games one year out look at Final
Fantasy and the stuff we don't even get
from Square
you look at it like that it's just it's
like Microsoft is an Xbox is just
they're set they're golden right and
it's it's not going to stop right it's
going to continue because they're gonna
look at some of these individual Studios
and all I've ever wanted was just more
games more quality games at that right
so for me it's a it's it's more it's
it's about like Xboxes here forever
because I know commitment that bothers
people oh I know that chafes people I
know that gets under people's skin that
Xbox is going to be looked at as uh true
competition that Sony and is basically
going to be funding Xbox's first party
moving forward that there actually might
be some sort of competition between the
two when there really hasn't been for
quite some time and that it's not just
it's not that just Xbox rolled over like
a dead dog and like PlayStation walk all
over no they didn't
they fought and they used what they had
to get back into the fight they used
their bank account people want people
forget they wanted this they wanted this
they demand I had to sit down and every
one of my YouTube videos and hear people
tell me constantly Rand we just want
Xbox to compete we just want Xbox to get
better and it's like yeah so do I I used
to email Phil I used to talk to Phil and
parties used to message them about like
would I want to see Xbox do and I'm like
I want Xbox to have
an industry-leading first party because
I want more games from the first party
that take advantage of the things that
you do better than anybody else or
taking put the console to the to the
best you used as you possibly can right
make those special experiences where
it's like you can only get this on Xbox
and you know you always respond and be
like that's what I'm trying to do you
know stuff like that right and he's done
it like he's literally done it beyond
what I could possibly imagine sure there
were some stumbles here and there right
right it's not everything gone smoothly
it taken longer than I expected and some
games weren't as good as they should
have been right but the man did exactly
what you all wanted him to do but oh now
it's like this now it's like well not
like this it didn't mean it like that
not like this well you got exactly what
you wish for and I'm sorry that it burns
I'm sorry
but it's exciting and it's so and and
personally I don't even really care too
much about ABK right I do play Call of
Duty every year for the campaigns I'm
weird like that yeah so yeah it is going
to save me 70 every single year we're
gonna get some exclusives out of it
hopefully prototyping some of the other
stuff come back I would love to see some
of those other Studios allowed to make
other games besides Cod but I just look
at Xbox and I compare to what it was in
2014. and I'm like yo
like the Tran the transition
is almost complete from being this Meek
Mouse and stepped on last step to
basically you know Mighty Mouse
who did that for you who did it who
dedicate so I don't know that that's
really expensive first of his name AKA
The Closer trust and believe that that's
the guy that I picked and I co-signed
that a long time ago so I knew I knew uh
RAM sorry I knew Rand yeah
no no doubt no doubt and and you were
spitting ran and Lasting for the people
who say you know they're fearful of Game
Pass
is the death of the industry you know
you know you should don't you know what
is it the term like you you risk you ask
for it you get what you wish for that
kind of that kind of talk like you know
any concerns with Game Pass or you know
from a consumer standpoint where do you
where you stand with that what obviously
I mean nice yeah not yet I haven't I
haven't seen a degradation and quality
yet right um if if I do I mean then
that's a problem but I don't really see
that because
you just spent all this money
and okay if the next Call of Duty
requires to you to spend 200 million
dollars to make it you're not gonna be
like well can you only do it for 150
because we kind of need to save some
money and you know no because you need
to keep the the value you need to keep
the IP as good as it is you can't just
scrimp on right it's like when people I
don't know I'm a fat dude right so you
go to McDonald's you get like three Big
Macs and some fries and chicken nuggets
and then you go up there and you order a
Diet Coke right like what four like you
ordered everything else here like why
are you skimping on this stuff or you
get a Sunday and you get all this stuff
but you like hold the whipped cream like
what who are you trying to fool you know
what I mean so it's like
I don't I think they're actually
probably gonna spend more to actually
make the games better because that's
what the games deserve it doesn't
prohoove it to be
the stems spend less to make the games
trash because then that is bad for Game
Pass like nobody would want to subscribe
to a service that has crap games and if
Call of Duty becomes crap then the money
that you spent in the acquisition is
essentially worthless right and you're
gonna lose your shirt on the whole so to
me it doesn't make any sense that you
would you would spend less money and
make the games worse that game pass make
stuff work I haven't I haven't seen any
examples of anything yet that
has it shows me that game pass degrades
the quality of games I haven't seen it
yet so oh thank you Mikey Barrow I
appreciate it
oh he just tweeted out something that
just confirmed exactly what I said oh he
just tweeted something out yeah I'll put
it in the chat oh okay you could share
with us no I shared it to you oh no it's
not private jet oh oh wow wow okay
quick looks like shout out to ex Cloud
Tim Dog he put out a tweet to Mike
Ibarra he says we're back with it what
is it Jeff always butcher is it Jeff all
right whatever uh we're back fam and
then Mikey borrowed responds was that a
Darth Vader yes
I love when what I say proves to be
right and um you know the mustard heart
this is not the day of the mustard heart
so if you feel like you're a little
wavery I I'm going to tell you right now
go get yourself some focus and focus
on working on that heart fair enough fed
up but red and I appreciate you brother
you know again my monster show
appreciate you pulling up always love
man this is this is one of those ones
this is a moment in gaming history this
holiday Century this is probably one of
the more cataclysmic shifts and it's
funny we finished saying that after
instead of Max
but this is truly the cataclysmic shift
where can the five people find you what
you got going on sir I mean the people
know where they can find me youtube.com
round of Thor 19. uh thank you guys so
much for having me it was a blast uh
King
you're the best bro I mean seriously I'm
I'm stunned that what you could do up
the top of your head and the Showmanship
that in Charisma that you have facts
that just do this stuff like I'm I'm
floored and you're just you're the best
bro seriously I don't know what else to
even say so thank you all right and I
can't wait to be on the show to watch
Jazz
um
I hope I hope he listens I hope he takes
heed to what I text him because if he do
not you will end up like his move yeah
I appreciate you man brother
hang out with y'all this week I'll send
you the details Cog you know I love you
love brother sovereign
always a pleasure my friend can't wait
to hear what you say about all this dude
and uh whatever add a kid out of here
yeah
so I've got a lot thank you guys all
right brother enjoy later all right so
now for everybody that's still sitting
here um if you didn't already uh like
share and subscribe please do so
um I do have something left and those
are for the people that did remember
exactly what I said I will do and what
will happen and it was prophesizing I
put in and I made sure that I hold up my
ending commitment so we're going to read
this uh these super chats okay you know
sovereign's gonna read these super chats
cause he's a super guy and um y'all gave
him a lot of work and we're gonna answer
all these chats as much as we possibly
can to the best of our abilities and
then I will give you your Just Desserts
guys because
um all you guys that held the line and
stood by me
um and you know I didn't know if I was
gonna stand out there by myself and it
didn't really matter but the fact that I
see everybody rally behind everybody
today we rock Twitter so many people
change the Emojis and um I mean they
profile pic we do have those for the
members that's in here but right now we
do have a shout out to Ben uh we do have
the badge that's there the new badge is
available so you can just you know spam
the chat with those badges uh today is a
celebration people and it's all about
gaming and it's all about gaming
everywhere we won a game removing these
barriers and Microsoft is the people to
lead the charge so today you know they
held the line at E3 they gave you the
best show at E3 yeah and they continue
to turn up and it's on they did it on
the Lord's day and I am nothing but
appreciated all right real quick um The
Legend Tom Warren who's Breaking All the
news he was scheduled to be on today he
just said to you he said sorry guys I
couldn't make it but I love you guys so
salute to Legend from The Verge who
broke the news about the 10-year deal
that's why he couldn't make it he was
like uh I gotta break the news
but he also know he can't come on until
he
I know you were doing the Lord's work
today breaking all the news the Phil
Spencer situation the 10-year deal the
Call of Duty being exclusive to the deal
as opposed to all the deal all the other
gay Activision Blizzard King game
everybody's footing up there oh wow they
putting the badges up in the chat yeah
yo Tom Morrison King I can shave my
eyebrows if you like if you want them so
you could be proud you can be compatible
with Avatar yo you ain't got nothing to
do with that
absolutely it's beautiful to see soft if
you need help remember I got you because
I know you got a lot of work no no I got
it yeah I'm here I'm here to work today
I don't you don't need my opinion you
don't need my opinions today
I'm good listen yeah you already got
here I'm just going to tell you I told
you so when they don't buy take two next
that's it oh so you go on that Dusty
standing on your words okay listen there
I I don't if they buy them eventually
cool next no it's not happen come I'll
be here for the square
that's what I'm here for that was fun
seriously don't let the food he wants to
lose that bet that's what he is
because he will be messy on Twitter for
so many reasons
I just don't want him eating that chip
oh yeah I don't want him in that [__] he
already made that bet that's it I don't
care I'll take that I'll take the bullet
no you're not doing it
as well
for medical conditions I don't want my
brother to take that adorable make some
games yeah like nah we I need my brother
I ain't got no problem if if something
happens you know no no no no no no no
but here's the thing here's the thing
King going to take that chip again
because I don't think it's gonna happen
so
I have no problems again I have no
problem
S
I got no problem living a day in hell
for Square Enix but I got also no
problem
saying it's not going to happen and King
will take it anymore
you see this yes no so this is why I
will not relent okay because people he
wishes it to happen to me okay all right
what happened to him so he got to get
this smoke we can't Shield The Young
Ones
the conditions were is that is that
image got to be on Twitter yo listen I
don't care what it is when you see it
you go cry because I'm telling you you
already saw they had the proposal they
had all their paperwork they had their
vitals they had their social security
I also I do think this is one of those
things where you letting yourself in the
moment get too ahead and I love that I
love that about you I love the fact that
you don't respect my vision
for this score either so okay
don't get it twisted I'ma feel really
bad if I have to take that chip but the
things I'm gonna do on Twitter after I
take that [__] yeah after after the
score Enix has officially been confirmed
the amount of so and issues like people
like brat I'm popping in people like
blue John popping in I'm doing I'm doing
a world tour when it's gonna be six is
an ounce it's score index is announced
to be bought by by Microsoft
I'm gonna be sweating on Sunday but
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and
Friday I'm doing a world tour
we we had we had King it was so bad
forget King was dropping racial slaves
you do man don't
don't my video think
ing
it's up on patreon I'm saying look at
kiss move video and that's more
indicative of what's really gonna happen
you know what's funny yeah
I I I'll see even if I struggle and I
and I will I I don't I don't handle here
well I handle sour well I don't have no
heat well I know but here's the thing
the odds of me taking that ship King
like twenty percent and if I take that
ship with the 20
the knees what I've heard said hold the
line but you act like I don't already
have your knees I'm not playing with
fire you act like I don't already have
your knees your knees belong to me and
um they should be here with Lilith the
whole attic like you just gotta actually
I'm gonna do the business first
yo you're right do the business
go get a Hot Chip
Mike
all right this episode of The Iron Lords
podcast is brought to you by Factor
now that we're in the think of Summer
you might be looking for wholesome
convenient meals to support Sunny active
days Factor America's number one ready
to eat meal kit can help you fuel up
fast with flavorful and nutritious
Ready-to-Eat meals delivered straight to
your door you'll save time eat well and
stay on track reaching your goals now
for me winter spring summer or fall I'm
always working so unfortunately it's a
little difficult for me to enjoy the
great outdoors as much as I should
one thing I can say for sure is that
lady SOB always makes sure that I walk
out of this house with my breakfast
lunch and dinner and in tow
and while and she does all of this while
also being a working professional what
that means is that at the end of the
week you have two very tired individuals
looking for ways to spend less time in
the kitchen and more time enjoying life
in comes Factor meals we started using
factor a while back and I'm pleased to
say that it has been a hit we've been
able to cut our prep time in half by
replacing half of our weekly meals with
factor and it's been great whether it's
breakfast lunch or dinner the meals are
fresh they're varied they're healthy and
they're easy to prepare just heat them
up for a few minutes and we're done and
Lady Sav has some of her sanity back so
are you too busy with summer plans to
cook but want to make sure you're eating
well with Factor skip the extra extra
trip to the grocery store and The
Chopping and prepping and cleaning up
too while still getting the flavor and
nutritional quality you need factors
fresh never frozen meals already in just
two minutes so all you have to do is
heat and enjoy then get back outside and
soak up the warm weather ready to feel
your best while making most of your
summer Adventures stick to your Wellness
goals with premium ready to eat meals
featuring high quality ingredients such
as broccolini leeks and asparagus treat
yourself to a 34 plus weekly restaurant
quality options like bruschetta shrimp
Resort Green Goddess chicken
grilled Steakhouse filet mignon ready in
just two minutes
are you too busy running around during
the day to think about lunch keep your
energy up with lunch to go effortless
wholesome meals like grain bowls and
salad Toppers that are ready to eat when
you're on the go no microwave required
and if you're looking for calorie
conscious options this summer try
delicious dietitian approved calorie
smart meals with around or less than 550
calories per serving need an extra boost
to support your Wellness goals this
summer
try Protein Plus meals with 30 grams of
protein or more per serving we offer
delicious flavor packed options on the
menu each week to fit a variety of
Lifestyles from keto to calorie smart
vegan plus and veggie and Protein Plus
prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians each meal has all of the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long while meeting your goals
and if you're looking to mix it up you
can add a protein to select vegan plus
veggie meals each week
round out your meal and replenish your
snack Supply as well with an assortment
of 45 plus add-ons including breakfast
items like our delicious apple cinnamon
pancakes which I've tried delicious
bacon and cheddar egg bites which are
also fantastic I'm a breakfast guy so I
love that stuff
and potato bacon and egg breakfast
skillet or for an easy Wellness boost
try refreshing refreshing beverage
options like cold pressed juices shakes
and smoothies with Factor you can rest
assured you're making a sustainable
Choice they've offset 100 of their
delivery emissions Source 100
renewable electricity for their
production sites and offices and
features sustainably sourced Seafood in
their meals this July get factor and
enjoy eating well without the hassle
simply choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor-packed meals delivered to your
door ready in just two minutes no prep
no mess so head to factormeels.com
ironlords50 and use code iron Lords 50
to get 50 off that's called iron Lords
50 at factormeals.com
iron Lords 50 to get 50 off
no doubt that's the factor in there no
doubt soft talk Sunday smooth solve with
the factory built last pronunciation sir
thank you I appreciate that much
appreciate it um yeah man factors what's
up factor is what's up like wifey and I
wifey's is she's something else like she
I literally walk out of this house every
day Monday through Friday with like a
lunch pail well like my my my day is set
it's funny because my co-workers are
like what the hell I'm like yeah this is
traditional love right that's love
that's love but for me exactly and yeah
I know I'm out all day long but at the
same time like she has a full-time job
that's a lot and she like she puts
pressure on herself to make sure that
I'm not eating poorly or just having to
eat outside or whatever and then Factor
came into the the to the equation we're
like let's look into these these meal
plans and you know we looked at what are
the best ones factors right at the top
of the list it was like okay let's go
with Factor and the the deal up front
before we got this this the hookup right
the deal up front was very good so we
got that it's fantastic because we
literally cut off half of what what she
usually prepares we replaced it with
this and now we have more time to relax
yesterday as a matter of fact I got to
sit down and watch uh Transformers rise
of the Beast which I enjoyed immensely
would not have been able to do that
otherwise because I like how they come
ship the the shipping is dope oh yeah
yeah it's fantastic so uh go support
like I said we don't mess with anything
that we don't support facts they don't
use use that code 50 all factor is
what's up if you're having if you just
don't you're lazy don't want to cook or
if you like me and you really need to
find a way to get out of the kitchen
right
um this is it this is a really really
good option so it says uh let's play
with each other's joysticks we'll be
feeding you something shortly so
JJ JJ says these meals sound awful beefy
yeah thing I I really want to say before
we get back in the super chats yeah I
want to thank the the realm for like
supporting my personal YouTube channel
like the I see you guys in the comment
section like that channel has probably
doubled in view size in the past like
three months and like I really
appreciate that I see you you know uh
Stitch a bunch of people in there and
you know I it was always important to me
to like do my old YouTube channel but I
kind of let that on the back burner when
you know in the middle of making IOP
with with these guys and he recently
it's been like one of my goals to
refocus a little bit more on that but
you know I really appreciate you guys
for doing that and I'm gonna put my uh
my chat for the people that don't know I
do have a personal YouTube channel
absolutely salute the attic doing these
things due to the room supporting so we
got super chat we have plenty of super
chats so
um
all right first of all let's put the
crest in the tap put a new member p155
3D new member Lloyd bronze appreciate
you
and we got red and black dog new member
welcome to Lord bronze put the crust in
the chat for red and black dog
and we got another new member Lord
bronze pigeon salad
it's not the pigeon salad appreciates
you
that we have just Spartan 13 five
dollars to be chat not going to listen
to this right now but I had to pull up
for this massive W fill out here like
five shots couldn't drop me I took it
and smiled
then let's put the crust in the chat
once again for new member pigeon salad A
Gifted five IOP memberships appreciate
that thank you so much pigeon salad
appreciate that ah there we have let's
play with each other's joysticks five
dollar Super Attack the FTC the CMA the
DEA doesn't matter no one is blocking my
love for Saab
I'm officially announcing my acquisition
of SOB we will be merging
unbelievable thank you thank you for the
support I appreciate it
fresh dude 519 310. two dollar Super
Chat Spider-Man for staff build yes and
even swap let's go let's do that no he
was acquiring solved he said we're we're
merging
y'all can try your triple ply dip game
we don't want that we want that fresh
Pride game we will not be trading
Starfield for anything y'all have to
offer all your stuff is regurgitated
nonsense get out of here
I plan on visiting 999 planets in
Starfield save unlike play with each
other's joysticks I have no plans on
visiting Uranus thank you I appreciate
it
wow wow wow wow wow my man that was
hilarious
shout out to the people that's gifted
around so you know that's joined and
gifted we've had 70 new members today
just members appreciate that appreciate
that absolute we got Craig hole again
remember for six months gifted one IOP
membership thank you Craig appreciate
that thugging everybody out making sure
they're coming into the realm I
appreciate that then we have Chris
McComb with the 10 pound Super Chat what
did Jim actually achieve really he
didn't even make Xbox miss their closing
window and I think he he's actually done
more harm to Sony than anything he's put
the light squarely he's if anything he's
put the light squarely on Sony I think
he goes he doesn't go he this is this is
what he was supposed to do uh I don't
understand why the arguments were so
poor but whatever maybe that was the
part of the plan it didn't matter so
whatever I don't know I think Jim did
what he was supposed to do though oh God
take away the um yeah thanks yeah just
go ahead then we have sandwich gaming
new member gifted one IRP membership
with the Crescent attached for Sam
Schmidt's game we appreciate that and we
have Iron Mike five dollar super chat a
lot of people rolled the Xbox Doom and
Gloom wave just three weeks ago now
they're trying to run celebration laps
with the homies today you know who you
are
said it was always there there
not see you when I was shooting in the
gym bro
then we have THX 1138 two dollar Super
Chat new member uh don Phil I make him
an offer he can't refuse
yes then we have gaming 14 remember for
43 months Lord bronze the real work
begins 325 for your PlayStation 5
towards the price of the series Exodus
console I think he's giving up Game Stop
Trading
people will jump ship why not you hurry
this deal won't last
hilarious
that is hilarious and we have resting
Craig face
I'm starting to think Jim signed under
the rest
I mean he had to do what he had to do
then we have sin Vendetta ten dollars I
think once the deal actually closed and
it's finally done we need a we held the
line shirt for those of us who never
wavered absolutely yeah I'm thinking
about that
we have Texas member for nine months
Lord bronze King Corleone said get down
and lay down
now hand over those knees got to get
there later okay
then we have big Afroman 14.
[Laughter]
long time first time I'm glad I was here
to witness IOP history with the first
appearance of the king father King
corleo
and we have Eric five dollar Super Chat
I've been waiting for this episode for
18 months my name is Eric sapenti and
though I didn't lose I still got a bend
the knee to King shout out to you Eric
appreciate you appreciate you appreciate
not gonna lie I love this filter
Beastie then we have fanto Sir with the
two pound Super Chat the equestrian
sodium Odyssey continues uh the salt the
salt of the ponies yes I get it
then we have con artistic five dollar
Super Chat Laura Cognito your setup for
King was quite immersive you can create
a whole podcast with that type of
narration hit the like we had to give
the book of Acts we had to set a book of
bags shut out shout out to Anchors yeah
man for the inspiration then we have
King is overrated five dollar Super Chat
the Bell Rings music starts Phil joins
the call Cog introducing that
for sure let's put the crest in the chat
for Lord bronze newest member to the
realm rufin Rufio shout out to you
appreciate you y'all here
then we have Corey Hale member for 36
months Lord gold where does the goal
post move to now you know yeah that's
always something mismanagement
then let's put the crust in the chat
again for a new member Lord gold frogane
and that's not the pro game I appreciate
you then we have silent Cipher with the
20 Super Chat thank you appreciate that
absolutely we have on the bright side
with the two dollars we chat did Sony
have to give up the marketing agreement
that's a given that's happening so
that's that's bad
then we have Suicide Kings remember for
32 months Lord bronze hoof Bros hold the
wine I do not entertained the wide all
right all right wine w-h-i-n-e
then we have dark man dark man next 55
49 five dollars for chat Microsoft way
around the Cod parody problem offer
offer map skins and weapons on both Xbox
series X and PS5 for sale but had all of
that free if you have Game Pass yes
it'll be little uh loopholes here and
there to give you value on Xbox
then we have THX 1138 again two dollars
Super Chat PlayStation signed the
agreement one generation at a time
there we have casual new Noob gamer five
dollar Super Chat because it's pretty
much a done deal I guess I'll have to
pray for World Peace today at church
instead thanks Xbox for answering my
prayers you should you should pray for
world peace all the time
first before you were praying for a deer
[Laughter]
uh kiopt 901 5 super chat it's it's a
bit concerning how both the CMA and FTC
Focus was on defending Sony does Sony
really have that pole in the gaming
industry I think that's bad yeah it was
a bad argument all the way around yeah
exposed by judge Corley and we have put
the crust in the chat for Lord gold new
member it's reap shout out to it's reap
appreciate you
then we have put out the crest in the
chat once again for new member lady
silver I think uh topaz girl 170 shout
out to Topaz girl 170. appreciate you
awesome
then we got Mo B two dollar Super Chat I
would like for the coalition to remake
gun this goes back to the patreon
question yes yeah that's all oh my God
that game was good
and I'm thinking about black because it
was a that game with all the guns yeah
with all the crazy guns and bullets and
yeah we got Hollywood rules remember for
one year two last Super Chat we started
from the bottom now we're here
Cowboys fan 404 five dollars of attack
how sweet of Microsoft the past Call of
Duty around like adam22 as well
come on
hey hey we need to push that over there
uh what is it the BBC is the bridge
we're not we're not doing it
already said though there will be no
cucking here ladies and gentlemen
we don't we don't have that plug back to
you
woke up in bed next to a pony head Mafia
Style and Call full immediately
shout out to The Godfather shout out to
the golf ball with classic c classic
scene
then we have boy lock two dollar super
jets True Crime Xbox GT
yeah they go back to True Crime and do
it right oh man oh yeah oh yeah
then we have Tim per 21 member for six
months gifted five IOP memberships
appreciate you thank you put the crest
in the chat for Timber appreciate that
then we got uh another new member red
and black dog gifted five IOP
memberships as well thank you so much
appreciate you guys
let's put the crust in the chat once
again for silence Cipher Lloyd bronze
welcome to the brown appreciate you I
did a show with him yesterday and Silent
Cypher also gifted five IOP memberships
appreciate that thank you so much thank
you brother he has a beautiful uh like
setup like when you when you see him on
camera it's horrifying room to the day
yeah it's pretty cool because Michael
Myers oh damn that's awesome the mask
the full face mask back to you soft
Jesus Jesus
uh let me see Nintendo on the otaku
remember for one month five dollar Super
Chat no one is saying what will Nintendo
do after this year
and y'all do do on that side effects
nothing that you do on that side affects
us on this side Sony on crutches we hold
ourselves up
y'all went and got a 10 10-year deal
yeah I got a 10-year deal too y'all
gonna be eating off quad too big time
right here
PlayStation is not I mean Nintendo is
not on the bad side of the hold the line
okay
then we have Golden Arms PR let's put
the Crescent attack for Golden Arms PR
all right Lord bronze appreciate you so
remember okay that's what's up
Puerto Rican gold dinner you already
know I'm about that exactly okay with
the golden dolls yeah sure and we have
Polaris sucks five dollars to put that
Canada let one quarter only sell
companies merge no issues we allow no
outside competition funny this is where
they tried to take a stand hey is what
it is everybody go track a moose
then we got Pat with the two dollar suit
Champagne For The Campaign yes yes yes
pop and bottom yeah popping bottles and
we have David hot right remember for one
year 50 Super Chat thank you appreciate
that hats off to the iron Lords the most
fun podcast by a mile thank you sir
appreciate it was low
and we got Spartan go 17 two pound Super
Chat Lena Khan really got clapped in
that hearing yes she did oh boy I gotta
say this though King I don't know if you
do do you apprec because she has King
like energy like yeah her stubbornness
and don't care it's very king-like I
would say yo I was sitting there
watching her dip and Dodge her Matrix
like moves off yeah I gotta give it to
him she stood there but I noticed it was
affecting her when her eyes started
getting smaller though yeah
did you notice when she was like when
they asked her about the uh the lawyer
thing she's like I when I did do that I
loved and I was honored to do it yeah
yeah but last week he was practicing so
we go
and we have on the bright side five
dollar Super Chat Microsoft is closing
over the FTC so of course they'll close
over the CMA they probably closed
yesterday and it will file it to and
announce it tomorrow yeah that'll be
crazy we'll see it could be early it's
funny Jazz says something while he was
still on here he posted on Twitter
saying like yeah there's there's a lot
more news coming this week
I don't know there's been a lot more
people being very decrypted yeah what's
his name on Twitter just did it cool
um the big Xbox Insider
I always butcher his name
okay check it out
then we have uh Tom from Toonami five
dollars to the chat at the end of the
day the CMA are in this mess because of
their own incompetent actions they close
tomorrow and keep negotiating after the
fact could be
we got a Hardy Cherry member for two
years ten dollars PlayStation is
unlikely to be able to buy anything in
Japan keep 98 in mind they may have an
issue buying anything over the
regulatory threshold PlayStation doomed
themselves saying that they don't
compete with Nintendo
um
a big part of the decision George Corley
did say Nintendo's part of the market
absolutely 100
then we have Game Pass Daily ten dollars
if you chat shout out to the Lords and
the panel King let's play some fortnite
soon brother yes I'm down for that you
know what it is I'm about as soon as
this show is over I'm jumping on I'm
gonna get at least two hours
that we have Max arthay five pound super
chat I can only imagine the grins on
Brad and Phil's faces when they signed
that when that when that signed contract
came through yes it's uh I can imagine
it didn't come through he was sitting
right there
[Laughter]
um
that either his signature or his brains
yo can you see the picture they got with
me and you yes
so why they got you over the shoulder
though yeah make sure you sign right
there put it right there that picture is
like crazy that's crazy hilarious let me
see Gunstar 75 with the five pound Super
Chat Destin please take that controller
off the Xbox I'm getting overheating OCD
I guess he had a controller today
absolute salute and we got sanjitsu Sage
remember for two years ten dollars Super
Chat take two won't be but by Microsoft
they will enter a long-term partnership
to bring all games to Game Pass day one
in a special business Arrangement that
gives take two its own game pass through
Xbox Jesus
then we have Mr Aang two to us which at
bend the knee Sony yes they have bent
the knee then we have uh
ADI adido tune a ditto tune excuse me
I've said it wrong no it's not autotune
he mispronounce something
it could be that they wrote it well I
don't think so though five pound Super
Chat market cap for Sony is uh 117
billion so it's this small potatoes then
we have Max arthay two pound Super Chat
Sega come on Playstation come on P3 make
it so let's go
we have Max arthay again two prime Super
Chat that Candy Crush money is about to
buy take two yo
um
we'll see we'll see
and we have hargit Shani member for two
years five dollar super chat if they
actually go after one of those bigger
ones outside of the pan it should be UB
or better WB uh since they're having
issues could be
[Music]
[Laughter]
and I heard I don't know how true it is
it was rumored that Wonder Woman might
be canceled it's canceled um yeah
I'd be very disappointed because it had
the Nemesis engine monolith I know yeah
all right Malcolm X lax3
what think what do you think about
Microsoft picking up KOA Tecmo solve it
like that I think he had that one yeah
that on your list
[Music]
yeah yeah I remember that cool exact
moment I would take band down Namco well
I mean come on man get protecting over
here oh man I'm that's my selfishness
then we have the Don cjg five pound
Super Chat Jim and the clown man
Association I bet the knee the line has
been held Lord Cognito finish them off
and show them the meat ah
that was wild crazy I'm just bear with
me a second because I might get jumped
but I hope no doubt PK entertainment
from Vegas I see you see the chat salute
blessings did you get a chance to see
that fight
um he might be out there yeah my boy
Frank Martin got that win last night
kind of shaky
let me see we got Leroy is the master
I don't know
five dollar Super Chat Phil said Sony
catching bullets with their teeth you
know the rest Hold the Line have a great
show gentlemen thank you appreciate it
[Music]
yeah
shout out to vanity shout out to debage
went down yeah that's true it's true but
I've never been in a movie theater where
people got up to dance yes that was yes
I like that get your hands off my woman
[Laughter]
we got Raymond Morrell five dollars can
we give the EU a shout out the unsung
heroes of the avk deals
let's be real you they definitely light
it up not at the darkest hour because if
they didn't do what they supposed to do
which you know we thought they knew they
would but it was spooky so yeah you
spread the money in the right place oh
look you understand like some people go
and they go buy you know FTC things
just spread it to the EU because they
did actually remember they went to the
stock market and dropped off water was
it three million for your infrastructure
I heard that your infrastructure is
looking a little weak hey check under
your seat we ain't never gonna get
through these Super Shoes let's go back
to Virtual you virtue
that's weird
yeah
Mr worldwide stop snitching The
Regulators and bought that nice fountain
pen out yeah
excited enough enough was enough Dyna
know how that conversation went Miss
Smith still was sitting there yeah
then we have uh let's put the crust in
the chat for sack shop sack shop shout
out to shacksaw for gifting five IOP
memberships appreciate that absolute
then we have I still don't know how to
pronounce this one is the the Jenna or
the guinna I don't know which one two
pound Super Chat Rands invites a like a
vacuum they hold no weight kids
then we have uh amorized two dollars
Super Chat don't forget take two also
got Zynga last year yes so that would be
and that's what they was looking for
so thank you for holding my back there
we go well we got fam remember for 37
months kids mode oh shout out to you
brother 3K viewers hashtag hold the line
yes thank you below and salute to you
and addict amazing Planet Xbox they had
Colin Moriarty on go support weapon
wheel and now I'm already on that
patreon great I love to see them doing
that keep doing your thing kid
absolutely then we have a mental 9R five
dollar Super Chat Microsoft buying take
two it'll be hilarious to see them
trying to get a GTA 6 boycott going
that's for sure
then we got crack hole again once again
gifting another ILP membership strong
arm and someone else thank you I
appreciate you Craig cool again
then we got ice cold remember for three
months Lord bronze that's cool
appreciate you
then we have THX 1138 once again two
dollar Super Chat great seeing the realm
showing up every Sunday 3K yeah okay
y'all showed out wow I appreciate that
I've never seen that before
then we like got Spotlight gopz two
pound Super Chat do we want Xbox to buy
oh I'm sorry do we want Xbox sorry to
jump me a little bit
do you want to use it to make sure it
didn't say nothing suspect
uh if you want Xbox to buy more or
manage what they have or we know how
attic feels about that
if you want to be right or wrong
there we go wrong
what are y'all thinking of the b s e e x
Cloud rumor
exactly
[Music]
never know we got [__] J remember for
23 months Lord bronze so excited to see
King go off happy Lord's day and hoping
Xbox is green lighting a new True Crime
right now let's see that'd be awesome
then we got one pint Johnny five dollars
five pounds super Jack congrats on your
viewership fell as much love and
definitely deserved excellent show no
doubt thank you thank you and we got
Nicholas Branch five dollar Super Chat
I'm gonna buy a random camera big energy
for momentous occasion always loved the
Lord showing a big hail the Lord's
hashtag stay beefy
but we have net watch five dollars Super
Chat I have five and a half hours left
at work hopefully this dream is eight
hours no no you guys are the best gaming
podcast no competition thank you bro
appreciate you appreciate it appreciate
the support
then we have Adidas 20 zero remember for
one month Lord bronze in the words of
dirt griggity Xbox is improving
I should have had dirt on there we go
crazy crazy G14 five pound Super Chat
Jim Crying Ryan I want all your
exclusives to Phil Dominus Spencer's
fine I want all of yours salute to ILP
and Zion yeah definitely hear me she's
definitely designed on The Matrix the
way y'all was active oh boy
there we have Max arthay two pound Super
Chat Jim signed a deal with his Sharpie
and tears yesterday probably were some
tears
then we got country big right we just
read the super chats right well yes
pretty much I mean we just combined the
last two is just yeah I think we this is
pretty much set everything Halo and I
mean I didn't get my balls off for that
for the
um
the Halo and the Halo rumor and the um
you're a ratchet and climate situation
oh no no the Ratchet and Clank stuff I
can use a clown on them any day okay
okay well we had like what five o'clock
now it's crazy so I'll just get my balls
off on the car all right
you said country
country big happy Sunday Lords let's
spin that tear and hold the line salute
the country big oh my God so yeah people
spend the chairs
professional wrestler in UK song oh nice
really appreciate it for all you guys
every last one of you okay okay
we gonna be popping bottles next Sunday
and it's next Sunday
[Music]
I don't know how you feel called but I
feel like we should just tell people
what the next guests will be I mean the
most people we ever have in a chat for
for a minute is it next week already
yeah it's next week
well just think about it while the show
goes on I don't think about it you give
me your answer at the end we think about
it we have a Chris McCombs two pound
Super Chat Jim didn't bend the knee he
bent over oh
okay oh Jim
hold on a second I definitely got jumped
now okay uh let's put the crash in the
chat for one pint Johnny all right Pine
is all he can do that's it that's it
he's at his limit he's at the limit we
got [__] Jay five dollars for chat
PlayStation about to get barbecued just
like Lena Khan dracaris not the jakaris
oh man oh man that was funny
then we got fro game 10 super chat Lords
have been holding me down and holding
the line every week for me since 2020
love to the whole crew but a shout out
to Lord hoganito aka the beefy one the
beefy that's stupid
though then we got Zay 316 five dollars
shout out to the iron Lords and yes the
ILP is an Xbox podcast Jesus
he held the line and as king said now we
push the line
forward
then we got Zen zenner white remember
for 17 months Lord silver hoping Xbox
revives back compat as ABK IPS are tasty
hashtag hold the line yes I see those IP
come back and we have quick gameplay
five pounds five dollar Super Chat it
makes sense for Microsoft to buy square
and Sega at the same time oh they beat
the Japanese market and they can make a
friendly deal with Nintendo I'm load
acquisition but even down with us I said
get much at the same time okay
hold on a second then we have drunken
ninja hold on a second
drunkenness like a bunch of super chats
or is that they just in not in the right
order they're probably not in the right
order because I'm going literally unless
I got jumped but I'm going did you did
you read black at it well could you
imagine if they brought square and no
that's further down
the Final Fantasy back on Nintendo that
would be crazy that'd be crazy shout out
to y'all that'd be the happiest chip
I've ever ate in my life that they like
scoring I'll be smiling the whole time
until the heat hits
yeah you ain't gonna be smiling at all
because that he hit instantaneously well
then I'm gonna be not smiling
instantaneously I'll be smiling for you
and I don't want to hear you eating are
you gonna argue with me where my smile
gonna be I don't want you to argue I
don't want to eat no you wanna the whole
chip no you never you never clarified
how quick I have to eat them no no no
you can eat it as low as you like you
want to drag it out
I'm joking I will just heat them all
together
there's only one chip that's how deadly
that chip is yeah
all right and I told you it was
something I'll never do again in my life
but to watch you eat it hell yeah
and we got drunken ninja baby for 34
months petition to get a pause button
because y'all be saying some wild things
but happy Sunday lunch let's get this
Activision break
wait what
the simple thing I'm a beefy
yeah
oh man yeah there's a few minutes
all the Sony fans that are feeling down
seek help slash I'm not gonna say what
that is you can't do that they can't do
that
seek helpful
PlayStation where where pay happens
Jesus
that we got gave her by choice five
dollars to be chat I remember Jim saying
Sony could not survive that the deal
goes through and now they're signing a
10-year deal funny how times have
changed great show yeah time flies
[Laughter]
then we got Papa smoke
okay do you guys think we'll ever get a
metal arms glitch in the system remake
or sequel you never know
you never know I mean we got it we got
Voodoo Vince back so we never know what
what's what's that mean with like Kanye
West like we'll never know
listen you can't find me the bushes sign
it you can't find me in the bush
assigning papers with the five pounds
we held The Lion King we got Sony's
knees and the CMA is looking weak the
book of X yes
then we got let's put the question in
the chat by Hector F Lord bronze
appreciate you Hector f
and we got Gabe Forte ten dollar Super
Chat oh hell no Tyson Lewis that phrase
will be trademark it's trademarked hey
Boo-Boo isn't just a phrase it's a way
of life
you didn't do it right let me show you
the ropes as always hey King Boo Boo hey
wait wait somebody else did it did it
and I did the hey Forte and he was like
oh hell no oh that was that was that was
Tyson Lewis yeah Jackson was trying to
jump into action he was like oh
then we got an Xbox game FTW two dollars
to attack
came here from addicts Channel I like
this show thank you I appreciate it
that's what's up
then we have I'm a beefy boy ten dollar
Super Chat why is everyone talking about
prototype when Microsoft just needs to
call Marvel oh damn it now I gotta jump
oh I got jumped right in the middle of
it okay okay the Marine X-Men Legends
and Marvel multiple Alliance
no I'm with Dez it's a little beefy boy
if they don't actually go for a Marvel
but they get a competent Studio to
re-brain you know prototype back would
you guys consider that a like a w you
mean real Spiderman too
[Music]
opinionated two dollars in the chat pray
for Jim Ryan this is a rough time
nah he brought this on himself
then we have black addict
s yeah
my brother's Xbox smoking the Ops back
to back
deal closes Last of Us two battle pass
incoming
then we have Hefty 263 with the two
dollars okay shout out to Lord beefy I
do I know it's gonna be such the dude
Dave's half
uh yeah we got yeah baby
chat check on Marlon he came in the
realm like a calm PlayStation player and
now the good brother is unhinged who's
this that's crazy
stuff be happening there we go exactly
you know hold the line get changed
it's your turn now
[Laughter]
hold the line for the PlayStation baby
don't give up now baby
and we got let me see
I've just finished Hefty and y'all baby
okay we got Max arthay five pound Super
Chat uh you were given the choice
between war and dishonor you chose this
honor and you will have War Winston
Churchill church
and we got and we got Mr T t e e
take too interactive is bigger than just
rockstar I would be excited for the 2K
division which would give Xbox a foot in
the sports gaming markets okay would be
crazy bring back MLB 2K no competition
okay full of competition you know uh let
me see J Blaze 9800 five dollars for the
chat J dub and foxygames UK been getting
curb stops since 80 since what is 88.
then we got chocolate among five dollar
Super Chat someone at the gym approached
me and asked me how I got such good
results told them I've been on that
Cognito workout plan you finish
guaranteed
[Music]
the health as well
wow
here we have abacab 72 member for 29
months let's give a shout out to Major
Nelson for his sacrifice to get this APK
deal done seriously wishing major well
lines Adventures
remember shout out to Larry the king
with the ferragamos he's the pull up you
know that's it
it's gonna be where being at events
without layers
it seemed like he's still gonna be
around in some form of fashion because
he said he's going to Rebrand his
podcast but I think it's a next
adventure for me moving on to like
something else but yeah I think I think
he he's gonna go like just like a side
thing I think he's retiring from Xbox
but like still doing like the the the
influencer thing because he said he was
rebranding his Xbox I mean his channel
could be a whole new opportunity we'll
see what's up
then we have Tom from Toonami five
dollar Super Chat Microsoft is legit
Paulie from Goodfellas to Jim right now
Regulators didn't believe you after you
pay me you want caught on Playstation
after you pay me wow
okay okay
then we got hargit Cindy shout out to
Hardy always always looking out for the
for the community we got some Diablo 4
Ultimate Edition codes we got a Call of
Duty Modern Warfare 2 vault Edition
Global code so shout out to everybody
who got those codes and give a shout out
to Heart Geet for always always
supporting the community appreciate that
brother
then we have AKA Havoc two dollar Super
Chat Lord Lord Cog all beef no fillers
I'm good
I'm good thank you though thank you try
to get that beefy shirt
[Laughter]
there we go bragging your feet yeah
pause yeah we have a shirt that'd be
like where's the beef I have a picture
of Kong like ah
bird dog
I see this way to go
here we have then we have Spartan 661
two dollar Super Chat this is Xbox okay
all right a little 300 everyone a little
300 energy yeah we got to put the crust
in the chat for Pigeon salad gifted five
IOP memberships appreciate you pigs and
salad salute and we have silent Cipher
two dollars Super Chat that was a big
pause
pause worthy moments yeah
and we have crazy crack 831 not crazy
crack crack 831 no excuse me crazy
cracker yeah
whoa that's even worse though that's
kind of worse it's kind of worse though
now that I think about it yeah that's
kind of worse
I missed that hey he's crazy
it is statistically most important
there's way more serial killers with
white people than anyone else
it can't be so crazy white people I
can't say that I'm not co-signing none
of that
[Laughter]
wow there's certain things I can't say
back to you
back to you at it
oh no
there we go
not going there
Jada might be underway okay so five
dollars in the chat Jada might be under
the fridge with the other roaches all of
the line I got an ad in the middle of
your speech wow said that was black
addict that said that that's funny
yeah we have Highlander 001 five dollar
Super Chat Microsoft will own the top
three selling games on PlayStation over
their own exclusives Diablo 4 Cod and
Minecraft how sad is that advanced the
line that's how you win remember I told
y'all you see you gotta beat him that's
what Phil said you gotta beat them by
selling consoles you just gotta beat
them by putting the best-selling games
on their consoles keep selling guys
then we got Cedric H 20 Super Chat Sony
thought Microsoft is Meek Mill all the
while Microsoft Is Pusha T
you know what's funny King it's like you
said they're funding their own demise
it's like they have the money they're
giving to Xbox like he'll go put it in
that trailer and they go the first
trailer it's like the demise of place
and not that Trails or what after that
and the next trailer it's like demise of
PlayStation time soon
put it in the coffin
that's our retirement
what's in the box what's in the box
it's like they have the coffin but they
have a door in front of it and plays the
PlayStation Representatives he's like
what's the Box they shut the door that's
not for you to see just pay me and leave
yo it's a PlayStation 6 dev kit
great to see all the guests pop up
everyone wants to follow the general yes
yes absolutely and we got the homie Sean
Mason five dollar Super Chat I guess
Sony decided to be a seller must have
known the trade deadline was around the
corner yes yes yes
that we have pick up
pick up gaming two dollar Super Chat
phase one of Matt Booty's master plan
complete
delicious yeah four to five Game Pass
then we got Zay 316 five dollar Super
Chat we have the Avengers of Xbox
podcast passing through love this
community shout out yes
everybody beautiful absolutely and we
have some Jutsu Sage
jasmus going to the boo box like like
that movie Hook he doubted Captain Hook
could get Peter Pan's kids activism and
must now pay okay
there we go Spartan 661 five dollars
super chat if Sony wasn't so greedy
money hating developers Microsoft
wouldn't have bought the Publishers that
owned them to have them on Xbox F round
and find out wow yeah they did they
found out exactly what it is oh your
wallet is like that that
then we got rrd two dollars Super Chat
jazz is forbidden from having beans for
one year
then we got Robert Kelly Two Dollars to
attack you should you should eat five
chips Jazz Jesus
absolutely not y'all don't know anything
I don't know calling for anybody
they make them stronger every year yeah
last year ain't this year
it's a whole different chip games get a
chance to take a chip he had three chip
removed from the chip that I took that
you took oh no
[Laughter]
[Music]
shout out to the major news everyone is
talking about that's right Dex is coming
back for a new generation
crazy
there we go Raiden blade two pounds of
attack King love you bro love that
energy wow love it shout out to you sir
good energy oh yeah I'm gonna show out
for you guys y'all showed out for us I'm
gonna show out for you
then we have for the president Chapel
Lord gold fanto sir appreciate you put
the crest in the chat
we got Spartan go 17 to pounds super tap
Paris had that Vaseline 240p cameras Oh
Jesus
tears of the Kingdom
[Laughter]
they got a broadcast mode
so messy yeah we got Gerald back five
dollar Super Chat does this ABK deal
make Xbox more attractive to other game
developers as far as putting their games
in Game Pass all hail to ILP and
graybeards yes yes yes yes yes sir
absolutely I do think so I think um it
makes it a way more attractive Prospect
knowing that Call of Duty is going to be
in your game to be in with Call of Duty
huge
we got Robert kellett two dollars Super
Chat IOP civil war Civil War every week
[Laughter]
we started arguing yeah
I gotta I gotta watch it again
and we have hargit to need five dollars
the m a team and Xbox isn't going to sit
around Phil and Satya said they aren't
done yet and they are going to buy
multiple more Publishers just saying
multiple
Publishers did they say Publishers
multiple Publishers they're gonna buy
Publishers back to back
all right we got Michael Mooney five
pounds super chat if if I want High
attachment to console if they want High
attachment to consoles and experience in
high quality games and you want Japan
then you go direct to Nintendo and Drop
That 70 billion they tried that you
don't remember I left out the room
Nintendo has a different protocol it's
not even about the bread and you can't
even sway Nintendo's board you're
talking about old Yakuza people that's
like not hearing what you're talking
about that ain't gonna work over there
Microsoft walks in and put the money on
the table and they say if you don't get
out of here
take your money and leave look uh King I
don't know if you saw this but this is
ever born
are we tweeted that
and we have some Jutsu Sage five dollars
which at Microsoft for the next
acquisition is going to say listen you
know we still in third place right that
avk thing was like two years ago work
with us
uh Whatchamacallit numbers the Xbox Live
numbers Xbox Gold you gotta separate
them out we got something ready while we
still keep hurt
separated
then we got Raul Salgado ten dollars if
we chat push the line buy take two buy
Sega buy you we saw Pete sodia lesson
take no prisoners
eat them eat them while they weak right
now
there we have LA with the five dollar
Super Chat new to the channel but I've
been with Xbox since day one definitely
enjoying the channel and salute the king
Phil with the three for the win no doubt
then we have Anthony QA or OA one of the
two five pound Super Chat King came
straight off the set of New Jack City
earlier
I am My Brother's Keeper yeah
and then we had a BC My Name Is Mud
member for three months Lord gold I
agree that they need to manage all the
studios that they have first so we don't
end up with more initiative 343 and red
Falls situations
concerns valid concerns
have Evan P 10 super chat I'm on
vacation from work and I'm able to catch
the Lords on the Lord's Day Big Win
Microsoft and we held the line next
Target Sega let's go let's go
and we have Lord Starkiller Xbox series
x01 10 super chat Hold the Line check
now we attack check move the line check
break the line check bend the knee check
then we have tsws gaming 2010. y'all see
Dev teams at Microsoft were excited oh
yeah it's popping off yeah that's
popping that's a crazy Network you have
right now and we have acute perspective
two dollars in the chat oh hell Phil
Spencer and his Ma and his and his money
right Microsoft Roundtable salute shout
out to you sir Phil Collins yo does he
go around and go down as the greatest
uh Xbox CEO now I mean
I'm close I'm close I mean you can make
it off right now you can make that this
is one of the biggest I think he is the
only thing to stop it is if somehow they
dropped the ball somehow I will give it
100 to Phil
if Starfield yeah it's just the game
down Starfield you know he's got at this
point he's got to get a couple really
high quality games yo that's this in the
chat yo that's crazy he said no kick he
has to go remember IOP
yeah that's true wow that's true then we
have
let me see
and we have Highlander 001 two dollar
super tap Microsoft will now own MLG
that will hurt Sony of
it
interesting
that's something we never even talk
about was that yeah yeah that's a big
deal we have Lord Star Killer Xbox
series x01 10 super chat FTC taking them
L's back to back to back to back they
got 10 days this is 10 or 11. this is 10
right this is what do you mean how many
losses they took it's like oh and five
and they're like yeah yeah not not good
not good not good then we have some
Jutsu Sage five dollars in there today
Halo Infinite release in 2021 for June
2023 is the top 18 worldwide on Xbox
series consoles stop the slander Halo is
strong campaign reviewed great okay I
mean grace
wrong with engagement but yeah it's not
wrong it's just I think the gamer has
passed Halo by and if you're going to
use that same old formula have to change
the formula they tried to change the
formula I think in the multiplayer
aspect if they can do a battle royal and
nail it yeah I think it can bring it
could take it to a different level yeah
super certain Affinity though yeah
um let me see septic sauce five pound
Super Chat health check on Colin oh my
God absolutely Colleen
he had his defense Shield ready
you're like whoa goal post uh salute to
the holy yeah we have Tai casares
fifteen dollars I rather 343 they can
deliver a multiplayer compared to
naughty dog that gets its multiplayer
shut down by Bungie and let's be honest
Bungie haven't made a good versus mode
since they made Halo Reach um
but but they did make a good PVP that
just have no rewards with it they have a
structure they have a solid PVP just
nothing to do with it yeah fair enough
fair enough that's the Sony thing
all right so so you got to look at who
owns them now
you got to push the line
enigmatic dreams five dollars to attack
King if they get square you will Ascend
to God Emperor David Parasite Eve must
come back and I'd rather have Capcom for
Resident Evil listen like I said on the
gaming console show yesterday if they
buy square and this is for them I will
get only fans and my members will see me
go live streaking uh do that because
that will have to happen but technically
you could do that on the page hey hey
hey hey hey hey
back to you
[Laughter]
yeah yeah baby five five dollar Super
Chat cogs pants got extra beefy when he
thought it was really Phil Spencer in
the gym
oh
wow that's crazy that's crazy right
there that's wow I'm pretty sure Phil is
watching but I'm pretty sure
wow
Phil's Polly's face turns into red right
now wow that was wow you baby if I was
rocking with you man you did that
right wow
yeah my people keep it clean
put some beef in the chat
that's what it is
next up we have Kay Johnson ladies
Cog needs plenty of protein
no I don't I'm good somebody need to sit
down
food that's what this is that's a
Delirious yeah
we got Kay Johnson member for 17 months
lady bronze ladybugs Garth Bell strikes
again yesterday's price eight today's
price you get 10 years but since you
wanted to play each ABK game requires
separate contracts
negotiations is wow right now I gotta
chill with these bees for the chat bro
that's a hell of support what type of
sausage is that pause
[Laughter]
that's more
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right moving along
[Music]
[Laughter]
a lot of news broke this week yeah but
I'm learning because some things broke
more than that yeah for sure boss it off
somebody's stretching the truth yeah
[Music]
deal till 2027 next Xbox console comes
in 2028 and right after that
then we have Lord Starkiller once again
five dollar Super Chat took a while but
Jim Ryan finally bent the knee yes he
did she did
we have M Marquis ten dollars Super Chat
PlayStation ass can we get the ish and
go Xbox replied you'll get the ish you
will be knee deep in the end
I love that movie yeah we got casual new
game for five dollars Super Chat Xbox
will separate multiplayer from Cod this
year making multiplayer as a map pack
for Warzone which will be on Game Pass
as a perk and honoring PlayStation deal
for Call of Duty 224. yeah
well let's put the crust in the chat for
Lord Star Killer Xbox series XL1 Lord
bronze thank you sir lessons
then we have uh Laverne 98 Liberty five
dollar Super Chat breaking Toys for Bob
will be rebranded toys for King in honor
of King David's Hold the Line
then we have big Afroman 14 10 stupid
chat Microsoft confirmed to The Verge
that Sony's 10-year Cod deal is limited
to Cod Microsoft originally offered to
keep existing action Activision uh
console titles on Sony including future
versions but not anymore yep that's what
happens when you talk out of pocket you
should kill Jimmy I don't think Jimmy's
there after this next fiscal period and
I'm just gonna dictate this then we got
Lord Metroid two dollar Super Chat stop
saying no more to CJ is well prepared
whoa
[Laughter]
what a day hashtag Xbox hashtag what's
next
Sega Sega
then we have JD gamer 20 Super Chat for
all those fake sidechair analysts and
intellectuals you've you're done
finished finito never ever speak out
again to Lord General King we are your
army and happy to have held the line to
the soldiers we March hard let's get it
a lot of people said this is gonna be
dead a lot of people gotta eat their
words and the receipts is out there
exactly they're out there we got John
Wolfe five dollar Super Chat the line
was held and the deal is done now the
question is when do we get our Hold the
Line achievement Xbox that would be
awesome that's crazy
that'd be crazy
then we have a KJ Wars 85 remember for
one month Lord gold shout out to you and
we got one bad mother five dollar Super
Chat report Jim Ryan heard doing Lando
impersonations this deal is getting
worse all the time man shout out to
Lando then we got Isaiah 316 Lord bronze
put the crest of the chat for zays 3 16.
then we got silent Cipher once again
five more IOP memberships appreciate you
put the question silent Cipher we got
Nintendo on the otaku gifted in one IOP
membership thank you brother put the
Crush in the chat for Lord Donald
um
made that achievement for King it was
dope yeah
and we got Lord Starkiller x Xbox series
x01 gifted five IOP memberships thank
you Lord Starkiller appreciate that then
we got Corey Tidwell five dollar Super
Chat Jim Ryan told Phil Swing Down Sweet
Chariot stop and let me ride damn that's
a swing low yeah
then we got the official young dreads
two dollar Super Chat finally in the
realm couldn't find it thank you
let me shout out to you brother boy
locked two dollar Super Chat the Unicorn
gave Xbox it's Diamond horn today
of course yeah
then we have Chef leak two dollar Super
Chat somebody needs to check on Jada
you know you know I came so close
because he's sick right now I was gonna
call him and ask him I won't show oh man
I'm sorry to do six there I wonder I
wonder what it got you in such a state
crazy and we have country big 94 two
people Super Chat wow this is for God go
hit that like button for Jimmy no knees
hashtag hold the lines
my guy
then we have put the question in the
chat for Lord gold
femtanga let's go go with femtanga
then we got Hollywood rules two dollars
which had failed to gym yesterday he
built a gym yesterday's price is
definitely not today's price of course
not but we got Oscar wheat five dollar
Super Chat money makes the world go
round trust me Jim knows this now
talk with that little wallet
[Music]
then we have time to make it happen then
we got romelo two uh 20 Super Chat this
is a good day huh yeah it's a pretty
good day it was a good day
yeah and we got Gamers play HUD x0
member for 31 months Lord bronze what's
up Lord to the realm Lord King you my
sir or the master of the Quan the Sony
bent the knee as you predicted Swami
stay awesome
God that we got Hector the Macho Man
five dollar Super Chat I don't know
what's worse the beating of Lena Khan or
Jim crawling back to Phil asking can I
have some more soup please King is old
knees both was uh thoroughly
entertaining but nothing nothing this
present this morning is beautiful thank
you Phil
then we have the black Viking with the
200 and oks Knox I'm not sure what that
is I'm sorry uh what up fellas calling
it now the official ABK acquisition
video will have feature it will feature
at least one future XBox exclusive that
is probably true mm-hmm
then we got the everborn Saga five
dollars
what is all this T2 and square talk I
waited 18 months after we know Sega was
on the menu y'all not gonna mess this up
for me now
home of Sonic hashtag free knocker knock
is good knock is gonna have to be our
house arrest for a couple of years but
he good he good it's a couple of years
yo got that ankle brace then we got JD
game with ten dollars in the chat I'm
calling you out all of you ponies that
have been out here wishing for Xbox's
demise not gonna happen what will happen
is that you have been dehoofed and Tails
take it off y'all are down back
a lot of horse talk
oh man then we have Mr four mr411
chat turn ten makes the next blur combat
card game yes blur I remember blur yeah
remember oh yeah oh yeah then we got
Lord Metroid two dollars if you chat
Nintendo Mario Wonder tears of the
Kingdom Mario RPG Cod what
they will definitely benefit from it as
well though they're down with us stop
trying to fight John stop trying to make
yourself a rival
they are friends the courts looked at
you and was like I ain't got nothing
over here they did include them in the
costumes
bring them in bring shorty in that chair
it's a me I'm competitive
when the news was announced about Sony
agreeing with Microsoft Cog started
flexing his beef and posing like he was
Paul Bunyan pause yo yo you got a
imagination going on
stop flexing for these dudes
sometimes y'all elaborate too much on
these scenarios
like a lot of screenshots
[Laughter]
Pony peasants I present you hairless I
present you hairless before the Lord's
exposed as the pseudo-intellectuals you
are now give me my money going hard on
these people
I'm a generous guy Microsoft probably
that's probably what Microsoft's saying
yes they probably are
then we have
voluntary celibacy
shout out to voluntary so let's see I
appreciate you
we got monitors
I said he's taking a huge huge one for
the team exactly we have voluntary
celibacy once again ten dollars Xbox
officially pimping PlayStation yeah this
better have Microsoft money
that we have Lord Starkiller once again
five dollars which technology and Ryan
is Jim lying crying bend the knee Ryan
yes
he bone five dollars
after the deal is done I need Crash
Bandicoot doing the Harlem Shake on the
Xbox basketball
just start reading them really fast
let me take over your eyes
no no we need proper uh addiction here
okay and I get that we're gonna let song
Go Blind right 40 minutes
we got we got Jack City two five dollars
we got to hold the line Anthem shirt
[__] it's your turn to have five ideas
respectfully are you implying you that I
can do what we want who is this
replying yo I can't and what are we
doing okay who is this talking
This was oh daughter said we jumped out
of it God won't know who you are yeah
like who is this that guy bring him out
Vlog him yeah Jack's 82. sees him
Xbox guy out to fight
we are going to talk about what's
happening with Fable apparently
something big is happening with the
writing staff or whatever we held the
line you know you're gonna read that
favorable one
creeping and peeking through your window
to that Super Chat
damn cocky look it Mighty beefy right
now so the camera gotta go off I think
this extra thousand that we got here is
a whole different demographic there's
something else going on this [__] Beetle
talk it's getting crazy this is crazy I
like this I like this then we have OG TK
Cole oh homie homie as a neutral party
who plays on all consoles and PC I have
to be honest a lot of PlayStation gamers
are very quiet right now
those don't be accountable don't qualify
yourself in the beginning with talking
about your neutral
absolutely not I have everything but you
if somebody told you one of those babies
gotta go you're gonna grab want to say
not this one please it's all good then
we have Radu warniku with the five runs
I don't know where the runs are I'm
sorry they're right next to where you
know skinless ponies
[Music]
sir duck member for 36 months Lord
bronze this was a high protein pause
cast thanks beefy one cockpito there you
go wow
then we have Chris McComb five pound
Super Chat have you guys had any issues
with your allies I've been tempted to
get one but seem to be it seemed to be
issues have any of you tried the uh One
X player two no no none of us have
gotten it I'm adding issues with the
rock that that aren't just Windows
things yeah it's been pretty clean it's
really good it plays games
incredibly the only problem I do have is
the uh interface the interface is a
little clunky at the moment yeah Armory
crate is not good updates yeah yeah I
agree and there's a bunch of stuff you
could do like change out Army crate and
put something else but I mean you could
do all that but it's it's just a Windows
machine if you're good with dealing with
Windows you're fine
hi guys any ABK Studio you want to see
touch Xbox IP
then we have Thomas pandino five dollar
Super Chat didn't mention how Cod will
be delivered outside of Xbox could this
be the opening for Microsoft store
inside of other consoles for delivery of
cod Microsoft store that would be
something but I don't think so that'd be
interesting then we have Spartan 661 two
dollars uh two dollars I'm a Gray beard
without the gray at this moment ah
Grecian Five
Just For Men that's a low salute we have
Xbox guy five dollar Super Chat y'all
thinking play that y'all thinking pay
station five will end up being Sony's
worst selling console of all time no
pretty sure the Vita sold more than Sony
slot machine no I think
console but it'll probably be the
best-selling because it's going to be
the last it's going to be a collector's
item everybody
go go get one now
is a scoop for k n ratchet was
originally for PS4 but they spruced up
the visuals for PS5 the launch window
and crash 5 will be an XBox exclusive to
all those games God bless
wow then we have c-dub813 305 10 super
chat Game Pass will be everywhere but
the reality is Xbox console is all but
done now you better get that PC money up
for Game Pass App either way good win
for Game Pass
Maybe
Robert kellett two dollar Super Chat
King the true beef King yeah him set it
that way
what he said yeah he said you the true
beef yeah King is the true beef King
let him stop trying to take things away
from college
they call half his stuff you know Robert
I I approve that message I agree good
too then we have Lord Metroid two
dollars Super Chat Cog is going blood
sausage time dark as hell wow
I usually like my beef cruelty free but
I wouldn't mind if Cog want to get a
little rough
[Laughter]
no don't know if this is related but
just had my second PS5 traded today not
only did we hold the line we barricaded
the entrance hashtag No Quarter
[Music]
yesterday's beefy is definitely not
today's beefy
let's put the Crush in the chat for Mr
Shadow Lord bronze thank you joining
around then we got oh my God Spartan 661
two dollars in the chat Lena Khan got
her cherry popped by Microsoft come on
people let's behave whoa whoa no we're
gonna say behave after all this stuff
you know he's gonna say behave
that's all right that's all right oh
it's fine okay okay that's fine okay I
get it I get it it wasn't no behaved
this this is a step too far though this
was a step too far hold on blood sausage
cogs jeans
so
chat guys so then we have Doctor Strange
Love five dollars look at that I see
Bland all Thor was here he could learn a
thing or two about seasoning for Mr
beefy if you know what I mean
that was fine that was fine good Super
Chat appreciate it
used to season the meat and SOB get
addicted a cat put his chair spit I have
a cat I did not think 90 of the chats
was gonna be about yeah that's crazy you
need a beefy shirt now it's crazy
that we have Lord Starkiller five
dollars of attack can King David o'cock
or addict or SOB appear on wbg or TTS
reach out to Dirk griggity or shan786
Saloon I've been there I've been on that
yeah Dirk I think so also I'm the only
one who hasn't been on it I haven't been
on but he works like 18 jobs
15 jobs 15 Jobs go check the hold up I
mean I'll jump on there any week like
like dirt this be a solid anytime he
needs me hey co-host of the attic show
yeah
and we got pixel bit G five dollars
shout out to the best podcast out here
for holding it down and entertaining the
realm for years keep taking knees y'all
thank you appreciate it yeah
Joe Repco AKA flame five dollar Super
Chat the FTC got suplexed three times
over now Jimmy read the room not wanting
that smoke and folded like a cheap tent
all hail the king love y'all likewise
bro yeah
blessings and we have OG TK Cole five
dollars back oh gee King I have to stay
neutral my daughter has a relationship
with them blue people
hold on I gotta report you
parent and all three oh
play the PlayStation we know they
overheating their uh forest fire hazard
make sure that we uh compensate that
thank you crazy then we have jax 82 two
dollar Super Chat Cog is not for sale
[Laughter]
he need to elaborate on that what's up
you don't need to talk about that any
further the dog knows it's all jokes
calm down Chad
yeah
Mario M two dollars which have we can
see the restart of Starcraft ghost yes I
was gonna say that bring back craft
ghosts how long was that uh mandango big
Dickens he's off camera where's the beef
you don't want to talk about something
but if they were to talk about a new
Pokemon no I know because then you try
to get me to be to bite on some baits
all right all right the home stretch
whoa get there beef
oh he's a podcast
[Music]
the biggest clown
[Laughter]
that big day a big day um now it's just
a matter of you know how fast the
closing happens right we got to see what
goes on there and then you know the the
real work though we gotta we you know
even though I'm Lord acquisition there
is real work now to be done there's now
managing ABK the the turnover who exit
who stays who goes you know I know
internally they already have a road map
carved out you know as far as you know
what they want to do that kind of stuff
but um it's just gonna be interesting to
see what their short-term plans are how
they handle you know the Call of Duty
how quickly the entry point goes in I've
always said the series has to me is a
gold mine for Call of Duty and the
Casual Gamer how they link with that how
they Market that is going to be critical
yeah and um you know we know that it's
going to be we also got to talk about
the reality of more Call of Duty on
other platforms and the development
Pipeline with that so you know it's
going to be on streaming services it's
going to be on Nintendo you know Bobby
then stitched it so we had a you know if
I had a performance it's gonna be you
know that kind of thing so and then
extra development time making it for all
these other platforms that's still part
of this um you know Phil has been on
record for talking about old IP so I
would love you know we'll see what
happens with crash you know I'm gonna
ride or die for High Moon Studios I'm
gonna ride for um that was my man Tiga
from um who made war of side Cybertron
Fall of Cybertron you know listen man
I'm gonna pull for that if y'all can do
the licenses I know Dustin Dustin thinks
differently but look counting uh bring
no bring those into back compat I would
love to see like a a small influx of
backup Pat in the short term you know
but shout out to Jason Ronald and the
team you know execute some of those get
some FPS boosts going maybe you do them
in waves because there's a lot of you
know stuff in the in the backlog
um I want the round table situation you
know with ABK leadership and whoever's
going to be there would feel like the
same way they did was in the max when
they had you know Todd did they had you
know behinds in the crew what does it
mean how does things go forward
um there's some joints in the car I want
to see how they handle remember DJ Hero
Guitar Hero that kind of stuff we see
what goes into that
um how quickly you know the old Call of
Duty's going to Game Pass we're seeing
the engagement right now of all the all
the old cards coming up
um this this part though I got to be
real and King I don't know how you feel
about it but it involves your name you
know we got to talk about the king part
and I do think there's going to be a
transition that a lot of people have to
get ready for Microsoft did also do this
for mobile expect a mobile push now some
people ain't gonna like if they see a
Candy Crush ad in the director you don't
say oh and the Showcase that's gonna
happen I think it's going to happen we
have to be listen we are the hardcore
but me and addict always talk about
there is a Subs there's that the
majority are playing specific games that
maybe the hardcore does not play and
Microsoft now has a strong foothold that
they are going to flex and try to push
mobile we also don't Call of Duty has
mobile there's a Call of Duty mobile
version you know get ready for the Candy
Crush get ready there's going there so I
want to be realistic and to think that's
going to be part of this book so when
they do these shows yeah we have so so
far that these shows comprise of a
couple of different sectors right uh you
have the game pass you have the games of
service and then you have Xbox uh proper
and then I think they extend that over
to Mobile so I think there'll be a
four-prong attack going in like you said
it'd be mobile for those segment of that
crowd right it'll be at the game pass
segment for that crowd right there'll be
new announcements for Xbox and games
that will be going to other consoles as
far as like you know whatever you know
games or service and then the games of
service section will take up a large
amount too so I mean it's only you know
but you know High Court game is going to
be like that when they see that in the
show the hardcore game is full of s
right
I gotta say that because
you got people that's trying to tell you
because my son
he he read something he read somebody
say uh I don't play games right and he
looked over at me he was like
that that when was your first console
when did you get outside when I was
eight years old and
he said well when did you stop playing
and I said never well you know and he
said well what makes a real gamer
um and I said well listen son you got to
think about it this way when I had
nothing but time like you have nothing
but time I just asked you to go to
school do the best but you have nothing
but time you can play games all day I
said but you see my schedule so my
schedule breaks down and I gotta carve
out a certain amount of time to play
video games actually so my mobile aspect
will go higher like he sees me playing
my mobile games all day long and then
when I do get home I get a chance to
play my um console games right but
is curiosity in that question because it
is ignorance that lies in that question
there's no such thing as a hardcore
gamer and a softcore gamer it's just
gamer and these people want to validate
themselves by oh I achieved this much in
my lifetime and I've done this much in
my video game lifetime what happened to
the gray bids and the old heads that
were in the arcades that was playing way
before you even thought about it when
there was no achievements or when we did
have the the Sega Genesis or the master
systems uh uh um and consoles like that
Super Nintendo where there was no
achievement you know I can shame you for
not knowing what blowing in a cartridge
is but this this
idiotic mentality that you're a hardcore
gamer just because you can do a jump and
a spin in Demon Souls that uh somebody
else didn't achieve that uh that little
badge or whatever that little gold or
trophy that you got
um that doesn't make you a hardcore
gamer it just makes you a gamer at this
time your pockets right I could talk
about uh pocket watch uh those game
pockets it's just different things that
uh categorize you as a gamer so we're
not gonna shame somebody that can only
have time like the CEO of a billion
trillion dollar company that can only
play Candy Crush on his phone you're
gonna try to shame him for living life
but having time to game just because you
can sit there and play God of War from
beginning to the end but his schedule
doesn't dictate that but he lives and
dies on candy crush on his phone you're
not a hardcore gamer for that you just
have different priorities in life B
better talk we'll talk you got to get it
together your game we're all Gamers real
talk real talk I respect what you say
respect for the ogs you know what I'm
saying because at the end of the day you
know we from that era you know I'm
saying we're from that eraway it was the
arcade it was you know three lives no
continues and that was it you know what
I'm saying there wasn't no one keeping
track of my colleague Vision Genesis
Sega 3dos and all that so I understand
that's just a form of Separation because
let's just be real
a lot of this is masked by a subset of
people who are seething about this deal
they're seething that Xbox can be
competitive and seething that now it's
going to be they're used to Xbox being
the butt of the jokes yep and they don't
like a competitive Xbox they want Xbox
to fail and a lot of them look don't get
me wrong there are some people who
legitimately have a concern for the
industry and consolidation I'm not going
to invalidate that but there are some
people who are masking that that concern
and overblowing it because they just
don't like what color jersey it is
because when it's day Jersey they good
with all exclusive they're good with
someone using their Market power to to
isolate and get Xbox out of there you
see what I'm saying let's just keep it a
Bill Buck so a lot of that is just
emotionality and now you got all this
trying to invalidate people for liking a
platform but here's the thing we've been
there and I've shot up being around had
this conversation
for a lot of people who don't understand
why Xbox
we've been there when I even said yo I
don't know myself making a console I
don't know how I feel about that don't
they make Windows right I was there when
it's like okay wow hard drive in the Box
ethernet in the Box wow King I saw
addict we from the era where we met each
other we came to my house right but now
Xbox is allowing us to yo we marry
everyone's you know what I'm saying
separate we could be on Xbox Live play
games together that's Revolution they've
done things that were trans
transformative in the industry we all
remember Halo what it did systematic all
that stuff and then let's not forget the
360 era right and I want to shout out
actually he actually made a good point
you know saying on a constellation we
just haven't call him and that's what
people forget the 360 was a dominant era
they had they had the Zeitgeist and you
can say PlayStation caught up in the end
that's fine but you can't say 360 didn't
have the zitax you can't say 360 was the
formative years for a lot of a
generation of Xbox fans that love to see
that console all the IPS so that's what
people remember and then when the Xbox
One era comes out we see the shift and
we see that yo are they even taking
gaming seriously so it's not about just
cheering on a corporation if you like
this platform if you've been there from
day one you want to see the commitment
that they're serious to gaming investing
in yourself is commitment investing in
studios and things to feed this model
that is Game Pass that you have shifted
to is part of the mission so of course
people are going to be happy there are
people legitimately happy but to sit
there because you don't like a platform
and then try to make it seem like it's
all about care the industry stop because
a lot of it a lot of people are being
exposed even government officials are
being exposed for their bias so let's
just keep it a buck that's why people
are excited because people who've been
there from the 360 area the Xbox OG era
they want to see success and commitment
that it's just no side project from
Microsoft as a whole and that's why
again Phil Spence is beloved that's why
we see the the reverence people have for
it it's not about worship it's about yo
you like the platform they're showing
investment that's all it is and as far
as the last part I'll just say that um
look they're going to be tacked out
tackful with the mobile stuff they go I
think they're sitting on a gold mine
with Series S Call of Duty consoles I
think that that should be big um you
know 2023 I I said this King you've been
the leader for giving people Faith the
only thing I give myself a little credit
is while I was with you
is that I told people even in the heart
of it I said yo I expect them to have a
great year I've always said that in the
heart of the river I said still even
without ABK I was like they're going to
have and that's what the Showcase showed
they showed that it's more than just the
Halo games of Falls and you see in the
fables you're seeing what compulsion is
doing you're seeing what nxl is doing
you're seeing this that also leads to
what Phil said right ABK isn't the
end-o-b or ABP is accelerant to our
overall uh gold exactly and that's what
it is and people are happy because
there's a lot there's a lot of people we
got to keep in the book that one Xbox
out of here we just got to call it true
I mean but yeah listen I I can keep it
above I can keep it real just the same
way you want Xbox out of here I want
that PlayStation
no no no no no you know because but
dudes don't I own it though I don't feel
like I own it when they ask me oh you
know you wanted to die yeah I do so what
like I seen them kill off mad stuff I've
been on the Forefront this is the first
I'm in any see Guy like I'm a turbo
Graphics dude I've watched consoles come
and I watch the consoles go so nobody
cared for my tears as the kid to watch
Sega disappear like after the Dreamcast
what no more oh when turbo Graphics when
I brought the super Graphics of 500 back
in the days and they only made three
games like so when that stuff happens
and you tell me oh yeah PlayStation we
need them around I don't care if they
stick around
you find out and they messed around and
they found out and I am so happy that
I'm back in the dude with the bigger
wallet I picked the book in the gym and
he and he got the right guy to control
them it is over for you and I don't care
if you feel oh king that's not how
gaming should be you should be nice and
I should not be nice you have that
energy for me I want that energy for you
you on your offer I feel you with that's
where you at yes
all I'm saying is regardless to what
with a deal like this happens it's a
benefit to consumers right and it makes
more people access something that they
didn't have access to and then at the
end of the day the third place entity
right is now going to be competitive
with the first place entity thus pushing
the first place entity from the Sony
that we know that would make the soul
calms it had the wipeouts that had
multiplayer Lobster to do what they that
ultimately makes them in the mix and
that's better for consumers so again I'm
not buying or look we understand there's
going to be management I'm not going to
say that neither they got a lot of work
to do with the management so I'm not
saying that but I'm seeing a lot of this
disingenuous concern that they care
about the industry but when things were
going the other way and Xbox was about
to be completely isolated there was none
of this caring about the industry talk
and exclusive talks today they have
money hiding stuff there was none of
this caring about a platform so let's
stop with that narrative and including a
boycott Square
Final Fantasy on Xbox
but the thing that kills me look at the
name they talk about all consolidations
evil right okay fine you associate even
though consolidics are happening in
multiple Industries all over the world
but you don't want Microsoft have okay
I've been in the industry exactly look
at the names of the company solve
Bandai Namco no yup square Square Enix
wake up it's it's already yeah
hold up the the craziest thing is
Microsoft is buying a Consolidated
company
it's so funny when it don't go to they
Jersey that's the thing that I cannot
stand is fraudulent concern there's some
people yes but there's a lot of people
stop it I honestly I don't even believe
I don't even believe like the the
soapbox guy what you would think that
it's a it's a real
concerned for Blockbuster yeah
you know it's just the fact that even
even the people that you would think
okay you have a legitimate concern
no if when you really look at it Destin
pointed this out and it's very true this
is the way of things it is the circle of
life this is what happens some other
company
will grow because of the space that's
now created by Activision Blizzard
becoming part of Microsoft and they one
day will grow into some an entity the
size of an Activision Blizzard it is
just the nature of things so to say that
this is the end-all be-all it may be the
end-all be-all for what you know what
you you what you know the game industry
to be as you like it to be right as
opposed to not wanting it to evolve into
something else and to me it is about
defending the status quo
because that's what you know and again
you go back to it it's not your jersey
yeah so you're defending the status quo
because your jersey indicates that
that's that that's what has worked right
and now it's just not and now it's not
the same now you now the great thing
about it is this creates a space where
both things can work both things can
work because people think about you you
think about ABK going into Microsoft yes
call Cod is is this humongous thing uh
Diablo is potentially a humongous thing
then you have uh the king stuff and the
mobile stuff but the fact of the matter
is all those other IP we talked about
the smaller IP they've been dormant yeah
that's what allows yeah that's what
really is going to build up game pass
because we could talk about the first
party triple A 200 million dollar games
what we want at the end of the day the
middle ground still exists because of
Game Pass right PlayStation doesn't
support the middle ground the BT or game
anymore that's not that's not the that's
not the image they portrayed the ID at
Xbox no I know I missed it completely I
didn't see any of that yeah but all of
that you think about ID at Xbox all of
that exists and has a place because of
something like Game Pass so it's funny
because Japanese talk about this a lot
he says the the creativity that exists
right and and the space that exists that
used to be where the thqs used to live
and all that stuff and now we see look
if you look at if you look at embracer
right them them trying to release those
types of games right Gollum
notwithstanding because that was just a
very very poor game but those middle of
the road games that are still great
there's no place for them because
they're being subsumed by everybody
waiting for the next 200 million dollar
Blockbuster the funny thing if you look
at like the perspective remember when
much
the funny thing is the only reason
people are mad is because Sony keeps
getting outbid remember Warner Brothers
Sony's rumor to be a bitter there better
be uh on the blizzard act Sony wants
these Studios too
it's like it just at the end of the day
yeah I I hate for them it's like you
know people say you you camping for a
two million a two trillion dollar
company and you know Captain for a
billion dollar company so like it's it's
Sticks and Stones
you just got a cap for a pretty girl
I just find it like they say like what
Paris said I don't want anyone buying
stuff I I generally feel that from him
but when you look at people talking
about PlayStation reacting what are they
always saying they got to buy a take two
they gotta buy a Square Enix oh so
you're okay if they buy stuff
because but you look at the mortality of
your console right this this is the this
is the real fact the real fact I gotta
go guys I'm having stuff happen over
here okay all right the real fact is
Microsoft has the ability to stay afloat
right regardless to whatever the
turbulence is in the market and they're
able to uh purchase other entities to
keep them afloat and to keep Game Pass
being what game pass is Right Sony
doesn't have that same viable option so
they must do the tactics now you're
looking at it saying that okay they
can't keep up because now Microsoft has
acquired this this bigger entities and
they're going going to start flooding
Game Pass to the point that now it's not
uh for what is it shovelware it's not
broken games go there to die now it's
going to have uh viable games inside
right and it's going to be uh
sustainable as far as a product they're
made of an official product now
how does Sony compete yes we start
looking at the sustainability of your
console and then when your console comes
out and the financials come out because
this thing showed us the financials on
the consoles that you're only 15 of
what's actually going on right now you
see it's not sustainable and what Phil
was saying with single party uh uh story
driven games how they are looking like
the way of the dinosaur he was talking
about the overall at the market you
thought he was just talking about Xbox
itself no they all have the vitals of
everybody then they get a chance to see
them so no it's they're going to partner
with somebody too they have to become
viable or they will fade away they just
finished talking about how games take
six years to make now and we and you
know again redacted documents yeah Last
of Us calls how much to make
250 million or something like that like
yeah it was kind of crazy it's it's
Bonkers it's Bonkers so the thing about
it is is like Xbox doing this
overall creates space for all games to
exist in in in the industry in a way
that was going away in a way that was
slowly slowly diminishing and dying and
you know you could say whatever you want
about what you feel I that's why most
most arguments I find to be disingenuous
because most arguments do sort of
Whittle down to what platform do you
prefer right as opposed to what's the
trends that's actually going on in
multiple Industries and just what we see
as a reality that's pretty much what I
was saying on that but um yeah that's it
we gotta see how it is though I get it
but they have to they have to show
management they have there's a lot of
responsibility with a lot to do and
they're going to be under the Microsoft
for how things are handled so we will
see big day in gaming that's pretty much
all I got on patreon question was is
there a game I think we said this is
there a game series from dip down anime
that don't that you've missed out did we
say that one growing we didn't we didn't
really get to answer it we kind of
jumped into something else well that was
the first one but the second one from
dip down was kind of on the same range a
game series that you feel you missed out
on growing up that you wish you could go
back and play in King why is your pick
Banjo-Kazooie hashtag stay beefy
my pick Banjo-Kazooie he's messing up
I'm a pig keep messing with you oh okay
I was about to say ill
um no conquers
uh I something that I missed out on I
didn't miss out on anything like to be
honest with you um we were living in an
age where if we were in bootlegging and
things we had a preflow of games all
over the place we us never missed out on
anything all right so and I know you're
looking at our game of score whatever
the hell that you're looking at it but
trust me we played everything a lot of
those games were played offline
[Laughter]
I would change your question for us like
because I think that question is better
post to attic yeah right but uh what I
would like to come back and I know it's
coming back is Quake I want a real
hardcore Quake to to hit the market and
to do what Quake did when it first
launched you know and I know that's hard
in this day and age because it was the
first polygonal uh uh you know um
shooter killer uh def mode game
I think
oh no torok
um give me the tour Rock okay you know
what because I'm thinking about first
person shooters and what really changed
my brain
torok on that Nintendo 64.
was I think that was showed me but you
know beside GoldenEye that Shooters and
that was an adventure shooter that was
different you know we had the the AI
with the uh with the Dinosaurs I think
that's when Nintendo 64 was coming into
their stride yeah give me a torok an
updated torok for now and not that stuff
that they're trying to do with Dinosaurs
I don't need my dinosaurs having guns on
them I don't need none of that stuff
just just give me a torok game set back
there let's start making these Action
Hero games back again solve the game
that you want growing up that you wish
to cut back like King says like I I kind
of had my chance to dip my toe into a
lot of stuff yeah maybe not everything
stuck with me necessarily you know so
maybe you know now older maybe give
certain thing games or genres a chance
um I can't really think of any so for me
something I just want to come back then
they didn't really do justice to when
they when it did come back was Thief
came back in 2015 and they just did not
do justice to the original games which
are some of like
the best and earliest uh sort of
examples of the immersive Sim and when
they brought Thief back they kind of
felt like they needed to dumb it down
because they were afraid people wouldn't
you know kind of get the uh the
mechanics so going back to to the core
of thief and really giving me a game
that's all about Stealth all about you
know because there is something to be
said about a game that gives you all the
options right to be able to go but go
through as a ghost or or be able to kill
everybody or pick as you choose but
Thief is really about you being like
just going through as a ghost and trying
to steal what you need to steal and get
out without killing anybody so
yeah that that's what I would want to
see come back that's selfishly yeah for
me I missed out on Chrono Trigger I
never played that so um I would love to
see that come back officially apparently
you know it shall take balances you know
he told me that you know I guess it was
a PC first they said it's horrible they
want to feel romance a lot of people are
gravitating towards sea of stars because
I think there's a lot of synergy there
one of the musicians that did chronic's
music on it and a lot of chrome trick
accessibilities you got that another one
that I want back that y'all remember you
and King Face the original I want cake
oh my God yeah I want Kane I want I want
that energy to come back with the way he
would narrate the voice that was the
first time I heard like really voice
vampire voice dialogue in a game
throughout his thoughts while he's
killing and murdering and doing awesome
that first game is so good so good that
that's what made my PlayStation sing yes
because it was like you really see them
use voice in a game shows you the power
of a CD then you're like yo that's crazy
so yeah that's for me
um I'll just we could just combine these
things get up out of here with the halo
drawings with the SSD yeah argue with
that hang on that's his deal well the
thing about the SSD is they lied yeah
you know um we we now know that they
lied I had developers telling me that
they was lying and you know um that was
the last Bastion for you dudes you do
just holding on talking about now the
SSD is the only way this is possible oh
yeah it's a lie it's a trick it's a
marketing tactic
um and it's okay it's okay that you know
PC dudes to get a chance to play Ratchet
and Clank which is a really good game I
think it's a really good game I'm
playing more of it right now on my
PlayStation 5 and I'm a ratchet and
click dude I love it but uh to just like
prop up the SSD y'all dudes didn't even
know what the SSD was doing I said it
was going to facilitate Graphics right
y'all know now that it's nothing special
and you know it's now they have to do
with what the console can do so now I'm
just I'm just happy that it came out and
I'm just really more happy that
PlayStation I mean on PC dudes get a
chance to play Ratchet and Clank and if
you have a regular hard drive you can
get them yeah it's just it's just sad
that the first the first couple of weeks
is going to just be about smoking and
improving that PlayStation stuff wrong
so uh but yeah it's a great game it's a
great game I still haven't finished it I
played more of it uh
but yeah man it's it's a great game I
hate when they do stuff like this and
Mar the messaging around the game with
foolishness and whatever play the game
yep I agree last thing I'll combine the
topic as well was the Halo rumor
apparently there's someone on Twitter
Haley era I don't know the validity of
this person so I'm just pulling out the
news breaking Halo news in reference to
saying that the next Halo game will be
the last Halo game if it doesn't meet
expectations next Halo game did not meet
half the but will not meet half the
budget that Halo infinite so imply that
the next Halo games budget will be
smaller they said internally Halo is
officially no longer considered the
flagship and that decision has been made
somewhere in the past five months and
they're going to have some more ideas
about you know the culture of 343 what's
going on and uh everything else so
passionate Halo fan I don't know the
validity itself some people think there
is some ability to The Source in the
past and the only thing I will say in
reference was I can't pronounce his last
name
whatever Halo seniors Community manager
at 343 interestingly kind of quote
responding not quote treated but said
quote with this breaking Halo news and
follow it up with wild declarations
let's see who got the best theories and
conspiracies so a little bit of a shot
kind of back right around the same
timing of of the initial tweet
um you know what's your thoughts about
solve about like Halo potentially not
being the flagship anymore and that the
next Halo game would get half the budget
you know if if those rumors are to be
believed
I mean I don't know about the semantics
about budgets and what that means but I
don't know if you guys remember before
infinite came out
one of the criticisms I had was like it
don't feel like they're treating this
game like like
the Halo that we all know and love from
you know Halo one through three reach
um you know ODST and stuff like that it
just felt like it was different and
when I look at 343's efforts right I
think three four three is efforts
it felt like in their mind it was still
that Flagship game because I felt like
graphically they tried to do some pretty
amazing things whether people liked it
or not you know it kind of feels like
like people didn't like it like it went
in the direction of like a Michael Bay
Transformers like they didn't just like
the book and and
but I thought it was you know kind of
moving forward made you know the armor
looks sleeker the sort of the enemies
look different I thought in terms of
Graphics I was like okay if they're
gonna start keeping up with again when
the comparisons start being made to what
a Sony first party title looks like I
was like okay they keeping up with the
Joneses in that regard that's what it
needs to be because that's just people's
perception of what it should be right
and then the multiplayer stuff sort of
didn't hit not hit the single player
stuff Halo 5 didn't hit and all of a
sudden now the cachet that the that the
that Halo has kind of falls to the
Wayside a little bit so for me I kind of
did feel like internally they it wasn't
the same like the love wasn't the same
and I wasn't quite sure what they were
going to do to fix it and going into
Infinite I was like damn I don't know
what they're gonna do to fix it I wasn't
necessarily the biggest fan of going to
the old school look but then when I
heard free to play for the multiplayer I
was like okay in the world that we live
in free to play multiplayer Halo puts it
in a position where it's competing with
the fortnite fights and the in the war
zones and stuff like that I was okay
Halo's going to be big again that's
where it needs to thrive forget about
how it looks right it doesn't it doesn't
need to be on that level comparison to
like you know Uncharted or the last of
us or whatever the case may be so it's
just it's it's it's Flagship but it's
different it's perceived differently
um
but now I really don't know I really
don't know because again
that game came out
and what they gave us had it just been
that and there weren't Promises of
anything else that was a great Halo game
that was that was a great Halo game I
wasn't I was a fan of what I did in the
campaign overall how it how it finished
out I wasn't super happy with
um it wasn't the greatest campaign for
me in that regard in terms of how the
story resolved but
gameplay wise and the multiplayer Suite
was there it was just that
the bad taste in people's mouths is
because the the the promise of what it
was supposed to be right
did not meet expectations and I you know
we have to differentiate that people
keep saying Halo is the worst and it's
like no that was a great Halo it just
didn't live up to the expectation of
what they promised it to be yeah the
live service standpoint they just did
not live up to that
um so to me
and looking forward it's like well if
you eliminate all this live service
stuff now right we don't know that they
are but if you do that then yeah just
make a great Halo game with a great
campaign that people are happy with with
big bombastic moments Master Chief at
the center of it some heart-wrenching
story and then give me a great
multiplayer Suite right if you if you if
you're not thinking about making this a
live game in any way shape or form and
King mentioned the Battle Royale stuff
yeah dip your toe in other aspects of of
multiplayer that are going to you know
bring different players into the fold
and keep doing that
um I don't at this point Halo's been
around so long it's hard to to have the
expectation for it to still be the
number one thing
um it's kind of difficult I know
Nintendo's done it with Mario but if you
look at PlayStation PlayStations you
know front man has changed every
generation and then you look at the PS4
generation they've had multiple front
men so it's not about you know putting
that much weight on Master Chief and
every single Halo game in a world where
the arena shooter has taken a back seat
to the Battle Royale and sort of the
larger base sort of uh it's it's
different Arena assume is just different
it's a time and place thing and unless
you evolve that and that's what you want
to do to Halo uh probably at your own
Peril because the fan base is going to
want something else
um except Halo for what it is make it
great within that realm and you'll be
happy the fans will be happy
um and maybe again with the other things
that you do you can grow That Base a
little bit I don't I think it's fine
that it doesn't have to be
the the number one thing anymore just
make it great make it great and and and
organically it could become that again
right but stop trying to put that weight
on it anymore it's a 20 plus year
franchise I know Nintendo's managed to
do it with Mario and stuff like that and
Zelda again hey it doesn't always work
out that way right just keep making just
have people that love it that care for
it that want to put out great products
and the fans will be fine and you'll be
fine now if internally that means that
hey
we the numbers that we want for this
aren't where it needs to be that's a you
problem if you give me a great product
I'm going to be happy no matter what it
is no matter what the scope is whatever
no matter what it is it doesn't need to
be that anymore and that's fine if you
could get there great have it happen
organically don't force that on it fair
enough King thoughts um I I thought that
the Halo infinite campaign was fantastic
um of course uh the next Halo is not
going to be half the budget of the last
Halo the reason why that budget was so
inflated was because they were spinning
their wheels doing different things they
jump from uh one engine to the next
engine uh they had a different staff
come in and do this uh they went from
games of a single play driven story
driven game to a game of service so
there was a lot of fluff being uh money
being funneled there because they had to
get a product out because it was
launching a console and I think we're at
an age now where we have outgrown Halo
okay uh
as far as technical technically Advanced
console gamers
the reason why Nintendo is able to do it
is detect is still staying pretty close
basically
behind right so what they have to do is
they have to be creative within their
space I think we are prisoners of the
technology so when we get a technology
and we're able to do something and they
say well you know we can do games as a
service you won't hit Nintendo say oh
let's do games of a service because the
platform really doesn't lend to that
aspect of it maybe the next platform
would do so exactly and they'll be able
to do games of service but right now
they must make these games uh focused
like you know Zelda has to be focused on
this we have to do this I think the tech
dictates where we go with it right
that's the reason why you know it's like
Sovereign said they have multiple front
men that was on the PlayStation 4 uh the
same thing with the PlayStation 5. uh
God of War made a Resurgence if that
didn't hit if if people didn't like the
that that God of War right which what I
look it looks just like Gears of War
with a different mechanic but
if they didn't like it and it didn't hit
then y'all would be having the same
conversation right what what Halo tried
to do
and I think they missed this part the
game's a service part we just promised
that yeah the single player will have
extra stuff
we're still waiting for that that's
where you dropped the ball for me right
because I don't care about the
multiplayer aspect
I really have a game in fortnite that is
probably pretty much all that I want in
a shooter in in a uh you know a battle
royale or Arena they have so much there
that I really don't need your offering
because if your offering doesn't equal
what's in the market or surpass it then
you should not bring that offering to
the market right because it's only going
to be viewed as subpar regardless so we
started off with a great campaign and
story and the multiplayer was great for
its time you have to evolve that formula
if you want to be uh like taking you
know seriously Apex Legends came out saw
fortnite saw Pub G and they had to
compete I don't think that uh Halo's
campaign competed with what was the best
in the market I think Halo's campaign
competed with what they previously did
and they were dancing in the mirror to
their self so when you do that you come
out with that game that's better than
the other games that they put out but
that's better than what's in the market
so
yes I I don't think it's um
it's not the flagship I think those
words are wrong okay Master Chief will
always be the face of Xbox whether you
like it or not Max the chief will always
be the face of Xbox what it is is we
want a different direction for how you
use his brand right you know Halo Wars
you should have really went deeper on
Halo Wars you you really ODST why don't
we have a ODST two and three and four
why are we not digging deeper into the
Realms of this why don't we have a final
fantasy type RPG with uh Halo characters
you know the worlds are so rich why do
we have to keep doing first-person
shooters in something that Halo has
surpassed the video game genre and has
made it to movies it has made it to
Media to books and made it to comic
books why are we just limiting ourselves
to the first person shooter when it
comes to this icon Mario didn't do it
Mario got Mario rabbits you know America
has Mario Kart Mario does many different
things this is the reason why Mario is
still viable to this day good point you
have to diversify your brand or you will
die and this is what I'm seeing so maybe
that was the fight within 343 we want to
diversify and change and then you have
people that say well this was the
consistent and this is what the fan base
expects stop listening to the children
telling you what they want to eat you
give them what they want to eat and
trust me they'll love it you can't have
the fan base tell you what's a good Halo
game you make a good game and a fan base
will tell you if it's good you know I
see Forte came through the back door
what's going on man you got news what's
going on
you man yeah oh man big day we got 12
hours 12 hours big day 12 hours a lot of
news a lot of a lot of knees and Deals
and and then now you know hello there
ain't no PlayStation stuff we good we
talked about this no no no no
PlayStations all the way over there man
all right all right
it's in the bushes for the week
so Forte real quick you know you thought
on obviously you deal with your missed
out on and then obviously the Halo
situation which we talk about now with
the rumors about Halo not being the
flagship but just your thoughts on
remember the breaking news obviously
that PlayStation signs the deal for uh
10 years with Xbox recorded oh man let's
listen man all all rivers run dry at
some point in some of these River ran
completely dry when FTC got dog walked
on the last over the weekend so
so I mean what do you what do you expect
I mean listen I always tell people like
what do you expect Sony to do there I
mean Microsoft came out offered them the
deal Jim Ryan said okay we'll put that
in their back pocket and hope Phil
Spencer doesn't try to renege on it or
anything like that and they make they
made a calculated decision to say we're
going to fight this to the end and the
end was two days ago and now you finally
see just like you saw with the CMA they
came to the table because they was like
yo we ain't gonna be in these streets by
ourselves we ain't we ain't that type of
Lady they did the same thing happened
with Jim Wright and that was first thing
when do you see business conducted on a
Sunday on a Sunday yeah it's a wrap bro
so so you know a lot of uh a lot of
things basically just came to fruition
over the course of the last 24 hours
um
it's a great day for Xbox it's a great
day for people that support the Xbox you
know shout out to King for always
holding that square because there was a
lot of people and I felt King when he
said I don't I didn't know how many of
y'all was gonna be out there with me you
know he was the only person that was
willing to like state claim to it and
consistently say that continuously and
can nobody else say that you know uh so
support So support is real on that one
and I really really appreciate uh all of
the banter on it because it's it's great
you know being a person that sits and
looks at it from the outside I'm finally
glad that this is almost over so we can
get back to some normalcy when it comes
to gaming again but
yeah man it was a great day you get to
see we finally got a chance to see Xbox
win something
that's the thing because I feel like a
lot of people felt like you know if the
conversation was can Xbox grow Can
Microsoft grow anymore just because
you're a trillion dollar company
does that mean that it's over for you
can you not invest in yourself in
investing your platform to make them
better and that's the biggest thing that
I took from all of it it's basically
that over the course of the last six
seven years Sadia basically told Phil I
believe in you yeah and not only do I
believe in you I Believe In You by
giving you the checkbook to allow you to
do the things that you need to do down
to the table however long it takes to do
now you know with all that being said
halo yeah let's go oh man let's go ah
okay give us a route
I almost I I truly truly almost believe
everything that I saw
mostly due to the fact that we gotta
okay first of all
most of the people that are really upset
about the way that Halo is right now are
the people that the OG people the people
that remember what Halo used to be facts
and he's right Halo ain't that no more
we keep wanting Halo to be that amazing
thing that you know you got to remember
when Halo came out it was more about how
amazing and how possible it was to put
games like that on a console oh facts
yep so that was that was the beginning
of something that no one ever seen
before and then they one up themselves
by saying this is what multiplayer looks
like on a PC preach and you being able
to do all of these different things with
your friends and everything and then
we're gonna break down borders and tell
you that oh this is how you play across
the the country with your friends and
stuff yes absolutely
that's what that's what Halo was and we
don't have that type of we don't have
those backgrounds to kind of fall on
anymore to kind of keep that
conversation like what's the new thing
Halo did like to be honest with you
2007 that was kind of it for Halo
honestly you know Halo Modern Warfare
Call of Duty 4 came out yeah the player
base split I ain't gonna lie I was one
of the first people I put like well over
a thousand hours in Call of Duty oh yeah
I was out that's what I was calling
nobody no Halo 3 came out to finish the
fight in 2007 that was like that was
kind of the last year that you can't you
honestly can say that Halo went blow for
blow yeah yeah I agree with easy major
first party uh first person shooter and
then that's when the kind that's when
Bungie made their decision to say that
we kind of don't want to do this no more
and then they got they got those two
extra games out of them which I believe
are probably some of the best games that
people don't even realize reaches is up
there
but that's kind of where it kind of it
fell apart for Halo a little bit and we
just got to remember that yes it's Halo
a name but in essence it's not the same
game exactly it's not it's not the same
game it's not what people
like when we see Master Chief like story
wise it's not the same we didn't really
expand on the expected Universe of Halo
which all the stuff with the books and
stuff that they actually built on
we didn't get conclusions to stuff that
343 even did with Halo 5 and everything
so it's like a lot of retconning going
on and they don't really truly know what
they want to do with the franchise and
just like Saul said earlier
yeah it's not the face of Xbox no more
because I feel like Master Chief will
always be that face but Halo itself
isn't that face because they treat it
they treated that game over the last
three years like something that you know
we just need to get this out like we did
yo Halo didn't release with the series X
in launch time right it was a year later
which they needed to do because it
wasn't ready
but yeah it wasn't ready shout out to
state for actually getting it out the
door and then you know and God you know
me you know us I'm very selective in the
games I play because I know what I like
and I know what I want to play I beat
the Halo Halo infinite campaign enjoyed
it a lot played the multiplayer well
over almost five six hundred hours loved
it a lot but then it fell apart yeah
long seasons and stuff like that so it
just it's ultimately I'm not gonna say
Halo's done but I always said that Halo
needs to be put on the back burner and
the best thing that these Acquisitions
have done is giving Xbox a reason to do
it I feel that we you got you got Call
of Duty you got Starfield and Bethesda
you got the you got the plan with all of
the games like Fallout and everything
that's coming in the future you got the
new mm the MMO from um ESO you don't
have an announced here but they're
talking about right so there's a lot of
games and a lot of
um
a lot of things on the horizon for Xbox
which is great Halo just needs to go
away for a while and they need to bring
it back and find what the new identity
is and and unfortunately it's not really
for us
now if they could they could really fit
themselves great but I always and I tell
I told you this before car I felt like
Destiny was the perfect Evolution to
what Halo was
and that's why people played it as much
as they do to this day because it
reminds them of the old way of how that
game played with great gun play but a
flare of whatever new you could bring to
that type of genre to wear an arena
shooter okay and Halo hasn't hasn't
gotten to that yet so I'm hoping and
praying that they finally
do something with it I just feel like
overall a lot of people are just hoping
for something that just isn't there and
they honestly need to just get away from
Halo infinite and they need to do
something new but they don't need to do
it right away they need to focus on
other IPS get other stuff out the door
and then once we get to a a stable place
where Halo then we can begin building
Halo back up to what it used to be yeah
I feel that I mean I'll jump in quickly
um
look I don't I mean shout out to chat
they're going in on the source they're
like this chick you know whatever proven
to be no
[Music]
be wrong I don't know you know I'm not
here to to debate that all I'm saying
let's just I'm just thinking let's just
say everything the source said was true
everything right to me it's like I
really don't have a problem with it
still because part of me is like
we have to be honest from the standpoint
of if they looked at what they thought
infinite was going to be from a
financial investment and they didn't get
back that return then it's going to be a
scale back you know what I'm saying
we've already they've had to come out
forward facing and say hey we still
believe in Halo you don't make
statements like that unless people are
concerned and there is some type of
unrest and then we obviously seen the
departures right we can't ignore the
departures we can't ignore former 343
developers saying what they have said
about it right so we do know as first of
all respectfully as the game is a great
game I want to be I want to put that out
there though I do want to say that the
game is as much as it went through
development issues Craig face the delay
when the thing came and we finally got
that trailer like Forte he was on that
stream with us and we sat there said oh
yo that's it but they showed that
multiplayer trailer we all went
absolutely crazy we've had the most fun
going it was absolutely the story was
solid we I cannot take it with the game
for itself at its core is a great game I
will never take that away the issue is
the name of it is Halo infinite and it's
supposed to be a live service game and
to that part that part failed we cannot
sugar coat that part either you know
what I'm saying so to your point if all
this stuff is to be true right my thing
is what's wrong with it not being the
flagship at the end of the day it's like
we just came off a showcase that showed
the future of Xbox that showed a star
field that showed A Clockwork Revolution
that showed us sons of midnight
playground version of
um Fable that looked absolutely amazing
so hellblade too like we've like they
we're finally in that position that they
are not they are free of burger shake
and fries that they could actually take
time with the next Halo and if it let's
just say let's just say the room is all
true it's half the budget or whatever
whatever you know fine let them take
take some time away reinvent themselves
do what they got to do you know what I
mean and then from there shoot that shot
if it's the quote-unquote last shot for
Halo as a or whatever so my other thing
too is what king said we gotta let let
one we gotta let three four three be
able to do other things too
this is this this is a rich Universe
here where is like King said it best
where's the the turn base where's the
third person nobody showed like there's
so many stories you can tell with other
genres and other people that doesn't
have to necessarily be three four three
so there's still things that they could
do where it's not all the pressure and
that the Halo Universe could still live
on you know what I'm saying so this it's
Rich lore here this stuff that they
could do so I'm not worried about that
and then I am one I want to see what
certain Affinity does and I think
there's a huge opportunity for a little
bit of a shot to arm if they pull off
this war zone slash Battle Royale slash
version of the game so look that's
pretty much what I got I don't know if
this stuff to be true but I'm not
I think it's not a bad thing if the
rumor is true I don't think it's a bad
thing that Halo is not the flagship
anymore when everybody else has come up
from Xbox game studios which doesn't
demand the pressure for Halo to be that
and I don't have a problem with that you
think uh the pressure was put on them to
complete that Halo because the console
launch right absolutely absolutely it
was supposed to be it listen it was on
the artwork was on the box back in the
series X they were playing and remember
at the time PlayStation we looked at
them like yo Halo's about to have a
killer I mean Xbox series is about to
have a killer absolutely speak launching
with that huge shot in the arm they were
expecting that it wasn't ready we know
about the development issues we know the
story you know it is what it is but look
I will say this though you know they got
a shot they're making right shot at the
um Pierre height to the team he's done a
fantastic job with massive collection
let's see what happens you know what I'm
saying but yeah if it's the last one
this will be it but I think I think they
got a chance to to really do something
great sorry
yeah the other day I was watching um
somebody modded Chief into Resident Evil
4 remake yeah
um so she's you know third person over
the shoulder and but they modded them
just not the not the character model
they modeled guns yeah they model like
the whole so literally you can play the
game as Master Chief with Master Chief
quirks and and whatever and
it just made it makes you long for that
for that uh you know that flood game
that we've been asking for that third
person game this is no reason to be that
precious about master chief being like
in King is 100 right all of these other
uh franchises are still around because
they they weren't afraid yes to evolve
and take risks with these characters
what's the worst that can happen the
worst can happen is your fan base
doesn't like it you go back and make one
that they do and that's it like but you
tried right yeah and you keep trying to
this universe the Halo Universe is so
expansive you know you've already seen
what Halo Wars and stuff like that can
do what's the problem you've already
seen that you can have success with a
game that doesn't have Master Chief at
the helm in ODST like there's so much
you could do and it's just like yeah
it's kind of like it's super
close-minded and it's very weird that
this game has to adhere to all of this
and for it to be successful you know but
I think we've we've already sorry for
cutting you off yeah we've already
started to achieve that because I think
they started splintering off those you
know the Big Mac fries in the shake yeah
but you know we have uh Forza but we
have Forza Horizon Verizon right
um we have gears and you know they did
gears and gas tactics
five you know Halo they did uh a Halo
you know uh Halo Wars introduced atriox
let's be real inhaler Wars which is
awesome you got you could build law and
do other stuff with other genres and
other Studios could take a crack
they just they just need to and like you
said they're not under that pressure no
more to to produce you know like I'm
looking for I'm more looking forward to
the new Doom to be honest with you like
this it's just different things that
they're able to do now because they have
more Studios and makes them more
flexible so that it's not so much
reliancy on you know um Halo itself as a
brand I agree so that was your final
touch
Forte I appreciate you brother it's been
a minute
um where can I find people find you
appreciate you coming through on the
work day on this moment you know oh yeah
man first listen man you guys are
amazing I um always appreciate
um just having conversations with you
guys and I'm just talking about I got a
bit on the podcast twice before one week
yeah this is
dungeon
oh I've done it but yeah I'll help you
yeah put a couple drops here and there
in the Lord you know all right exactly
oh yeah yeah great great show as always
love the um part where y'all read like a
million super chats
pull us off today shut up shout out
shout out to the shout out to the
community for coming through shout out
to the 3000 people that was here earlier
and everybody that came through check me
out give me Forte PBS podcast with the
homie slobo back slap yeah he said what
you doing up in here
hey representing that's what we do
shout out to King looking like LeBron
James
[Laughter]
shout out to shout out to the homie and
uh shout out to everybody else man I
really appreciate you guys and um have a
good weekend man enjoy the game
appreciate you brother legendary gaming
Forte passionate game I love the tanks
man always that's one of our that's one
of our day ones man I always been
supportive of us and brother appreciate
you so much man go make sure you
subscribe to the channel and of course
they do DPS podcast make sure you go
check it out every Thursday at what time
are we doing
as soon as last word is over where to
come no doubt DPS podcast stop it anyway
enjoy your Sunday we got super chats
with things to do later guys appreciate
you brother brother no doubt so oh
actually
um that's very true question before I
forgot about that
um
uh snail killer
um hello Lords of beefy country recently
news came out of the last of us to
remaster I think the milking of the
franchise is getting too much when a
simple patch with suffice obviously this
is just speculation of a possible
remaster thoughts
I love uh you know um last of us too
I'm I'm I'm part of the problem
Jim said you would I'll buy the hell out
that game I'm not gonna lie somebody had
tweeted at me or text me or something
the other day and I was like I love Abby
um I don't I don't I don't care to get a
new higher new resolution
let me lose more
nah I'm part of the problem and this is
this is this is a big problem I don't
believe under Sean late and this will
happen I agree
um and when you fall in love and they
probably catch Halo syndrome when you
fall in love with doing the same things
over and over again you're going to
twiddle out the fan base and you're not
going to grow the fan base and you're
going to milk the franchises till
they're no longer viable and when
they're no longer viable and no longer
sustainable what are you going to look
over to you're going to look over to new
stuff and trying to diversify and you're
going to find yourself in a position
where it's not going to work I think
that that resources and everything that
they're using uh shout out to Marlon
Marlon you were right you were dead on I
would love to see a new Mortal storm I
would love to see a little Warhawk I
would love to see a lot of games that
they have back in the days that they're
not putting that investment money into
but at the same time this is business
and they did these uh failed experiments
that didn't go well and now they're
looking over at their their you know the
cash cows and stuff that did bring in
the money and it's only normal and it's
human normalcy to say let me go back and
revisit this so I can fund this next
project so who's to say that that money
from The Last of Us doesn't fund the
next project but here's the problem
when does fatigue set in and if that
game if you do invest into this game
where you don't have to redo all assets
and do all this other stuff you just you
know fix stuff up and it costs a
fraction of the cost but you're trying
to get Triple your return what happens
if you don't get that return and you're
not able to fund the next project so I
think that is a bad way to do business I
always do believe that new Ventures will
yield new money and a new audience so
I'm against it but again I'm part of the
problem because I'm telling you here
you're going to buy it and they know it
they know it solve your thoughts on this
is it too much is it where you're at I
mean like The Last of Us Part One
remaster or remake whatever you call it
um yeah I'm waiting for that to come to
PC
I'm not giving them more money on
Console unless it's a it says you know
it's Last of Us Part three so
um yeah I'm not again
when you look at what they did would go
to sushima yes you could patch this give
it a 60 and right and be done with it
and but I get it I I get it because and
I don't agree with it but I get it you
know last of us has how many Emmy
nominations
the excitement the excitement for what
two can be uh season two is probably
going to be cut up at the two you know
the second game will probably be cut up
into two seasons
giving them time to actually finish part
three or get close to it before they
continue past you know past the point of
wherever they leave off with the show
after the second or third season so I
get the business reasons for it that
game already looked pretty all it needs
is a FPS patch and it should be fine but
I understand the business of it and you
know ultimately you do want them to when
you look at all these games we just talk
about the Red Dead you know possible
remaster and stuff like that right you
want all of these games to be at a
certain level right a certain standard
of quality frame rate Graphics whatever
and have that be something that's the
same across the board because that way
what it does is the people that love it
already can consolidate it into the kind
of this one package and then the people
who haven't who missed it the first time
around
who may not be attracted to it because
of how old it is or whatever now it's
wrapped up in this new package and hey
you could bring new people into the fold
so I get all of the business reasons for
it but in terms of bringing it if this
is just going to be an uprising maybe a
frame rate thing I don't see it needing
to be a brand new game so that was out
seventy dollars so we'll see we'll see
what it actually is yeah but I will say
this though if it is just an upgrade uh
ghost of tsushima like
mark my words that there will be a a re
they will they will do a full sort of
remastering of it at some point that's
happening it's just what it is it's just
what it is whether whether it lands on a
PS5 or not I don't know but
um but obviously that works being done
on a PC version at some point right so
and in a PC version you're gonna see the
ray trace and you're going to see all
this other stuff so yeah I'll wait for
that yeah because that's going to be the
Evergreen version yeah I'm waiting for
that sale for the Remake to the remake
of the part one but yeah I haven't
bought it yet yeah I'm like I'm waiting
until y'all drop that price because I'm
not giving y'all seven dollars for that
but look it's not about me it's the
business the business says God you're
wrong like King said there's more people
like King there's more people that's
will actually buy it and I I come across
that line and I'll make corporate cargo
make a return very briefly I understand
I understand
yeah why you would do that especially
when you have the series going up you
line this thing up right in conjunction
you get people who new audience Jim
likes the multimedia component to it I
get it you know what I'm saying so get
your butt get your bread but I won't be
I'll stay on my moral High Ground okay
okay
significantly reduced yeah yeah I get it
I get it so I'm gonna do the poll on the
end and then you just yeah
all right with the path now clear for
Xbox to acquire ABK and Xbox being on
record to look into more mergers and
acquisitions
what do you think Xbox and X blue should
be the choices oh people hate that
it gets so bad it's funny
stand Pat
ABK and Bethesda are enough manage what
you currently have more efficiently
adequate like that one B
look into another publisher who can be
self-sustainable short weaknesses in
Japan and continue to feed the Game Pass
model yeah [__] likes that one see buy
smaller Studios only to address specific
needs and avoid regulatory scrutiny yeah
or D I don't care Xbox seriously
invested themselves and we held the damn
line shout out to everybody that might
actually win Loki shout out to everybody
in the chat shout out to the legendary
that's the legary shout out to Jess
Corden Rand out Thor Paris Lily gaming
Forte all the people who could and could
not make it Tom Warren whole glow Gene
Paul everybody man what a show what a
show 3K as far as live viewership that
is unbelievable I think we've shattered
every person around and just I want to
shout out to Rome for everybody really
wanting to wait
for us and to hear what we got to say I
think there's a lot of weight to that
that I don't take for granted because
our show goes out at the end of the week
we missed we literally missed the
Zeitgeist we miss everything for the
most part it's rare that we get stuff
like today where Phil drops the bomb
right and it's just like up PlayStation
signs of deal it's whatever but um look
man it's love it's love we appreciate
y'all and I want to say last thing this
is a reference to King and the
characters and stuff like that you know
majority of everybody gets it the
majority gets it they understand that at
the end of the day this is jokes and fun
and none of this is to be weaponized to
take seriously like real war and real
violence and like we y'all know what
this is you know obviously a lot of us
have our platform preferences but at the
same time you know everything is done
with life fun and love and jokes it's
never to really truly separate people I
hope people get that part because that's
the part I do want to stress and look
nobody nobody might do a brother better
than cousin or he does his thing you
know what I'm saying and I just I'm
proud of him I'm proud of the fact that
people can't wait to hear what you got
to say because they know you wear that
green on your chest super strong you
know what I'm saying and it's it's love
that not only that the community but our
peers and those of the industry actually
respect that and it's a celebration it's
reverence it's having fun remember the
key to IOP we celebrate people we give
people Lord names Donovan it's about a
celebration but the end of the day is
all about fun we like playing games
together bringing people together it is
community focused so as long as y'all
get that message that's all it's about
if you're taking this stuff and you turn
twisting it and getting angry and you
really mad and I ain't love podcast
that's something in your heart that you
gotta fix that has nothing to do with
that this is all love it's jokes as
brothers and I love that we bring people
that normally wouldn't even talk to each
other together on this podcast and can
unify so I just had to say that and I
love y'all this was super dope
um I'll show you gonna do super chats
first then out shows but you wouldn't do
so what you want to do yes
we'll finish off with the super chats no
doubt no doubt solve Lord saw with the
marathon the most Super Chat you got to
get an award you gotta get a check for
all this Awards Jesus bro and you know
the the ad reads shout out to me
yo shout out to factor I read the ad
read I was like you it was they outlined
breakfast lunch and dinner like they
broke it down
sometimes you know sometimes I'll just
elaborate on stuff whatever but this
time I read the ad read I'm like oh is
this this much me you know and the whole
rest is this so I'm like oh man this is
gonna be crazy it's like a five minute
ass he's like yeah it's only one today
yeah
listen I I love I knew coming into today
I was like oh man get the tea ready get
the water ready it was going to be just
like you said Kyle like for me
is to see is to see the way the king
rallies the troops yes the thing is
anybody wants to hate on him
the thing that's funny about it is
because the moment the Persona comes off
then it's like okay hold up
things that everything's that he's
saying is is also making a whole lot
yeah because they want to play honestly
the clown stuff anybody wants to clown
and whatever
but you can't turn the man turns around
and then
speaks about the gaming industry in a
way that shows that he knows what the
hell he's talking about he's like oh and
it's like you know if you still want to
hate after that that is on you but you
said it perfectly where it it is this is
this man has been doing this since we've
since we've known him facts and the fact
that it's on this platform now this
stage you get to see what we see yeah I
love it the only the only thing that I
have to laugh at this a little bit but
it's the right thing the only thing is
that
but but
still uh and to see it happen and to see
so many people gravitate to it I mean
for you to get 3 000 live man really to
see
really the Sea King right three thousand
like ready to see King his reactions his
different personas and to see that and
people come in like bro
what is it so we're seven years in now
six seven years in a minute yeah yeah
who would have thought who would have
thought less than 10 in that chain yeah
you arguing why did you show up bro your
son you're supposed to be supporting me
in my dream so yeah yeah so it's a
beautiful thing I don't care if I'm
horse after the show I have to deal with
Lady stop in the morning
repercussions but yeah I mean and it
only it's only getting better like I
said a month and a half will be over in
Seattle uh doing paxy stuff and uh Pax
West stuff excuse me and uh yeah man
upwards and onwards no always the man of
the hour
two unit Soldier
Xbox Soldier you know what I'm saying
Patriot
it's crazy King coleon the general
you know what I'm saying like oh like
this was this was this was history this
was a moment I'm proud of you I love you
you have the right tact in the way you
do things I loved your message that you
put out before
you know just give people the real that
was beautiful
you're one of the funniest people I know
it's just so cool to see your stars
shine where can I find people finding
what you got going on King David first
and foremost I would like to thank
everybody that showed up
um Dustin thing it hits a little bit
different
um because
a lot of a lot of times it throws you
off when people do things that they
don't have to do
he didn't have to show up facts
he didn't have to worry he wore it that
means you put thought yeah you put
thought in in you know a lot of times
you know putting thought and then
respect into something
um is a beautiful thing
um
uh for Tango plays um
I I want to give a shout out to him
um it's without all the other console uh
con content uh creators making videos
about stuff that everyone does and
sharing it out and being in a good
community
we probably won't cross over and and
meet other people so shout out to him
and everybody else that did make videos
even if he clowning us whatever you know
shout out to you guys because we all
participate together
um
shout out to to Jazz shout out to Rand
shout out to Forte shout out to Paris
um
this is is humbling yeah but I put into
the universe and I prayed to God the
other day and I was like um
I need 3 000 in the show wow you put it
I put it
before if you look at Boone show yeah I
said three thousand
and I pray oh
and I said please
you know I don't ask for much I try to
say if y'all see all the stuff y'all
think I'm not humble I I am super humble
but I'm also and it wasn't a 3000 for me
is it 3 000 for the whole team is it 3
000 hold on for everybody here because
just they could tell you they can attest
to when we only had 12 people in the
chat
um and you know sometimes you you say
man why am I doing this for the right
reason what's going on here my only goal
and my goal has always been to make sure
that we get the bag
um
and um and I'm not talking about I'm
just talking about you know the bigger
overall organ thing I don't ever want
them to have to work again like as far
as traditional jobs because we all work
traditionally jobs facts and you know
and we still come here this I don't know
seven hours right now and I don't know
where you can get that from but for all
you guys to show up for all you guys to
change your your your Twitter uh profile
pic to the badge that um Ben donated
Benzino is a phenomenal dude we have so
many great people in this community to
to do that to show solidarity
um this wasn't an Xbox versus
PlayStation thing
this was a celebration in a moment of
History right so if you watch this show
you're going to at some point in time
say I was there I saw that idiot dude
characters
and he did the characters in different
voices and in different styles and he
put thought and he went on he got props
and he was getting dressed behind the
scenes like he was doing a play
and he also came and brought knowledge
to the table
I am humbled by everybody that is here
that is still here I appreciate every
and every anyone that even you know
super chatted but just being there not
even not even the super chassis super
chess is fantastic but just being here
sharing in this moment this is something
that we will always remember and like
you know God and Sovereign
a lot of y'all got to get ready for
Monday the Leisure day facts your time
out and to give us that time
I'm gonna do my best for you this is the
first day
that I had the bubble guts
I was wondering because there's a lot of
pressure on you people like yeah perform
gig dude you better show out king you
better King you better king and you know
what I told I told my wifey when I was
going upstairs like right before I never
have to go to the bathroom before the
show
I gotta go to the bathroom and I'm
walking and I'm thinking I said am I
nervous I forgot what nerves feel like
climbing in a ring fighting somebody
that's when you get the nerves in your
gut you feel it you usually you gotta go
to the bathroom before then then you
fight right and this was an indication
that this meant something to me I spent
more than any other thing that I've done
right so when when I did it I was we had
to switch on the Fly because I didn't
know King coleon was going to come up
first
remember this yeah it was completely
different for the record I don't know we
never talk we talked I never know what
you're going to do yeah so so that but
the thing is we got a added curveball
because Phil drops the news right today
that was not planned I know if mentally
for you you had to Pivot I gotta pivot
the whole show notes and everything else
and then the way things just played out
was just insane but yeah and then saying
that we never get news on a Sunday facts
I'm gonna tell you this and I don't I I
don't care if if it's just my little
tinfoil hat crap going on in my head
I'm the dude that gave him Phil Dominus
Maximus Aurelia Spencer I'm the dude
that's been riding with this dude when
it was at the worst and for that
information to come out right then there
before we go on our show two hours
before whatever
thank you for throwing that bone
if it wasn't you threw that and we
caught it and I was gonna run with it
and I do appreciate it if if it's not
I'm gonna have the chance to ask you
because that's what you're gonna pull up
for the job I'm gonna need to ask that
question did you throw that
because I'm gonna get I'm giving you
credit for the regardless
who did that for you kid who did that
for you yo Phil Dominus Maximus really
expensive
um Satya believed in you I believe in
you and now more troops believe in you
we're not doing soft talk Sundays that's
not gonna happen here our hearts do not
pump Kool-Aid we we're gonna stand in
the world fighting to the better and my
son got a chance to really find out what
the 300 Spartans was and what that story
was and I explained it to him and I
showed it to him and he his eyes got
wide and he and I said Son sometimes
under certain circumstances you're going
to be faced with immense odds
but the measure of the man is going to
be if you're going to stand there and
face those odds head on not knowing if
you're going to win or not knowing if
you're going to lose but knowing that
you stand on your ones and twos and you
keep your best effort I knew that they
was going to give their best efforts so
I had total confidence in their winning
and if they lost I was going down with
them and if they win we was going to
rise together so that was it at the end
of the day and I know y'all saying
console Fanboy stuff but
my heart bleeds green you love your
platform okay this is it this is what it
is you're honest about you loving them
like I said the main thing as long as
you're not slander and others everybody
else for they drink personally and all
that that's
but no that's all I got let's solve
let's get there was a thought and y'all
still here that's insane
um so I was getting these recipe super
chats and if you need help let me know
uh we got let me see one second we got
Raymond Morrell two dollar Super Chat we
will hold the swine the second second
Lieutenant Cognito all right that was
good that was good that was good I like
that one that was good then we have
nobody with the five dollar super chat
now if you want a money maker if your
Xbox bring back Skylanders and the money
they would make would be insane yeah
right
then we got no Bundy two dollar super
chat but why Cog don't keep that energy
for what but why does Cog not keep that
energy for Colin oh you think so listen
Kyle's the homie but very clear we've we
disagree on a lot of that stuff when it
comes to Xbox you know what I mean and
um I've said it before it's just that
again how I say things I'm just not a
demonstrative person when it comes to
debate because I think what happens is
if he feels strongly and I feel strongly
about something and I get passionate and
angry and I'm yelling and he yelling
you're not going to come to an
understanding and I think that's the
problem like I think people want people
to be so emotionally Trump part of
having a debate is listening to
understand why somebody and he the
reason why I don't go is crazy because
there's a part of me that understands
some of his perspective but in the flip
side he has to understand my perspective
which is someone who came from this
ecosystem and why we love it and what I
love that he does last part question is
he asks like yo why do people like like
Xbox like that because he truly does
understand it so when I see questions
like that that's a person trying to get
understanding yeah he may have some
valuable takes that I disagree with but
at the same time being respectful to
have a discussion with someone on a
completely opposing view that's a sign
of maturity so that's not about matching
energy it's just about having an
intelligent discussion with someone that
you on an opposing side that's all
um
we got Lord Starkiller five dollar Super
Chat Xbox was underfunded in the past
not now some folks thought past errors
made by Microsoft Xbox would just
continue that is true
and we have kamex with the two pound
Super Chat Xbox fixing Cod servers for
Game Pass
and we have JD gamer five dollars in the
chat bring back Panzer Dragon Saga RPG
as both a remake and give us the true
RPG sequel that we wanted oh and House
of the Dead yes give me all of that give
me give me give me give me all let's go
then we got GSD AKA getting stuff done
five dollar Super Chat beefy Cog needs
to throw on the cocoa butter and
meditate and mediate a king Colin
interview
Colin [__] [__] some of the same views
yeah
like they just we already spoke like
this isn't it it's no beef like what why
is everyone heavyweight matchups people
want like yo they want that like it's
it's
yeah I I don't I don't get the vitriol
for this guy like I just don't get it no
I do get it I did he has something
political stuff well no no no no no I
got to be fair to the Xbox Community
look he calls the homie he know he says
some stuff that I completely disagree
with like yo that's not it as far as I'm
concerned on the Xbox side of things and
I think that's where the frustrations
lies because again when he's in the
PlayStation ecosystem and he has his
views but I will say this he a lot of it
comes from his view of the long-term
consolidation of the industry right and
I think I think there's some valid
points there like we said here I think
Paris even Paris has some common like
points yeah yeah you know what I'm
saying so again I think that's where the
vitro comes from but I I completely
agree it's a lot of it I feel it's
overblown people just want
[Music]
and last point I'll say a proof of this
don't always have to solve it look what
happened with me and Jackie
if i.com I know everyone in the
community ride it right respect
but I had to do it my way and as a
result look what happened you see what
I'm saying as far as that man being a
man and saying you know what I think I
see what you're coming from I apologize
the way I came in it and who knows what
might happen between him in the future
is we've talked offline but that's what
it is you don't always have to be
disrespectful to someone that completely
disagrees with you that's all yeah
and we have some Jutsu Sage five dollar
Super Chat Cog that Haley person has a
personal Grudge with someone at 343i
they were involved with their lying can
guarantee it 100 it's purely personal I
I got your text message behind the
scenes bro so look I uh to your point I
never said we said this is true we just
said hey hypothetically you know oh my
God I think with a wild face that's
crazy but um no I get your point bro and
you know apparently people debunked it
but I thought it was a good conversation
to have I thought it was still worth
having that conversation but salute to
you stage I know you go hard for fail I
love you bro absolute to you for putting
up those pictures you took of me with
Mark Cerny Corey ballog Sony Executives
because we know picture gate was going
on and I respect you for that bro I love
you he was the first person that wanted
for me to shook my hand when I went to
E3 by myself before I don't know a
podcast existed you know how much I like
to celebrate the creative industry so I
love you you go extra hard on Twitter
sometimes I mean a little extra but I'm
like
[Music]
do y'all think they continue infinite
for the multiplayer and just give us new
campaigns as the new games
oh I don't know I mean it's there and
it's good you just got to build upon it
so I don't know
but the thing is the question is who's
how many people really going to come
back for it right and it's yeah
I think the only one you was out of the
Matrix wow
I just had to do something real quick I
think the only way it works is if they
like relaunch the same game with the
same Cosmetics into the newer game
absolute yeah
and we have Prem krishnil Singh five
dollar Super Chat uh Beulah from uh from
Fiji Lords have a blessed week take care
thank you beautiful
hashtag held the line hashtag pray for
Jimmy
then we have Sage once again five dollar
Super Chat I think we're forgetting that
Halo infinite wrecked both Call of Duty
Vanguard and Battlefield 2042 EA Blame
Halo for how Battlefield did give Halo
its respect and people don't forget the
north always remembers man
we got JD gamer ten dollars make Halo
great again I'm not suggesting that
infinite wasn't uh it was what it was
but the live service has been lacking
let Cod be your live service game just
give me a great Halo every three to five
years now I'd be happy with that
out
yeah definitely definitely pause Jesus
343 has to evolve Halo and leave the
hardcore Halo Community behind the
gunplane infinite is good it just lacked
content and didn't appeal to a younger
gen either of all for new Gamers or
retire it yeah that's why I say you had
the Battle Royale the arena and the
story for a triple trip oh yeah do that
okay exactly you can evolve it you can
evolve it while doing side stuff if
you're still so afraid of evolving the
core game right keep that for the
hardcore and then do all this other
stuff with it yeah
Xbox I need Halo to be Xboxes Mario that
means I want Halo Wars 3 ldst2 Halo RPG
Halo horror with the flood and a Halo
Minecart racer I Want It All what a home
race let's go I'm with you I'm with you
with all that yeah
let me see Brandon C two dollars Super
Chat not sure what sweeter deal closing
or SOB's lips oh
yeah all right I'll take it back that's
worse than anything they said about [__]
beetles we got another one we got
another one
and I told you there's a new demographic
in that crowd
Lois love everybody
and clearly everybody
[Laughter]
thank you for your support
thank you for your patience they didn't
want beefy they didn't want chunky he
was in that man both
he was he liked the way
that's better than Cognito I'm good now
I don't feel it cuz my camera's on now
keep cameras they look at that song
different now what I'm trying to be
extra it's not bad that's the super jump
bro I like that energy y'all that's what
I'm talking about
deflecting like crazy yeah yeah
oh we got uh we
perhaps appropriately
sagging nut sack what he got to say Halo
is a big universe why does it have to be
just about master chief retired Master
Chief and do something else with the
universe yeah what's up with Spartan
lock bro yeah what's up with that lock
series word man let's redeem this redeem
[__] man come on got his helmet running
around what is it racism
then we have Carlos Alvarado Super Chat
600 hours and still playing Halo Pierre
hints is
I don't know what that emoji is Burger
without it it's beefy beef oh maybe that
yeah what is it baby shot a shallow pan
of food okay I don't know what that
pizza's Pizza I don't know oh then we
got Pony up five dollars it was at
wonder why Cold War came to PS plus
before the ruling could have saved a lot
of time if somebody's assigned the deal
instead of kicking and screaming uh
sometimes we like to fight
I'm out there we got sagging nut sack
once again follow Super Chat me
personally I enjoy guardians but also
love Infinite uh the gun play is awesome
my point is gamers are very fickle and
don't know what they want uh and don't
know what they want 343 I should never
have listened to gamers
nope my point exactly
King before I go white versus Joshua
your thoughts
oh okay white uh versus Joshua
that's not son is it signed no wow I
don't I don't I don't think that's
signed but if it's signed I think Joshua
uh under Derrick James right now is
going to be a different level of Fighter
um he's he's in a different Camp he's
not around yes man he's going to be in
top form I know you can't uh Shield a
bad jaw a glass jaw but at the same time
what you're able to do is teach new
techniques Lennox Lewis was with Pepe
Carrera early on in his career and he
got knocked out and he went with
Emmanuel Lewis Yeah a different Beast so
sometimes it's really the trainer and
still in certain levels of confidence
and techniques and character of the of
the fighter and I think Derek James is
that person to get that out of Anthony
Joshua I'll say that
let's play with each other's joysticks
yes stop if you need help I'll deal with
Lady zombie whoa hold on
and then afterwards I can deal with you
a few times
do not know no Adam 22 situation
I've said multiple times there'll be no
cucking here
000 viewers as soon as the podcast began
makes all the hard work worth it much
love respect to the iron Lords thank you
for a piece of that piece of love you
already know we got silent Cypher the
Crescent attack Asylum sign for gifting
five more IOP memberships
and we got Ben samorin with the two uh
two pound Super Chat shout out to King
and the Gang mad love from the UK
King in the gang united king in the game
kicking
then we got Eric Guerrero ten dollars in
the chat just want to show my support
you guys are awesome I love what you
guys do absolutely thank you thank you
we have Vanessa five dollar Super Chat
happy to listen live for once normally
working on Sundays but enjoying some
vacation and IOP you are the best thank
you so much for being awesome thank you
so much thank you so much
then we have dexterous Joe five dollar
Super Chat King and Lord God y'all have
been killing it I'm I'm a recent fan of
IOP can't be happier to find y'all even
as a PlayStation fan I'll say this hold
the line
that's the one who get it
I said well who gets it love y'all got
to explain to me what happened okay
see if we got Tai casares three dollar
Super Chat nah we just want to be
entertained by you both live
my God
then we got GSD getting stuff done five
dollar Super Chat no beef with Colin
he's from my alma mater I just want big
personalities no no doubt no doubt he's
been there he's been back in the room
again
we got Titan 2793 10 super chat big up
to iron Lord's family for sharing the
Lords on a Sunday peace yeah
then we got Jay Primo uh member for 13
months Lord bronze how are you still
going yes I asked myself this every week
there we got big Afroman 14 five dollars
to be chat love IOP you guys quickly
became my favorite podcast in such a
short time love all four of you and each
one of you shine in your own ways on
this pod thank you brother appreciate
that super dope comments then we got
blue five dollar Super Chat I wish you
could get Sean Laden on on from on to
iron Lords ask him some juicy questions
yes I would love to talk to him it's got
a whole conversation for him yeah
absolutely I know about the cool
then we got big Afroman 14 again two
dollar Super Chat yeah no load attic
low-key looking kind of good too dude
yeah we get into some thighs slap in
there
you love them
see where are we here
I'm done we got we got a second that
sack again two persons which they signed
and they're fighting in September
okay thank you um I'll I'll definitely
but I just think that's just a stay busy
fight because they're trying to get him
in a wild at the fight and while they're
just trying to fight Andy Ruiz and
that's I think Andy Ruiz and Waldo
fights and Joshua fights white and then
we have the Anthony Joshua versus
Deontay Wilder that we decided to
finally get man we need that fight yeah
for sure
we got Troy Perry gamer with the three
dollars Super Chat hey on live here it's
9 A.M in Australia Hold the Line
wow this is some crazy lines then we
have NR zic two dollar Super Chat Case
Closed time for Jim to hold the line
like that
okay hold that lying tongue there we go
Tony up two dollar Super Chat haycock
when a sacred symbol slash uh X defining
Duke episode coming up soon I think
maybe yeah Tuesday Colin told me you
guys are recording it Tuesday Yeah
Tuesday Tuesday yeah we're gonna do the
crossover that will be like crossover
end of next week yeah so that'll be
excuse me we are caught up wow all right
attic Sage people think to the people
before we head out because you get your
outro yeah I appreciate uh sorry about
that I had to go pick up Grace but um
sorry about all uh yeah first off shout
out to the realm man we had like 3 500
people we we are ending the podcast with
22 000 views
and that you know you guys drive us you
know I'm sitting here stuttering man I'm
stuttering uh obviously
you guys enjoy it's been six hours of
content
yeah so what I'm gonna do is you know if
you guys like reactions like anime you
guys want to be one of the people to ask
questions I'm going to put the patreon
in the yes description again uh in the
chat so don't look over there hit hit us
up man you know I think the 10 super
chat you can I uh the the ten dollar one
over there you can actually make us
react to something uh so yeah I
appreciate everyone for coming through
here and then you know if you want to if
you want more more addict you know not I
don't know about thigh slapping but you
can go over here and follow me on
YouTube and you know I appreciate
everyone for coming through we had an
absurd show and you know we'll be back
next week I think we should give our
our guests oh wait that's just me but
I'll lay that up to Cog if he wants to I
mean they want to pull right yes it was
like it was like 1200 people voted yeah
so salute should be having the legendary
young Yay hopefully we should not
finalize that the new voice of carry you
and we'll talk about game and all that
good stuff and then there's another
Super Chat song that you gotta read we
got a couple we got two more uh we got
Homeless Bird ten dollars Super Chat
love to the Lords and around been
enjoying the Yakuza series especially
Yakuza Yakuza zero on Xbox series X via
game pass those illegal drama spin-off
judgment has my heart shout out to King
David no doubt Yakuza fans tune in next
Sunday should be good then we got
currently playing King's Choice
yeah yeah what was his name again
currently playing this camera off why
your camera
and then he says King me
you want the domination yeah
yeah you don't remember we have a chess
fan in the building
kill it with fire yeah I think he's a
Checkers fan
yeah that's what we talk about Let It
Burn
we have GSD getting stuff done five
dollar Super Chat No Cap your stream is
turning into oh no yeah
he's crazy
we enjoyed it everybody thank you so
much the realm I came out in force
blessings enjoy your Sunday I appreciate
it appreciate y'all you know what's
funny we've went so long that like
everyone is into our podcast so I'm
sending you guys over there wiping well
completely different show I think
oh we got it too
got something else hold on yeah
we entertainment to us
drop the n-word we address it yeah he
put on a lenty tweet about what oh so
Pastor whatever so we will talk about
that during the history so I'm sending
you guys over there go in there tell
them IOP sent you completely different
show so be prepared for that but I'm
sending you upload a weapon wheel see
you guys no doubt peace peace
[Music]
thank you
really Forte
Gary Forte five dollar super tired y'all
some freaks Mark today the official day
the Xbox Community truly showed out plus
came out the clock
all right
thank you
[Music]